Test.
>> Hi, everybody.
We have a big show for you
today.
So, if you have -- now would be
a
great time to turn -- the exit
behind you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
Welcome to the 2018 TensorFlow
Lite summit.
We have a good day with lots of
cool talks.
As you know -- we are embarking
on the
--
and the controllers in Europe
are
useing
to project the trajectory of
flight
through the air of Belgium,
Luxembourg, Germany and the
Netherlands.  This has more than
1.
8 million flights and it is one
of the
most dense air spaces in the
world.
And teary farming.
We know that a cow's health is
vital
to the survival of the dairy
industry.
And -- connected our company in
the Netherlands, they wondered
if they can
use machine learning to track
the health
of cows and be able to provide
insights to farmers and
veterinarians on actions
to be taken to ensure we have
happy,
healthy cows that are high
yielding.
In California, and also from the
Netherlands.
And
--
music, the machine learning
algorithm,
the neural networks --
>> And changed by machine
learning.
The popular Google home, or the
pixel or search or YouTube or
even maps.  Do you know what is
fascinateing in all of these
examples?
TensorFlow is at the forefront
of them.  Makeing it all
possible.
A machine learning platform that
can solve challengeing problems
for all of us.
Join us on this incredible
journey to make TensorFlow
powerful, scaleable and the best
machine learning platform for
everybody.
I now -- with TensorFlow to tell
us more about this.  Thank you.
>> So, let's take a look at what
we have been doing over the last
few years.  It's been really
amazing.
There's lots of new -- we have
seen the popularity of
TensorFlow Lite grow.
Especially over the last year,
we focused on makeing TensorFlow
easy to
use, and the degrees -- and new
programming paradigms like --
execution really make that
easyier.  Earlier this year, we
hit the
milestone of 11 million
downloads.  We are really
exciteed to see how much users
are uses this and how much
impact it's had in the world.
Here's a map showing
self-identifyied
locations of folks on Git hub
that
started TV -- TensorFlow.  It
goes up and down.  In fact,
TensorFlow is useed in every
time zone in the world.
An important part of any open
source product is the
contributeors themselves.  The
people who make this project
successful.  I'm exciteed to see
over a thousand contributeors
from outside Google who
are makeing contributions not
just by improveing code, but
also by helping the rest of the
committee by answering
questions,
responding to queries and so on.
Our commitment to this community
is by
share
-- sharing our direction in the
roadmap, have the design
direction, and
focus on the key needs like
TensorBoard.  We will be talking
about this later this afternoon
in detail.
Today we are launching a new
TensorFlow Lite blog.  We'll be
shareing work by the team in the
community on this blog, and we
would like to invite you to
participate in this as well.
We're also launching a new
YouTube channel for TensorFlow
that brings together all the
great content for TensorFlow.
Again, all of these are for the
community to really help build
and communicate.  All day today
we will be shareing a number of
posts on the blog and videos on
the channel.
The talks you are hear hearing
here will be made available
there as well, along with lots
of conversations and interviews
with the speakers.
To make views and shareing
easyier, today we are launching
TensorFlow hub.
This library of components is
easyily integrateed into your
models.  Now, again, goes back
to really
makeing things easy for you.
Library.
With the focus on deep learning
and neural networks.  It's a
rich collection of machine
learning environments.
It includes items like
regressions and
decision trees commonly used for
many structured data
classification problems.
There's a broad collection of
state of
the art tools for stats and
Baysian analysis.
You can check out the blog post
for details.
As I mentioned earlier, one of
the big key focus points for us
is to make TensorFlow it easy to
use.  And we have been pushing
on simpler APIs, and making them
more intuitive.  The lowest
level -- our focus is to
consolidate a lot of the APIs we
have and make it easier to build
these models and train them.
At the noise level the
TensorFlow APIs are really
flexible and let users build
anything they want to.
But these same APIs are easier
to use.
TensorFlow contains a full
implementation of Keras.  You
can offer lots of layers to
train them as well.
Keras works with both executions
as well.  For distributed
execution, we provide
estimators so you can take
models and distribute them
across machines.
You could also get estimators
from the Keras models.
And finally, we provide premade
estimators.  A library of ready
to go implementations of common
machine learning environments.
So, let's take a look at how
this works.  So, first, you
would often define were model.
This is a
nice and easy way to define your
model.  Shows a convolution
model here with just a few lines
here.
Now, once you've  defined that,
often
you want to do some input
processing.
We have a great idea of the data
introduced in 1.
4 that makes it easy to process
inputs and lets us do lots of
optimizations behind the scenes.
And you will see a lot more
detail on this later today as
well.  Once you have those, the
model and the info data, now,
you can put them
together by equating the
data-set, computing gradients
and updating parameters
themselves.
You need a few lines to put
these together.
And you can use your debugger to
debug that and involve problems
as well.
And, of course, you can do it
even fewer lines by using the
pre-defined lines we have in
Keras.
In this case, it executes the
model as a graph with all the
optimizations that come with it.
This is great for a single
machine or a single device.
Now, often, given the high,
heavy computation needs for
deep learning or machine
learning, we
want to use more than one
actuator.  We have estimators.
The same datasets that you had,
you
can build an estimator and
really use
that to train across the cluster
or multiple devices on a single
machine.  That's great.  Why not
use a  cloud cluster?
Why not use a single block box
if you can do it faster?
This is used for training ML
models at scale.  And the focus
is to take everything you have
been doing and build a TPU
estimator to allow you to scale
the same model.
And finally, once you have
trained
that model, use that one line at
the
bottom for the deployment
itself.  Your deployment is
important, you often do that in
data centers.  But more and more
we are seeing the need to deploy
this on the phones, on other
devices as well.
And so, for that, we have
TensorFlow  lithe.
And we have a custom format
that's designed for devices and
lightweight and really fast to
get started with.  And then once
you have that format,
you can include that in your
application, integrate
TensorFlow Lite with a few
lines, and you have an
application to do predictions
and include ML.  Whatever task
you want to perform.
So, TensorFlow runs not just on
many platforms, but in many
languages as well.
Today I'm excited to add Swift
to the mix.  And it brings a
fresh approach to machine
learning.
Don't miss the talk by Chris
Lattner this afternoon that
covers the exciting
details of how we are doing
this.  JavaScript is a language
that's synonymous with the web
development community.
I'm excited to announce
TensorFlow.JS, bringing it to
the web developers.  Let's take
a brief look at this.
The same TensorFlow
applications in JavaScript, you
can call them just as plain
JavaScript code.
And a full-fledged layer of API
on top.  And full support for
TensorFlow and
Keras models so you can pick the
best deployment for you.
And under the covers, these APIs
are actuated.
And we have NodeJS support
coming
soon, which will give you the
power to
actuate on CPUs and GPUs.
And I would like to welcome
Megan
Kacholia to talk about how
TensorFlow does performance.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you. All right.
Thanks, Rajat so, performance
across all platforms is critical
to TensorFlow Lite's success.  I
want to take a quick step back
and talk about some of the
things we think about when
measuring and assessing
TensorFlow's performance.  One
of the things we want to do is
focus on real world data and
time to accuracy.  We want to
have reproducible benchmarks and
make sure they're realistic of
the workloads and types of
things that users like you are
doing on a daily basis.  Another
thing, like Rajat talked about,
is we want to make sure we have
clean APIs.
And we don't want to have a fast
version and a pretty version.
The fast version is the pretty
version.
All the APIs that we talked
about that we're talking about
through various talks, these are
the things you can use to get
the best performance out of
TensorFlow.  You don't have to
worry about what is fast or
pretty, use the pretty one, it
is fast.
TF Data from Derek after the
keynote.  As well as
distribution strategy from Igor.
And these are great examples of
things
we have been pushing on to
ensure good performance and good
APIs.  We want good performance,
whether it's a large data center
like here, or maybe you're using
something like on the image
here.
A GPU or CPU box under your
desk.
Making use of a cloud platform
or a mobile or  embedded device.
We want TensorFlow to perform
well across all of them.  Now
the numbers, because what is a
performance talk if I don't show
you slides and numbers.  First,
look at things on the mobile
side.
This is highlighting TensorFlow
Lite performance.  There's a
talk giving a lot more detail
how it works and the things we
were thinking of when making it
later
today
by Sarah.
And weft the speed yum with  Qu
-- and it's critical to have
strong performance regardless of
the platform, and we're really
excited to see these gains in
mobile.  In looking past mobile,
just beyond, there are a
number of companies in the
hardware space which continues
to expand.  The contributions
that come out of the
collaborations that we have with
these companies, the
contributions they give back to
TensorFlow and back to the
community at large, are critical
to  making sure that TensorFlow
performs well on these specific
platforms for the users that
each group really cares about.
One of the first ones I want to
highlight is Intel.
So, the Intel MKL-DNN library,
open
sourced and highly optimized for
TensorFlow.
We have a 3X inference speedup
on Intel platforms, as well as
great scaling efficiency on
training.  And this is one of
those things that highlights how
important it is to have strong
collaborations with different
folks in the community.  And
we're excited to see things like
this to go back to all the
users.
And I want to call out a new of
the collaborations with NVIDIA
as well.
And Tensor RT, an inference
Optimizer and we have been
working on this
for a long time.  It's been
around for a little while.  But
with the TensorFlow 1.
7 release, we have native
support built in.
You can get low latency, high
throughput.
You can see an inference speedup
versus native 32 with standard
TensorFlow.  It's great to see
the collaborations and the
contributions and the great
numbers delivered by it.
Looking past inference and going
on to some of the training
things.
So, mixed-precision training is
important.
As faster and more hardware
comes out, if you use the
support, that's how to get the
best out of the hardware.
One of the examples is the Tesla
V100 that NVIDIA has.
And we want the mixed-precision
training support get the best
performance out of the hardware.
You can see a training speedup.
This is on an 8X Tesla V100 box.
You can see the performance
improvement moving to
mixed-precision training versus
the standard TensorFlow.
Scaling efficiency is really
important as well.  Obviously we
want to make sure
TensorFlow flows well, maybe a
single GPU.  But keep going
regardless of what you throw at
it.  We want to make sure that,
again,  looking at examples for
real-world data as well as
synthetic data, it's great to
benchmark on synthetic data, but
real-world needs to perform as
expected.
90% with real data and 95% with
synthetic data.
This is a V100 box that has one
1 and 8GPUs.  And you can see
the scaling here.  But this is
something we care about,
and you're going to hear more
about scaling efficiency with
internal APIs later today.
Moving past -- moving on to
cloud frameworks.  I want to
talk about cloud TPUs.  Cloud
TPU was  launched in beta in
February.
Just a month and a half ago.
This is Google's V2 TPU.  It's
available by Google's cloud
platform, like I mentioned.
It's exciting to look at the
numbers here.  This picture is
showing a device.
And on a single device, you can
get 180 teraflops of
computation.  But it's not just
about the power, it's
about what you can do on this.
Doesn't matter if you can't run
the types of models that you
want.
I want to highlight the
reference models that we have
open sourced that are available
today as well as a bunch more
types of models coming soon.
Again, just to highlight the
breadth of things you can run on
the hardware and get great
performance and great accuracy.
We have an internal team
continually making sure that
these models perform well, they
perform fast and they are also
training to accuracy in the
expected amount of time.
It's not just about putting a
model out and open sourcing it,
but it's making it work as the
community expects it to work.
Again, some numbers.  What good
is it if I don't show numbers in
the performance talk?
One of the numbers I want to
call out
on this slide, the cost to
ImageNet is under  $85.  It's
exciting to see what you can
achieve but making use of this
platform.  And if you want more
numbers, you can
look at the DAWNBench
rentry that was submitted for
the ImageNet training.  One
final exciting thing to call out
is the available of pods, later
this year.  So, what's a pod?  A
pod is actually 64 of the
devices, like I showed earlier,
all wired up together.  And you
get about 11.
5 petaflops of computation in a
pod.  That is a lot of compute
power that is going to be
available in this.  What can you
do with that?  The team has been
pushing training resident 50 on
a pod to accuracy in less than
15 minutes.  We're very excited
what can be done with this type
of hardware.  And just the
amazing speed that you can get
that wasn't really possible
before.
So, Rajat talked about the APIs
and just the ease of use and
things we're focusing on.  I
have given you some numbers.
But what happens when you put it
together?  What can TensorFlow
do?  I want to invite Jeff Dean,
the  leader of the brain team,
to come up and talk a bit more
about how TensorFlow addresses
real problems.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks, Megan. So, I think
one of the really remarkable
things about machine learning is
it's capacity to solve real
problems in the world.  And
we've seen tremendous progress
in the last two years.  In 2008,
though, the U.S. National
academy of engineering put out
this list of grand  engineering
challenges that they were hoping
to be solved by the end of the
21st century.  It's 14 different
challenges.
And I think it's a really nice
list of things we should be
aspiring to work on as a
society.
If we solved all these problems,
our planet would be healthier,
people would
live longer, we would be happier
and things would be better.  And
I think machine learning is
going to help us in all of
these.  Some in small ways.
Machine learning influencing our
understanding of chemical
molecules.  Some in major ways.
I'm going to talk about two
today.  But I think machine
learning is a key to tackling
these areas.
The two are advancing health
informatics and engineering of
tools for scientific discovery.
Clearly machine learning is a
big
component, and TensorFlow itself
you can think of as a tool for
helping us engineer some of
these discovers.  But one of the
things that I think is really
important is that there's a lot
more opportunity for machine
learning than there is machine
learning expertise in the world.
The way you solve a machine
learning problem today is, you
have some data.
You have some computation, maybe
GPUs
or TPUs or CPUs, and then a
machine learning expert.
Someone who has taken a graduate
class in machine learning.
Downloaded TensorFlow and
familiar enough to play with it.
But that's a small set of people
in the world.  And then you stir
all this together and you get a
solution, hopefully.
So, that's -- the unfortunate
thing about that is there's
probably tens of thousands of
organizations in the world today
that are actually effectively
using machine learning in
production environments and
really making use of it
to solve problems.  But there's
probably tens of millions
of organizations in the world
that have
data in a form that could be
used for machine learning but
don't have the internal
expertise and skills.  How can
we make machine learning much
easier to use so you don't need
nearly as much expertise to
apply it?
Can we use computation to
replace a lot of the need for
the machine learning expertise?
We have been working on a suite
of techniques, AutoML.  And
neural architecture search is
one example of this.  One of the
things a machine learning expert
does is they sit down and decide
for a particular problem what
kind of model structure they're
going to use for the problem.
A resident 50 architecture, a
nine-layer  CNM with these
filter sizes and so on.
It turns out that you can use
machine
learning to optimize a
controller that proposes machine
learning models.  You can have
the controller propose machine
learning models, train it on the
problems you care about, see
which work well and which don't
and use that feedback as a
reinforcement signal for the
Model generating model.  You can
steer it towards models
working well for particular
problems and away from the space
where they're not working well.
If you repeat this, you can get
powerful, high-quality models.
And they look a little weird.
So, this is not something a
human machine learning expert
would sit down and sort of
extract.
But it has characteristics of
things we know human machine
experts have discovered are
helpful.  If you think of the
resident architecture, it has
skip connections that allow you
to skip every layer.
These more organic-looking
connections are the same
fundamental idea, which is you
want to allow input data to flow
more to the output
without going through as many
computational layers.
So, the interesting thing is,
AutoML does quite well here.
Every dot here -- this is a
graph
showing computational cost
versus accuracy for ImageNet.
And every dot shows different
kinds of tradeoffs.  And
generally, as you expend more
computation, you get higher
accuracy.  But every dot here is
sort of the work
of years of effort -- a
cumulative effort by top machine
learning experts in the world.
And if you run AutoML, you get
better accuracy and better
computational tradeoffs than all
those  models.  That's true at
the high end, you care
about utmost accuracy and don't
care about computational budget.
But at the low end, you have low
weight with low computational
cost and high accuracy.  That is
exciting.  I think this is a
real opportunity to use more
computation to solve real
machine learning problems in a
much more automated way so that
we could solve more problems
more quickly.  We have released
this in
collaboration with the cloud
group at Google as a -- as a
product that
customers can use for solving
their own computer vision
problems.
And obviously the one I have has
lots of other categories of
problems.  Okay.  Advance health
informatics.
So, machine learning and health
care is going to be a really
impactful combination.  One of
the areas that we have been
working on is a variety of
different
medical imaging problems,
including one problem in --
where you're trying to
look at an image and diagnose if
that
image shows science of diabetic
retinopathy.  400 million people
are at risk of this around the
world.  It's very treatable if
it's caught in time.  But if
it's not, you can suffer vision
loss.
So, in many parts of the world,
there aren't enough
ophthalmologists to inspect
these images.  And so, we have
done work, and with work that
we've published in the very end
of 2016, we showed that we had a
model that was on par with board
certified ophthalmologists.  And
since then,
we have been continuing to work
on this.  And we've changed how
we sort of label our training
data.
We've gotten retinal specialists
to
label the training data rather
than general ophthalmologists.
And we have it on par with
retinal specialists, a higher
standard of care.  We can bring
this and deliver this to lots
and lots of places around the
world.  But more interestingly,
I'm going to tell you a tale of
scientific discovery.
So, we had a new person join the
retinopathy team.
And as a  warmup exercise, Lily
who leads this work, said to
this new person, hey, why don't
you go off and see if you can
predict age and gender from the
images.
Maybe age within a couple of
decades, and no gender.
The AUC should be .5.  They came
back, I can predict gender with
AUC of .7.  That must be wrong.
Go off and come back later.
And they came back and said my
AUC is now .85.  That got us
thinking.  And we investigated
what other kinds
of things we could predict from
these retinal
images.  You can predict a
variety of things indeed caytive
of cardiovascular health.
Your age and gender are signs of
cardiovascular health.  Your
hemoglobin level, lots of things
like this.
We have a new, non-invasive test
for cardiovascular health.
Normally, you have to draw blood
and do lab tests, but we can do
this just from an image.  Which
is pretty cool.
We're also doing a bunch of work
on predictive tasks for health
care given a patient's medical
record, can we predict the
future?  This is something
doctors want to do.  Understand
how your patient is going to
progress.  And you want to be
able to answer lots of kinds of
questions.  Will the patient be
readmitted if I release them
now?
What are the most likely
diagnosis I should be thinking
about?  What tests for this
patient?  Lots of questions like
that.  And we have been
collaborating with several
health care organizations to
work on identified health care
records to predict these things.
In January, we posted a many
author archive paper and looked
at these tasks.  Highlighting
one here.
Predicting which patients are
most at risk for mortality, and
using this,
we're able to predict which
patients are most seriously at
risk 24 hours earlier than the
clinical baselines that are
currently in use.  That means
that doctors get 24 hours of
advanced notice to pay attention
to the patients critically ill
and need their close attention
and close watching.
This is indicative of what
machine learning can do.
The Google brain team's mission
is to make machines intent and
approve lives.  I'm going to
close with a bit of a story.
So, when I was 5 years old, I
lived in northwestern Uganda for
a year.
And the local crop there is a
root called cassava.  And I was
5.
So, I liked to go out and help
people pick cassava.  But it
turns out that machine learning
and cassava have a kind of cool
twist together.  Please roll the
video.
>> Cassava is a really important
crop.  It provides for over 500
million Africans every day.
>> When all other crops failed,
farmers
know they could rely on their
cassava plants to provide them
food.
>> We have several diseases that
affect  cassava, and these
diseases make the roots
inedible.
It is very crucial to actually
control and manage these
diseases.
>> We are using machine learning
to respond to the diseases.
>> And TensorFlow is the best
foundation for our solutions.
The app can diagnose multiple
diseases.
It's nuru, Swahili for light.
You wave your phone over a leaf,
if it has a symptom, the box
will pop up, you have this
problem.  When we get a
diagnosis, we have an option for
advice and learn about
management practices.
: the object we use through
TensorFlow relies upon our team
annotating images.
>> We have collected over 5,000
high-quality images of different
cassava diseases throughout this
project.
We use a single model on the
mobile net architecture.  It's
able to make predictions in less
than one second.
>> Instead of implementing
thousands of lines of code,
TensorFlow has a library of
functions to allow us to build
architectures in much less time.
>> We need something that can be
deployed on a phone without any
connection.
TensorFlow is able to shrink
these neural networks.
>> The human input is critical.
We're building something that
augments your experience and
makes you better at your job.
>> So, with AI tools and machine
learning, you can improve the
yields, you can protect your
crops, and you can have a much
more reliable source of  food.
>> AI offers the prospect to
fundamentally transform the life
of
hundreds of millions of farms
around the world.
>> You can see a product that
can actually make someone's life
better.
This is kind of revolutionary
.
>> Cool. And I think we have
some members of
the Penn State and IITA teams
from Tanzania here today.  If
you could all stand up or wave.
And I'm sure they would be happy
to chat with you.
[ Applause ]
I'm sure they would be happy to
chat you at the break about that
work.  With that, I would like
to introduce
Derek Murray who is going to
talk to you about tf.data.
That's a way to describe an
input line.  Derek.  Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. Thank you, Jeff.
And, wow, it's amazing to see
how people are using TensorFlow
to make the world a better
place.
As Jeff said, my name is Derek
Murray,
I'm thrilled to be here to tell
you about tf.data.
It helps you get your data from
cat
pictures to cassava pictures
into TensorFlow.  They're
usually overshadowed by the more
glamorous aspects of machine
learning, matrix, convolution,
but I would argue they're
extremely important.  Input data
is the life blood of machine
learning.  And the current
algorithms and
hardware are so thirsty for
data, we need a powerful input
pipeline to keep up with them.
There we go.
So, when I kicked off the tf.
data project last year,
TensorFlow had room to improve.
You could feed in data from
Python at
each step, kind of slow, or set
up curators to feed in data.
These were challenging to use.
So, I decided to focus on three
themes, the main focus of my
talk today.  First is
performance.
When we're training models on
state of
the art accelerator hardware, we
have a
moral imperative to keep them
busy with new data at all times.
The second is flexibility.  We
want to handle any data in
TensorFlow itself.  We don't
want to have to rely on
different tools so you can
experiment with different views.
And third, we have ease of use.
With TensorFlow, we want to open
up machine learning to users of
all abilities.  And it can be a
big leap from following along
with your first tutorial
to training your first on your
own data.
And we can help smooth this
transition.  Tf.
data is the only library you
need for TensorFlow.  How to do
that?  We took inspiration from
the worlds of
data bastes and designed tf.data
as tools to divide up into
three.  First, the tools to
extract data from a wide range
of sources.
These can range from in-memory
arrays to multi
Terabyte files across a
distributed system.  Then we
have the tools to transform your
data.
These enable you to extract
features, perform data
augmentation and ultimately
convert your raw data into the
tensors you will use to train
your model.
And finally, loading into the
accelerators.  That is important
for performance.  That's the
high level pitch.  What's it
look like in real today?
This is the standard tf.
data input pipeline for example
protos for example files.
I bet that 90% of all TensorFlow
input pipelines start out this
way.  It's so common, we have
wrapped this pipeline up in a
single utility.
For petago logical reasons, it's
important to start out there.
We get a list of  files on your
local
disk or in GCS or S3, and
extract the tf records.  We use
functional transformations to
pre-process the data.
We took inspiration from C
Sharp, Java and Scala which use
method chaining to build up a
pipeline of data set objects and
a higher order of functional
operators like map and filter to
help you customize the behavior
of that pipeline.
And finally, the load phase,
tell TensorFlow how to get data
out of the set.  And one of the
easiest ways is to create an
iterator.
Just like the name sake in
Python,
gives you sequential access.
And we will see ways to soup up
this part of the pipeline later
on.  I have given you an
overview, I want to come back to
the key themes and tell you how
we have been advancing each of
them.  Let's start with
performance.  So, you remember
all those exciting performance
results that Megan told you
about in the keynote?  Well,
every one of them was measured
using real input data and  ad
tf.data input pipeline you can
download and use in your
programs.  And there's one that
I personally like, and it
measures the performance of
training an infinitely fast
image model
or real data in order to tease
out any bottlenecks in the
pipeline.
When we ran this last week on an
NVIDIA feed, it processed over
30,000
ImageNet images per second.
That's much faster than we can
train on current hardware, but
it's exciting for a couple of
reasons.  And this throughput
more than doubled other the last
eight months.  And a testament
to the great job the
team has done in optimizing
TensorFlow performance.
And the accelerators are getting
faster all the time.  And we
have this extremely useful
benchmark that guides us as we
continue to approve tf.data
performance.  How do you get
that kind of performance?  Well,
one option is you can go on
GitHub, the TensorFlow
benchmarks
projects, and use it in your
program.  You should probably
just do that.  But maybe you
have a different problem to
solve.  We have recently
launched tf.data on TensorFlow.
org, and this guide is full of
useful, theoretical, and
practical information that gives
you the ability to put
optimizations into practice on
your own pipelines.  And to
support this on the technical
side, adding a raft of new
features to tf.data to achieve
this
performance.
One I critically want to call
out is this part of TensorFlow
1.8.  You can start playing with
it in the builds right away.
And up to this point, tf.data
has been exclusively for code
that runs on the CPU.  This
marks our first foray into
running on GPUs as well, there's
a lot more I can say on this
topic and we are developing the
features.  But let's go back to
look again at program from
earlier on.  Show you how to put
the techniques into practice.
First off, when dealing with a
large dataset like  GCS or S3,
you can speed things up by
reading multiple files in
parallel by increasing the level
of throughput into your model.
And you can turn this on with
the
single record, the call, numb
parallel -- and then you can
improve performance
by switching to fused version of
various  transformations.
And I can repeat -- between the
boxes, the buffers.
And fused together the match and
batch, the execution of the
function and the map and the
data transfer
of each element into the  batch.
And together, these two
optimizations
get big speedups for models that
consume a large volume of data.
And last, but not least, we have
the GPU prefetch that I
mentioned.
This ensures that the next batch
of input data is in memory on
the GPU when it's ready to
begun.
There is a crucial part of the
CNN benchmarks.
But achieving it had buffers
from CPU to GPU.
And the new device API gives you
the same performance and only
requires you
to add one line of code to your
input
line to get the benefits.  This
is the cliffs notes version.
I would encourage you to watch
my colleague's talk later, he's
going to
show you
a more specific approach.  And
restructure check it out.
Now, let's switch gears and move
on to the second.
Originally the flexibility in
tf.data stemmed from the
functional transformation.
Allowed you to put any
TensorFlow graph, at any point
in your pipeline.   So, for
example, if you have existing
TensorFlow
code for pre-processing images,
you can stick it in a data flow
map and start using it right
away.  The original version of
tf.data traded on this and let
you pass a list of tensors in
and get a list of tensors out
from these transformations.  We
heard back from the users, they
had
more sophisticated things and
complicated structures.
We had in TensorFlow, added
native support, and it's useful
for dealing with complex
categorical data and  trading in
models.
So, at this point, if TensorFlow
is doing everything you want to
do, you're all set.  But one
thing we have learned over last
few years is not everything is
most naturally expressed in a
TensorFlow graph.  We have been
working to give you alternative
ways to build up the tf.data
pipelines.  The first is to add
data set.  And this allows you
to build a
pipeline from a Python function
that
generates -- and you can wrap
existing Python code and benefit
from the performance transitions
like prefetch and GPUs.  The
other way
might be more appealing to power
users.
We have openedded up a backend
API,
and you can build the plugins in
C++.
And I've heard from some of our
partners, this is useful for
custom and we're dogfooding this
approach for some of the
implementations like the
recently added Kafka data set.
I'm looking forward to what some
of you will build with this new
API, and encourage you to
contribute back via pull
requests.  We're excited about
the contributions from the
community at this point in the
project.
Okay, final thing I want to
cover is ease of use.  I want to
speak to folks like you who have
used TensorFlow for a year or
more, and struggled with the
data into TensorFlow, I don't
have to make much of a case.
But the users have high
expectations and there are
people getting their first
exposure to every day.  We
continue to push hard on
usability.  I want to share a
few highlights.  First off, as
Rajat told you in the
keynote, eager execution is
here, makes using
tf.data a lot more pleasant.
Alex is going to tell you more,
but from my admittedly biased
perspective,
you can start treating data sets
just like any object.
You can look over them with the
regular fore loop and there's no
iteration required.
What's neat about this, it works
together with tf.
data like GPU prefetch so you
can combine the efficiency of
execution for your input
pipeline and the flexibility of
Eager execution for your model
code.
Next, return feedback.
Power users like the
composebility and
figurability of the data API,
many had
users just want an easy way to
pull best practices.  TensorFlow
1.
8 will have new protocol buffers
and for
CSV data to make it easier to
handle the formats and apply all
the best practices from the
performance.
So, let's go for one last time
back to the standard problem.
As I promised in the beginning,
it can be replaced by a single
call.
And this performs all the
parallel IO, shuffling,
batching and fetching for you.
Gives
you back a data set you can
continue to transform using map
filter and transformations.  And
if you have a workload, use a
binary format like tf.records.
But those who tend to have
smaller data, they prefer
something simple.
And the CSV format fits that
fine.
There are thousands of different
CSV data  sets that are
available to download for free.
And this snippet shows you how
to use
an API, installing them to
download with just a couple
simple commands.  Once you have
done that, you can use the new
data set function in TensorFlow
to get the data out of the
loaded files.
In this case, it's a data set of
a million use headlines.  What I
particularly like about this
new API  is it takes care of
figuring out the types of common
names and dramatically cuts down
the boilerplate you have to run.
Finally, we have been working to
improve the integration between
tf.
data and high-level APIs like
estimators and Keras.  The Keras
support is still in the
pipeline, if you'll excuse the
pun.
But if we want to switch our CSV
parsing code for estimators,
it's a simple matter of
returning the data set from an
estimator's input function.  No
more iterator required.
And pass the input function to
the estimators train method and
we're good to go.
The road we're taking, make the
data sets and the integrators as
natural as possible.
Features like Eager execution
and the high level APIs are
making this easier.  The
eventual goal is to make it
seamless so it's a natural
extension of your TensorFlow
program.  Well, that is about
all the time I have.
So, just to recap, I told you in
the beginning that our mission
for tf.data was to make a
library for input processing
that was fast,  flexible, and
easy to use.  I hope I have
convinced you in the last 15
minutes we
have achieved these three goals.
I hope you understand that tf.
data is the one library all
input processing.  If you want
to find out more, there is a ton
of documentation about tf.data
on TensorFlow.org.  Cover how
toes and performance guidance I
mentioned earlier.  And the
benchmarks and the official
models and repositories,
examples of high performance and
readable pipelines written in
tf.data.
And with all of this information
and knowing the creativity, I'm
really looking forward to seeing
what all of you build with this
library.  Thanks a lot for
listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay.
And now it is my great pleasure
to introduce Alex Passos who is
going to
tell you all about TensorFlow
Eager execution.
>> Hello. My name is Alex.
And I'm here to tell you about
Eager execution, you have heard
the last two talks.  But I'm
here to tell you what it's
about.
This new imperative
object-oriented way of using
TensorFlow.  We're introducing
today as part of TensorFlow
core.  Because you're here or
watching on the live stream, I
hope, that TensorFlow has been
this, like, graph execution
engine for machine learning that
lets you run graphs in high
scale and all sorts of other
nice things.  But has it?  And
why did we choose to go with
graphs in the first place?
Since now we're -- I'm going to
tell you about Eager Execution.
We moved beyond what we can
achieve with graphs, it's a good
idea to recap why we bothered.
And like a really good reason
why you want to have your
computation respected
as a platform-independent graph,
once you have that, it's easy to
differentiate the graph.
I went to grad school before all
of this was standard in machine
learning tool kits and I
do not wish that on anyone.
Life is much better now, trust
me.  And if you have a
platform-independent abstract
representation of your
computation, you can just go and
deploy it to pretty much
anything you want.  You can run
it on the TPU, you can run it on
the GPU, put it on a phone or a
Raspberry Pi.  There are all
sorts of cool deployments that
you are going to hear about
today.
And this is -- it's really
valuable to have this kind of
platform-independent view.
Compilers work with data and
graphs generally.  And they know
how to do nice optimizations
that rely on a global view of
the computation.
Expressing the -- data  laying
and all things like that.  And
these are  deep-learning
specific.
We can choose how to  properly
lay out your channels and height
and width so your convolutions
are faster.  And finally, like a
key reason that's very important
to us at Google and important to
you as well, I hope, once you
have a platform-independent
representation, you can
deploy it and distribute it
across hundreds of machines or a
TPU like you saw earlier.  And
this is a seamless process.
Since graphs are so good, what
made us
think it's a good idea to move
beyond them and do Eager
Execution?  A good place to
start, you don't have
to give up automatic
differentiation.
Like Python's autograph --
sorry,
autograph, that lets you shape
dynamic code.  You don't need to
have the computation to
differentiate it.  You can build
up a trace as you go and walk
back the trace to compute
gradients.
Also, if you don't stop to build
a platform like in this
computational graph, you can
iterate a lot more quickly.  You
can play with your model as you
build it, inspect it, poke and
prod at it.  And this can let
you just be more productive when
you're like, making all these
things.  Also, you can run your
model for debuggers and
profilers and add all
sorts of, like, analysis to them
to just really understand how
they're doing what they're
doing.  And finally,
if we don't force you to
represent your computation in a
separate way than the host
programming language you're
using,
you can just use machinery of
your host programming language
to do control flow
and complicated data structures
which for some models is key to
making the model work at all.
So, I hope you're not wondering
how do I get to use this?
The way to use this is
super-easy.
Import TensorFlow and have Eager
Execution.
And what happens is any time you
run a TensorFlow application,
instead of TensorFlow  building
a graph that later when executed
is going to run that
matrix multiplication, we run
that for you and give you the
result.  You can print it, you
can slice it, dice it, do
whatever you want with it.  And
because things are happening
immediately, you can have highly
dynamic control flow that
depends on the actual values of
the computation you're
executing.  And here is just a
simple conditions line search
example that I wrote, and it
doesn't
matter.
It just is loops that have
complicated values based on the
computation.  And this runs just
fine on whatever device you
have.
And together with this enable
Eager Execution theme, we're
bringing you a few symbols in
TensorFlow that make it easier
for you to write code both
building graphs and executing
Eagerly.  We're bringing in a
new way of doing gradients.
And you're familiar with how you
do gradients in normal
TensorFlow.  Great the variable
and the loss function.
I hope you can think of a better
loss
function than this one, and you
call gradients to differentiate
it.
But when you have eager
execution, we try to be as
efficient as you can.
And if you're going to
differentiate, you need to keep
track of the memory of
information of what's happening
so far.  Like your activation.
But I don't want you to pay for
the cost of this tracking when
you're not computing gradients.
Performance, the whole reason
we're doing this, we want to use
these big, nice
pieces hardware to train models
super-fast.  When you want to
compute gradients,
you use this context manager and
records all the operations you
execute so we can play it back.
Otherwise, the API  is the same.
Also,  training loops in Eager,
as Derek pointed out, is much --
it's very easy and
straightforward.  You can just
use a 5.4 loop to iterate over
your data sets.  And data sets
work in Eager just fine and work
with the same high performance
you get in the graph execution
engine.  Then you can do your
predictions, supply your
gradients and do other things
you're  used to doing.  But
really, the interesting thing
about Eager Execution is not
just when you're writing the
code that it's finished, that
it's done that we already know
works, but you're still
developing.  You want to do
things like debug.  So, when
Eager Execution is enabled, you
can just take any model code and
I
use my simple example here.
Add notes to, like, to anywhere
you want, and once you're in
the debugger, you have the full
power of debugging available.
You can print the value of any
tensor, change the value of any
tensor, run any operation you
want on any tensor.
And this will hopefully empower
you to really understand what's
going on in your models.  And
you'll be able to fix any
problems you have.
You can also take Eager
Execution code and profile it
using whatever profiling tool
you are most familiar and
comfortable with.
So, here, I have a little dump
model
that just does an app.  And
let's pretend I don't know which
is going to be the lower, this
one is more expensive.
But you can run the code for the
Payton profiler and find out the
matmul
is 15 times more expensive.
Also, by the  way, those
examples are
run on the Google collaborate
thing,
which is a completely public
shared for notebooks hosted on
Google prod.  And I think we
have a demo on Eager that's
hosted on that you can play out
with later.  If you're on live
stream, you can play with it now
if you can find the link.  But
together with Eager, we're
bringing a lot of new APIs to
make it
easier to make graphs and
execute models.  They are
compatible with Eager Execution
and graph modeling.  A low
priority feature request is how
to customize gradients in
TensorFlow.  And I'm sure you're
familiar with
the tricks, stop gradients and
functions.  But we're
introducing a new API that works
in both eager and graph
execution.  What I like about
this example is it's a thing
being asked by many, many people
how to do it.
If I want to have my forward
pass and the backward pass, take
the gradient from a particular
TensorFlow and clip it.
Keep it small to prevent it from
exploding.
It just takes six lines of code
to clip the gradient.  And I
think this is cool.  I look
forward to seeing what you can
do with this when you're doing
more than
six lines of code and solving
all new and interesting research
problems.   A big, big change
when programming with Eager from
graph that I really want you to
stop and think about is we're
trying to make everything as
Pythonic and object-oriented as
possible.
So, variables in had TensorFlow
are usually a complicated thing
to think
about, but when execution is
enabled, simpler.
It's just a Python object.  You
can change the value, read the
value.
When the last reference to it
goes away, you get the memory
back.  Even if it's the GPU
memory.  So, if you want to
share variables, you just reuse
those objects.  You don't worry
about variable scopes or any
other complicated structure.
And because we have this, like,
object-oriented approach to
variables,
you can look at the APUs in
TensorFlow
and rethink them in a way that's
object-oriented and easier to
use.  And one is the overhaul
with the metrics API.
So, we're  introducing this new
tfe.
metrics, one has an updoubt of
value, and one gives the result.
And hopefully this is an API
that everyone is going to find
familiar.  Please don't try to
compare this to the other
metrics API.
We're giving you a way to do
object-oriented saving of
TensorFlow models.  If you tried
looking at TensorFlow check
points, you know they depend on
variable names.  And variable
names depend not just on the
game show variable, but all
other variables present in the
graph.
This can make it hard to save
and load subsets of the model
and really control what's in the
check point.  We're introducing
a completely
object-oriented,  python-object
based
saving API where you -- it's
like Python -- any model gets
saved, you can save any subset
of your model.  You can load any
subset of your model.  You can
even use this tfe.checkpoint
object to build things you want
to save that have more than a
model.
Here we have an optimizer and a
global stack.  You can put
whatever you want in there.  The
object graph is something you
can save and load.  You can save
and load your discriminators and
generators separate.  And take
the discriminator and load it
back up as another network that
you can use on another part of
the model.  This should give you
a lot more control to get a lot
more out of, like, TensorFlow
checkpoint.  But if you have a
question that everybody asks me
when I tell them to work with
the Eager Execution, is it fast?
Graphs have this high
performance.
How fast can I make this run
Python code all the time?  We
can make it fast enough.  For
models that are highly
computationally intensive, you
don't see
any Python overhead and we are
fast with the TensorFlow.
Sometimes slightly faster, and
reasons that I don't fully
understand.
Even for highly dynamic models,
you
have comparative performance
with anything else you can find.
And please don't get attached to
these numbers.
We have many more benchmarks and
we're optimizing Eager
performance aggressively.  But I
hope you know if your model can
keep it busy, you're doing large
matrix computations, there's no
cost in experimenting and doing
your research and model building
with Eager Execution turned on.
When you're doing smaller
things, there are overheads.
Don't get attached to them.
We're being aggressive about
optimizing this.
If you run an identity, it takes
a microsecond.  If you run it
with Eager Execution turned on,
there's an extramicrosecond.
If you're tracing gradients,
another three microseconds.
But just enqueuing something on
the  GPU screen, that takes a
single digit microsecond.
So, if you can execute enough
computation to keep a GPU busy,
you're unlikely to see anything
bad from using Eager Execution.
And, again, these numbers are
improving very quickly.  Please
don't get too attached to them.
But there is this large
ecosystem of
TensorFlow code libraries,
models, frameworks, check
points, that I don't think
anyone wants to give up.  And I
don't want you it give up if you
want to used Eager Execution.
So, we're also thinking really
hard
about how can you -- how you can
interoperate between Eager and
graph.  One way is to call into
graphs from Eager code.
And you can do that with tfe.
make template.  We build a graph
for that little Python function
and you can use it and
manipulate and call the graph
from Eager Execution.  We also
have the reverse, which is how
to call into Eager from a graph.
Let's say
you have a big graph and you
understand everything in it, but
there's a little chunk of your
computation that you really
don't know how to express in --
either don't know, or you don't
want to
bother expressing it in using
liar TensorFlow graphs.
So, you can wrap it in a tfe
graph,
and you can run any TensorFlow
in there,
including convolutions and other
things not available.
And you can look at the values
and use dynamic control.  I hope
with these two things together,
you can reuse Eager and graph
code across.
But the easiest way to get Eager
and
graph compatibility is to write
model code that can go both
ways.
Once the code is written and
debugged
and tested, there's nothing to
tell you to build a graph or
execute Eagerly.  Debug in Eager
and impart that same code into
graph.
Put it in estimator, deploy it
on the GPU, distribute it.  Do
whatever you want.  This is what
we've done in the example
models.  And there's going to be
a link in the end of the of
presentation so you don't need
to worry about writing this
down.
So, here is some practical
advice for you.
Write code that's going to work
well when executing Eagerly and
building graphs.  To do that,
use the Keras layers, they're
object-oriented, easy to
understand, manipulate and play
around with.
Use the Keras model, that will
give you saving and loading and
training and all sorts of things
automatically if you want.  But
you're not forced to use those.
Use config summary, they will
move to the TensorFlow package
soon.  If you're watching this
on video, probably already
happened.
Use the tfe metrics instead of
the  tf.metrics, these are
object-oriented and friendier
and eager to use.  And use the
object-based saving.
Which is a much nicer user
experience anyway.
So, you're going to want to do
this all the time, it's how your
code is going to work well in
Eager execution and graph
building.  So, now, I would like
to take some time to tell you
why you
should enable Eager execution,
and like
a real good importance reason
that led
us to build this in the first
place, being able to play these
objects and manipulate them
directly is just a much nicer
experience than having to build
a graph and interact later in
the session.  It's a lot more
intuitive, let's you understand
what's going on better.
If you're
new, play around
>> Now I would like to point to
a few things.  Some of my
colleagues, they're going to be
in the demo room during the
break
with laptops, with  notebooks to
let you type and try Eager mode
there.  Please go and give it a
try.  Or if you're watching on
the live stream, type that short
link.
Hopefully it will stay long
enough for you to type it.  And
play with it right now.  It's
really nice.  We have a getting
started guide on TensorFlow that
should be live now.  That tells
you what you need to know about
Eager execution and starting to
use TensorFlow using Eager
Execution.  We have a ton of
example models like
from RNN to net to all purposing
that are available behind that
link, and I
encourage you to look at them
and how easy to write the model
and how easy it
is to reuse the same code from
graphs to deployment.  We have
deployment for graph from all
models except for the highly
dynamic ones which are hard to
write in a graph form.  Give it
a try.  Let us know how it went.
We're super-excited to share
with you and I hope you have a
good time playing with this.
Thank you.
And now it's time to have a
treat.  Introducing Nick hill
and Daniel.
They have a cool demo set up,
but I don't to spoil it.
>> Hi, everyone, my name is
Daniel.
>> My anymore is Nikhil.
>> We're from the Google brain
team.  And  today, we're
delighted to talk about
JavaScript.  Python has been one
of the mainstream languages for
scientific computing.  And it's
been like that for a while.
And there's a lot of tools and
libraries around Python.
But that's where it ends.
We're here today to talk -- to
convince you that JavaScript and
the
browser have a lot to offer.
And TensorFlow Playground is a
great example of that.
I'm curious, how many people
have seen TensorFlow  Playground
before?  Oh, wow.  Quite a few.
I'm very glad.
Those of you who haven't seen
it, check it out after the talk
at playground.tensorFlow
Lite.org.
It's a visualization of a small
neural network.
And it shows in real-I'm the
neural network as it's training.
And this is a lot of fun to make
and had a huge educational
success.  We have been getting
emails from high schools and
universities that have been
using this to teach students
about machine learning.
After we launched playground, we
were wondering, why was it so
successful?  And we think one
big reason was because it was in
the browser.  And the browser is
this unique platform where you
-- the things you build, you can
share with anyone with just the
link.  And those people that
open your app
don't have to install any
drivers or any software.  It
just works.  Another thing is,
it's -- the browser is highly
interactive.  And so, the user
is going to be  engaged with
whatever you're building.
Another big thing is that
browsers -- we didn't take
advantage of this in the
Playground, but browsers have
access to sensors like the
microphone and the camera and
the accelerometer.  And all
these are behind standardized
APIs that work on all browsers.
And the last and most important
thing, is the data that comes
from these sensors doesn't ever
have to leave the client.  You
don't have to upload anything to
the server, which preserves
privacy.
Now, the  Playground that we
built is powered by a small
neural
network, 300 lines of vanilla
JavaScript that we built as a
one-off library.  It doesn't
scale.  It's a simple loop and
wasn't engineered to be
reusable.
But it was clear to us that if
we were
to open the door for people to
merge machine learning and the
browser, we had to build a
library.  And we did it.
We released Deep Learn JS.
A JavaScript library that is
GPU-accelerated and does that
via WebGL, standards in the
browser, and allows it to render
graphics.
And deeplearn .
js allows it to both run
inference and training in the
browser.  When we released it,
we had an incredible momentum.
The community took deep
deeplearn.
js and forwarded it the into
browser and built fun things
with it.  One example is the
file transfer.  Another had the
character RNN and built a novel
interface that  allows you to
explore all the different
possible  endings of a sentence.
All generated by the model in
real-time.  Another
example is the model -- this was
a post about this one, that the
person that built it allowed
users to explore the
hidden dimensions, the
interesting dimensions in the
embedding space.
And you can see how they relate
to boldness of the font.  And
there was even education
examples
like teachable machines that
built this
fun little game that taught
people how
computer vision models work so
people could interact directly
with the webcam.  Now, all the
examples I showed you point to
the incredible momentum we have
with  deeplearn.js.  And
building on that momentum, we're
very excited today to announce
that deeplearn.
js is joining the TensorFlow
family.  And with that, we are
releasing a new
ecosystem of libraries and tools
and
machine learning with JavaScript
calls TensorFlow.js.  Now,
before we get into the details,
I
want to go over three main use
cases of how you can use
TensorFlow.js today.
The first use case is write
models directly in the browser.
Huge implications.
Think of the playground they
just showed.  The second use
case is -- a major use  case --
is you can take a pre-trained
model in Python, use a script,
and you
can import it into the browser
to inference.
And a related use case is the
same
model that you take during prep,
you can  re-train it,
potentially with private data
that comes from those censors of
the browser -- in the browser
itself.
Now, to give a schematic view,
we have
the bruiser that uses WebGL to
do fast algebra.
And two sets of APIs, the ops
API, which was deeplearn.js, and
we worked hard to align with
TensorFlow Python.
It is powered by an automatic
differentiation library.  And on
top of that, we have a
high-level API work layers API
that allows you to use best
practices and high-level
building blocks to write models.
But I'm also very excited today
to announce is that we're
releasing tools
that can take an existing Keras
model,
or TensorFlow  savedmodel and
forward it automatically
for execution in the browser.
Now, to show you an example of
our
API, we're going to go over a
small
program that tries to learn a
quadratic function.
They're trying to learn A, B,
and C from data.
So, we have our import tf from
TensorFlow JS.
This is a standard ES in
JavaScript.
We have the three, A, B, C, we
mark them as variable.
Which means they are viewable
and the optimizer can change
them.
We have the function that does
the computation.  You can see
tf.add and tf.square like
TensorFlow.  Notion that  API,
we have a chaining API which
allows you to pull these math
operations on tensors
themselves, and this leads to
better readable code that
is closer to how we write it.
It is very popular in JavaScript
world.  That's that part of the
model.
Now, for the training part, we
need a loss function.  This is a
loss function, an error between
the prediction and the label.
We have our optimizer, the edge
of the optimizer.
And we train the model,
optimizer.minimize for some
model.  And I want to emphasize
for those who
have used
tf before, Alex's talk, it's
aligned with the Eager API in
Python.  All right.
So, clearly, that's not how most
people write machine learning.
Because those low-level algebras
can be quite verbose.  For that,
we have our layered API.
So show you an example of that,
we're going to build a recounter
neural network that learns the
numbers.
But the complicated part is that
those
numbers, like the number 90 plus
10, are being set character by
character.  And then the neural
network has to
maintain an internal space with
an LSTM cell.
And that gets passed into a
decoder.
And the decoder has 100,
character-by-character.  It's a
sequence-by-sequence model.
This may sound complicated, but
the layered APU is not that much
code.
We have the import in
TensorFlow.js.
We have the sequential model.
Those familiar with Keras, this
API looks very familiar.  We
have the first two layers of the
encoder, the last three layers
are the decoder.  And that's our
model.
We then compile it with a loss,
an  optimizer, and a metric we
want to monitor, like accuracy.
And we call model.fit with our
data.  What I want to point out
here is the "Await"  keyword.
This is an asynchronous call
which  means -- because in
practice, that can take 30-40
seconds in the browser.  And in
those 30-40 seconds, you don't
want the main UI thread of the
browser to be locked.  And this
is why you get a call back with
a history object after that's
done.  And in between the GPU is
going to do the work.
Now, the code I showed you is
when you are trying to write
models directly -- when you want
to write model the  directly in
the browser.
But, as I said before, a major
use
case -- even with deeplearn.
js, were people importing models
that were pre-trained and they
wanted to do it in the browser.
Before the details of that, I
want to
show you a fun little game that
our
friends built that takes
advantage of an
automatically pre-trained model
and imports into the becauser.
It's called emoji scavenger
hunt.
I'm going to show you a real
demo with the phone.  It's in
the browser.  Let's see.  And
you can see here.  So, you can
see I have a Chrome
browser  opened up on a Pixel
phone.  You can see it at the
top.
And the game uses the webcam and
shows
me
an emoji and I have some number
of seconds to find the emoji
before the time runs out.
Nikhil is going to help me
identify the objects.  Are you
ready?
>> I'm ready.
>> All right. Let's go. All
right.  Watch.
>> Have a watch.
>> Nice. Yay! We got that.
Let's see what our next item is.
Shoe.
>> Shoe.
>> Help me out here, buddy. We
got the shoe!
>> What's next?
>> That's a banana.
>> Does anyone -- this guy's got
a banana.
>> Come over here. Yay!
>> All right.
>> I'm ready.
>> We're going to have a high
score here.   Beer.
>> Beer. It's 10:30 in the
morning, Daniel.  Step out --
>> All right. All right. So,
I'm going to jump into some of
the technical details of how we
actually built that game.  Stand
by, please.
So, what we did was we trained a
model
in TensorFlow to be an object
recognizer for the game.  We
chose about 400 different
classes that would be reasonable
for a game like this.
You know, watches and baa
bananas and beer.
We used the TensorFlow for poets
code  lab.
And in that code lab, you take a
pre-trained mobile net model.
If you don't know what MobileNet
is, it's a state of the art
computer model for edge devices.
We took that model and retrained
it.
Now we have an object detector
in the pipeline.  How to get
this into the browser?  We
provided this tool today to help
you do that.
Once it's in, you get the same
and make the computer talk and
all that kind of fun stuff.
Let's jump into how but convert
that model.  As Daniel mentioned
earlier, we support two types of
models.  TensorFlow saved
models, we have
a converter for that, and a
converter for Keras saved model.
You define the model and define
it with the saved model.  The
standard way to do that.
Similarly, this is the code for
Keras.  The next piece is that
we actually convert it to the
web.
Today, we're releasing a
package, TensorFlow.
js, a script lets you point to
the TensorFlow save model and
lets you point to the output
director.
That's where the static built
art facts go.  Keras is the same
flow.
Point to the output and you have
a directory.
Now, you statically host those
on the website, simple static
hosting.  And on the JavaScript
side, we provide an API that
lets you load that model.  So,
this is what it looks like for
TensorFlow.  And the TensorFlow
save model, we noticed that it
was a model, we don't right now
support continuing training of
this model.  While in the Keras
case we actually let you
continue  training.
And we're working hard to let
you keep these APIs alive in the
future.  Under the
cover, what are we actually
doing?  Graph optimization.
Which essentially means we prune
out nodes you don't need to make
the prediction.  You don't need
them.
We optimize waits for browser
caching.
We park in 4 megabytes, helps
the browser be quick the next
time you load.
Today we support about 90 of the
most commonly used TensorFlow
ops, and we're working hard to
control more flow ops.
And we support 32 of the most
commonly used Keras layers
today.  And as I mentioned, we
let you continue training for
Keras models and let you do
evaluation as well as make
predictions.  Okay.
So, obviously there's a lot you
can do with just porting your
models to the web.
Since the beginning of
deeplearn.js, we have made it a
high priority to train directly
in the browser.  This opens up
the door for education and
interactive tools like we saw
with the playground.
As well as lets you train with
data that never leaves your
client.  This is huge.
To show off what you can do with
something like this, we built
another little game game.
The goal of the game is to play
Pac-Man.
Daniel is much, much better at
this game than I am.  Say hi.
There's three phases of the
game.  Phase one, we're going to
collect frames from the webcam
and associate those with up,
down, left and right.  Daniel's
going to move his head up, down,
left and right and he's going to
play the game like that.  And
you'll notice, as he's
collecting frames, he's kind of
moving around a little bit,
which helps the model see
different angles for that class
and generalize a little bit
better.  So, after he's done
collecting these frames, we're
going to go and train our model.
So, we're not actually training
from scratch here when we hit
that "Train" button.
We're taking a pre-trained
mobile net,
porting that to the web, and
doing a re-training phase.
And using a  layered APU to do
this that the browser.  You want
to hit the train button.  It's
going down, looks like we're
learning
something.  That's great.  So,
as soon as we press that play
button, what's going to lap is
we're going to make predictions
from the webcam.  Those are
going to get plugged into those
controls and it's going to
control the Pac-Man game.
Ready?  All right.
So, you can see in the bottom
right, he's highlighting the
class that is could  inned.  And
he moves his head around, you'll
see a change by class.  And he's
off.
So -- so, all of this code is
online and you can go fork it.
We invite you to do so.
Obviously this is just a game.
But you can imagine, you know,
other types of applications of
this, like make a browser
extension that lets you control
a page for accessibility
purposes.  So, again, all this
code is online.  Please go fork
if and play and make something
else with it.  Okay.  Daniel, I
know this is fun.
>> I got it.
>> Okay. So, let's talk a
little bit about performance.
So, what we're looking at here
is a benchmark of MobileNet 1.0
running with TensorFlow.
TensorFlow classic, not with
TensorFlow.js.  And I want to
point out, this is a batch size
of one.  This is important
because we're
thinking about this in the
context of an interactive
application.  Maybe this Pac-Man
game, feeding in webcam data,
you want to know the prediction
time for one.  Can't really
batch it.
In the top row, TV Cuda running
on a 1080 GT X, it's about 3
milliseconds.  And the shorter
the bar, the faster.
The second row we have
TensorFlow CPU
running with AVX512 on a Macbook
pro here.  And 60 seconds for
that.
Where does TensorFlow.js come
into the picture?  We're getting
about 11 milliseconds for this.
Which is pretty good if you
think about this in the context
of an interactive game.  So, on
the laptop we just showed the
game, we're getting about 100
milliseconds for that.  And
that's still pretty good.  Like,
you can build a whole
interactive game with what's
running on there.  The web is
only going to get faster and
faster.  There's a whole new set
of standards
coming,
like web GPU to push the
boundaries.  But the browser has
limitations.  You can only get
access to the GPU
through WebGL on these APIs.
How do we scale beyond that?
How do we scale beyond the
limitations we have in the
browser?
There's a whole ecosystem of
server-side JavaScript tools
using NodeJS that we would love
to take advantage of.
So, today I'm really happy to
tell you
that we're working on NodeJS
binding to the TensorFlow C API.
That means you'll be able to
write the
same with the Eager mode, the
poll
polynomial, and the Pac-Man
example, and
bind to TensorFlow C and have
your TensorFlow running with
CUDA installed.
Eventual we will run the
TensorFlow opt backend, that
same JS code.  These bindings
are under active development.
Stay tuned.  All right.  So,
let's recap
some of the things we launched
today and talked about.
This  low-level ops API which
does
hard level linear algebra and
the Eager mode.
This is previously known as
deeplearn.js, rebranding today.
We  released these high-level
layers API.  That mirrors
TensorFlow layers.
And we saw that with the
addition of RNN and the Pac-Man
demo.
We also  showed you how you can
import
TensorFlow saved Model and Keras
for re-training in the browser.
We have released a bunch of
demos and examples on GitHub.
These are not the only two.
There is a whole repository that
can get you started.
They have live links and you can
poke around and play.  I invite
you to do that.  We really want
to see you get involved in this
project.  We have a bunch of
links here.
JS.tensorFlow.org is the
website.
There's tutorials,
documentation, et cetera.
Our code is open source under
TensorFlow.js, play there too.
And we started a community
mailing list today.  That's the
short link
here.  And the community
mailing list is for people to
post demos and ask questions.
So, this project was not just
Daniel and myself.  This is a
larger team effort between many
of our amazing colleagues at
Google.  We want to thank them.
And we want to thank all of the
amazing open source contributor
for deeplearn.js.  And we're
really excited to build the
next chapter of machine learning
in JavaScript with you.  Thank
you.
>> Thank you.
>> We can
>> Okay. We are now going to
take a break.  We have about a
little under half an hour.  We
are going to be back here at
11:30 for a great talk on
performance.
Head on over to the auditorium.
We have food, demos, we have the
speakers there to ask questions.
Have fun.
Test.  Test.
>> So, we've got a few more
seating down over here.  We can
help you out on that end.  We
have a few seats left over here.
>> Hi.
>> A few seats over there.
>> I would like to get started
again.
So, hi, my name is Brennan.  I'm
talking about training
performance today.
Now, this talk is centered
around a user's guide to how to
improve performance.
So, there's -- performance is
very complicated, a lot of
internals to TensorFlow as to
things we're going to optimize
your training time.  But I'm
going to talk today about how
you can make the most of the
TensorFlow you know and love to
converge faster.  Now, before I
go further, I want to
take a moment to acknowledge the
great
work that's done not just by our
engineering TensorFlow team and
not just by other teams at
Google, but by our partner
teams, for example, the partner
team at NVIDIA, doing a lot of
work to make TensorFlow work
fast and I want to acknowledge
that.  With that, dig into
motivation.  Why do we need
performance and how to improve
performance.  Is it just fine
today?
Some folks at Baidu put together
research.  If you want to
improve the quality of your
models, just
train on larger data sets.
These beautiful straight lines
are  showing for multiple
different models,
as you give more and more
training data, you get linearly
more accurate.
Now, I'm being slightly
facetious
here, if you look closely, the
axis on
the graph are log rhythmic, not
linear.
We don't need linearly
increasing
amounts of data, we need
exponentially more data.  This
holds not just for model classes
on -- in this case, it was
sequence-to-sequence-type work,
but they found this applied to
images and translation.  To
multiple different areas across
multiple model tops.
We're going to need to train on
exponentially more data to
improve our model quality.
Unfortunately, we have quite the
obstinate adversary, physics.
Here's a graph of
microprocessor trend data over
40 years.  And we can see that
clock frequency has hit a wall.
And are performance is not
getting that much faster
compared to how it used to.  We
are going to have to work a lot
harder
to meet the challenges of today
and tomorrow with performance.
Silicon itself is not going to
get us
there without a little bit of
clever cleverness.
The result of these two forces
coming
together has resulted in a
Cambrian explosion of hardware.
We have TPUs and other exciting
things coming.
There's startups like Nirvana is
part of Intel, and the IPU from
Graphcore.  Taking points in the
design space and trying
different hardware methodologies
and layouts to get to get the
best machine learning
performance.  This is going to
be a very exciting, exciting
area coming forward as we think
about performance in the future.
Now, before I dig into the meat
of my
talk, I do want to give  a -- I
do want to acknowledge, this is
the Jurassic
period and not of the pre-
Cambrian era.
You have a picture of tetal
bytes that's not licensed, send
it my way.  Across models and
paradigms, it looks  roughly as
follows.  You have the training
data.  You need to load that if
in.
This is phase one, read from
neither disk or generate from a
reinforcement learning
environment.
Decompress it, parse it, image
model,
image augmentations, random
flips, color distortions.  And
compute the forward pass, the
loss, the backwards pass, your
gradients.
And after the gradients, update
the things you're trying to
learn and repeat the cycle
again.
Now, again, there's a wide
variety of accelerators.
The phase one happens mostly on
CPUs.
The accelerator takes over phase
two and phase three.  With that,
let's dig in.
In my experience, as people
migrate to modern accelerators,
new TPUs, new
generation of GPUs, et cetera,
phase one is actually where the
most performance problems are.
Things everyone  hits.  There's
a problem with phase one.  We're
going to spend a bit of time
digging into input  pipelines.
Now, you heard earlier from
Derek about tf.data.  This is
the far and away recommended
API and way to load data into
TensorFlow.  And here is if
you're doing simple image model,
for
example, ResNet50, it will start
like this.
Images batched together into tf
.record files.  You can shuffle
and repeat.  The parser function
you map across every input
image, that will do things
like parse the examples, jpg
decode, and
you batch it up and return the
dataset.
Now, if you run this on a
fancy-pants
CloudTPU, a modern accelerator,
only 150 images a second.  This
is nowhere near what you should
expect.
Now, before you think, wow,
cloud TPUs must be garbage, I'm
going back to what I was doing
before, it behooves you to try
to optimize performance.  When
you're optimizing performance,
it's important to follow a
methodology.  You have to
measure your performance, find
your bottleneck, optimize your
bottleneck and repeat.
What does that look like with a
cloud TPU.
There's tools in TensorFlow for
GPUs and TPUs.
But you have capture TPU
profile.
And you can run this to --
pointing it to your TPU.  In
this case, the
TPU's name is Seta.  And capture
into a profile log directly.
The same as with TensorBoard.
With that, I would like to
switch to
the laptop where you can see
what the profileing tools look
like.
Here it a trace from actually
the very same input pipeline, or
similar to the input pipeline I
just showed.  And you can see
here that your step time graph,
you have this tiny bit of orange
at the bottom.  And this is the
compute time on the cloud TPU.
And everything up here, it had
blue, that's actually waiting
for data.  That's input pipeline
processing.  So, our TPU is
sitting idle and this
is telling you 92% of the  time.
Totally, totally not what we
want to be  doing.  So, let's
dig in.
Now, what I recommend  using --
we have a bunch of tools and
they're constantly improving and
getting better.  To really
understand what's going on
underneath the hood, we're going
to use the trace viewer.
So, here I've loaded it up.  One
thing I should note, the trace
viewer is
designed for power users.  It
may be a little bit
unapproachable.  Let me walk you
through where to look in the
trace viewer.  In the top, you
have the TPU.
Now, one cloud TPU has eight
compute cores.  And these
operate independently, although
typically they're operating on
the same sorts of data, just in
parallel.  So, these are on the
top you can see your step
number.  You can see the
TensorFlow ops that it's
executing, and finally with the
XLA ops.
So, TPUs are programmed by XLA
and you can see what's going on
underneath the hood.  Below
that, the CPU compute threads.
These are the general TensorFlow
thread pool threads.  The
iterator thread.  And finally, a
set of threads for in-feed and
out-feed.
These are managing DMAs to and
from the TPU device.  Now, it's
a little hard to see at the top,
so, we're going to need to zoom
in.  We're going to need to look
in a little bit more depth.
In order to navigate around
within the  trace, the keyboard
shortcuts are the
most useful.  Keyboard shortcuts
are from the left hand.  A and D
move left and right.  W and S
move in and out.  So, this is a
little bit like the
arrow on like a key pad, just
like with your left hand on the
home row.  There's a couple
other keyboard shortcuts.  So,
for example, if you click on
something, you can see the
details about what this is.  And
if you press F, you'll focus in
on just that sort of element of
the timeline.
So, you can zoom in and navigate
around really easily.  If you
want to see a little bit more
about it, you can press M.  This
marks it on the UI.
You can see that our step time,
our training step took 5.4
seconds.
We go to the infeed queue, that
was also 5.4 seconds.
So, let's dig into what's going
on the
CPU since the TPU is sitting
idle  waiting for data.  There's
a lot of things going on.  We
need to zoom in a lot farther.
Not just at the second range,
but down to the millisecond
range.  Here we can see each of
those vertical bars, that's 5
milliseconds, okay?
And if we zoom in this far, we
can see that our iterator is
running  continuously, and the
map function is what's taking
the longest amount of time.
Okay?  The map  function,
there's a bunch of other little
ops that are happening here that
are your batching or your
repeating or whatnot.
But the map function is the bulk
of the time.  That's are the
focus of the optimization
efforts.  And the map function
runs the elements
of the map on your normal,
standard TensorFlow thread pool.
And look closely, we can zoom in
further, no two ops running at
the same  time.  We're using
multiple threads in the thread
pool, this is processing single
threaded.  That leads to the
first optimization.
I'm going to switch back to the
slides.  This is what you need
to do to use multiple threads
for your input pipeline for your
map function.
Hit numb parallel calls to 64
and you'll be using up to 64
threads, and
because cloud TPUs are hooked up
to a
powerful machine, you can use
all of these threads
concurrently.
If you do this and rerun your
model, you have a 4X
improvement, over 600 images a
second.  That's pretty great.
But, we're not done.  An
important part of the
performance methodology is step
three.  Repeat.  You have to
repeat again.  So, we take a new
trace.  I'm not going to do it
live on the  laptop.  Because we
want to go through.  We have a
lot of stuff to cover.  We now
see right here.  We have a lot
more compute threads
going on, but we're still very
much input-bounder.  And if we
zoom in a lot, you can actually
see that the bottom element
here, this tf.
record, waiting for data to load
from the file system.  We
process things in parallel
quickly
and take a while to transfer
them to the device over PCIE.
This presents a pipelining
opportunity.
Now, to give you a bit of
intuition for what I mean, input
pipelines you should mentally
associate with ETL.  Extract is
the first phase where you
load the data from storage.
Transform phases to prepare for
training.
And finally load into the
accelerator.
Not just in the API, but a
useful mental model for
performance.  To give you a bit
of intuition for that, each of
the different phases of ETL use
different hardware components in
your server system.
The extract phase is
emphasizing the disk in the
storage system or the network
link if you're from a remote
storage system.
Transform typically happens on
CPU and it's  CPU-hungry.  And
your load phase is emphasizing
the DMA, your connections to
your accelerator.
This is true with a GPU, TPU or
any other accelerators you might
be using.  And so what's going
on is if you map this out over
time, you're extracting and
while you're extracting, you're
doing nothing with the  CPU.
And during a transform phase,
doing nothing with the
connection between the CPU
memory and the accelerator.  And
training, the entire CPU and the
rest of the machine is sitting
idle.
This is incredibly wasteful.
Because they're all using
different components in the
system, you can actually overlap
all of this in a
technique called software
pipelining.
So, you are extracting for step
five, transforming for step
four, loading data for step
three and training for step two.
This is an efficient use of your
compute resources.  You can
train faster.  You'll notice in
a well-pipelined
model, your accelerator will be
100% utilized.
But it's possible that your CPU
or disk will be a little bit
idle.  That's okay.
Your accelerator is typically
your most protecter resource.
That's the bottleneck.
It's okay if the others are
slightly faster than you need
them to be.
How do you enable software
pipelining with datasets?
Set numb Juried parallel Juried
reads to 32.
And it's using party interleaf.
A key dataset transformation
that anaI believes pipelining.
And you can set the prefetches
right at the end.
And that means everything is
pipelined with
everything below.  Your
extraction is pipelined from
your loading into your
accelerator.
Now, one thing I want to
mention, when
you net numb numb_parallel_reads
is
equal to 32, you're using
parallel_reads.  We have
conflated these in the API
because we believe that
distributed storage is critical
going forward for machine
learning  workloads.  Why is
that?  As we have the research,
we see that datasets are going
to become larger and larger over
time.  So, you're really going
to  need -- they just won't fit
on a single machine.  You need
to distribute them across a
cluster.
Additionally, when you have data
disaggregated from your
accelerator
nodes, it means you can more
efficiently share your
accelerator nodes.  If you're
training on them today or
tomorrow and in three minutes
someone else wants to train,
you're not  copying datasets
around.  It's easier to use.
And finally, it makes it a lot
nicer doing large-scale
hyperparameter searches.  You
have one
cluster and a fungible pool of
resources.  We believe that
districted resources are
important and we have  worked
hard to make that fast with tf.
data.  So, what happens when you
do this?
It turns out, the cloud TPU,
you'll get over 1700 images a
second.  With these
optimizations.
So, we're now about 12 times
faster than our initial input
pipeline with less than 60
characters worth of typing.  So,
that's pretty good.  But we can
do better.  If you capture the
trace, you'll actually see that
our transform step is slightly
longer than our accelerator
trading model time.  The TPU is
just too fast.  And we need to
break out some advanced
optimization techniques that are
available today.  One of the
most powerful ones is to
use these fuse dataset
operators, map
and batch, shuffle and repeat,
fusing together the operations
to improve performance on your
CPU.  Tf.data works hard to
ensure that the elements
produced out of your dataset by
your iterator are in a
deterministic
order.  But if you give tf.data
the opportunity to reorder, we
can enable performance
optimizations.  We can use
sloppy interleave
underneath the hood, working
around variability in similar
storage systems.  There's other
tweaks you can do.  And apply
them together in this optimized
input pipeline, we get over
2,000 images a second and we are
now accelerator bound.
Here is TensorBoard, and
everything is 100% orange.  We
are entirely accelerator bound
and it's churning 100% of the
time.  This is great.  We can
now start looking into
optimizations that we can do on
the TPU to make the TPU faster.
We can see that our CPU is idle.
We can see that there's some
overhead, reshape and copy that
we might think
about optimizing away with some
device-specific optimizations.
Which brings me to phase two.
Now, as I mentioned before,
we're in
this sort of Cambrian explosion.
We're still in the early days,
we're finding that a lot of the
accelerators work differently.
Some chips
are  smaller, some chips are
bigger,
some chips use HBM- HBM-2, for
example, TPUs and CPUs.  Some do
away with that entirely,
Graphcore's IPU and optimized
for communication.  And it's
hard to provide out of the box
performance recommendations that
are going to apply to all of
these different hardware
platforms.  That said, there's a
few common things if we peer
into the future, gaze into
our crystal balls, we think this
is what we're going to see more
of.
What I expect to see a lot of is
interesting numerical formats.
This is a 32-bit format we know
and love.
Most models today have been
trained in  fp32.
There is great work at NVIDIA
and
Baidu, and you can train an
fp16, pf32, but the activations
in fp16.  This is a big win on
two dimensions.  You can run a
larger model because more layers
fits in memory.  But
additionally, your model tends
to
run faster, because accelerators
today, GPUs and TPUs are not
compute-bound.
They're actually memory
bandwidth bound.
The memory is too slow.
So fp16 can unlock a lot of
great performance on devices.
But one other floating point
format, there's bfloat 16.  And
this is different than fp16.
Even though it uses just 16
bits.  The range is us same as
fp32.  You don't worry as much
about
vanishing or exploding gradients
and NANs that you might when
using fp16.  There are a number
of numerical formats such as
flex point.
Folks from Intel parenned at
NIPS is in a poster section.  We
are going to make it easier to
use the numerical floating
formats.
Stay tuned for APIs in this
space.  Another hardware trend
is optimization
nor matrix optimization.
Especially in this mode.
In Volta GPUs, they have tensor
cores with.
TPUs are built around a 128X128
matrix unit.
This is a systolic array, this
tran
sisser configs ration that makes
it easy
to compute convolutions.
And here is showing a systolic
array does.  It's named after
the heart, which is pumping
blood in these cycles.
Plumbs
through the data and you get
fast matrix multiplication.
What this means, because we're
seeing
hardware-supported matrix
multiplication at different
sizes and scales, the way you
lay out the data and implement
it, can make a huge difference
on performance on these
accelerators.
Here I'm calling out two
different models running on
GPUs.
You use channels last, you end
up losing a fair bit of
performance compared to a
channels-first implementation.
If you compare different LSTM
cell implementations, the folk
the at NVIDIA worked really hard
to make really fast
kernels for LSTMs and make it
available as part of the
package.
If you're using a GPU and want
better performance, use the
optimized libraries for your
platform.  This is true.  You
need to use the latest version
of TensorFlow.
We're constantly working on
performance improvements, and
cuDNN and Intel MKL we talked
about today.  And investigate
16-bit numerical
representations.  We see a lot
of potential
performance advantages there.
And doing inference, we have
talked about TensorFlow RT,
which is available
for NVIDIA platforms that can
quantize and make inference
really fast.  And as part of the
technique, if you see, for
example, that a particular
computation is a bottleneck, you
can substitute it with
somethings that computationally
faster.
You have Tor careful because you
may change the quality of the
model doing this.  With that, I
would like to move on to phase
three.  Now, typically, when you
use an accelerator, you're
actually using more than one
accelerator.  You're using a
single device, it may have
different components that
operate in parallel.
Here is, for example, a picture
of the
NVIDIA DGX-1 and shows the
connectivity between the GPUs.
You have two of four each with
connectivity between them.  If
you don't take advantage of the
topology, if you do a naive
gradient
within the server going via the
CPU or TCIP switches, it will be
a significant
disadvantage due to a clever
utilization by nickel and CCL-2.
We have an optimizeed
implementation available as part
of the benchmarks, but
it's a little tricky to use.  We
are working on making this easy
for everyone to use in
distribution strategies.  And
you'll hear more about
distribution strategies in just
a few minutes.
TPUs, you also need to carefully
aggregate your gradients.
And we have the cross John
Boehner shoredoptimizer.
You take the existing SGD and
just
wrap it with a TPU cross
shardoptimizer.
This will aggregate across the
compute shards within a single
device.  But the exact same code
works all the
way up to a whole cloud TPU pod
across 64 different devices.
Now, I want to take one moment
to actually talk a little bit
about measuring performance.  I
guess the saying goes, there's
lies, damn lies and statistics.
Well, I'm going do add a fourth
one.  Performance benchmarks.
The Internet is pleat with
shoddy benchmarks and
misinformation.  And
this irks me to no end.
We have seen benchmarks, they
use
synthetic data or measuring only
certain subsets.  You have
incomplete comparisons.  One
benchmark is comparing the full
device.  One is comparing only
one part of the device.  We've
seen bugs in the machine
learning where they've optimized
a way, or done performance
tricks that make it run faster,
but actually make it not
converge to the same accuracy.
You've lost quality of your
model.
Additionally, as we look
forward, this is actually, to be
fair, a nuanced space.  And
hardware is harder and harder to
give an apples to apples
comparison.
We have different numerical
formats and different algorithms
fit better on different
hardware.  Some chips have small
amounts of memory.  If you have
a very, very big model that
can't fit, that's a very unfair
comparison.  As a result, I
strongly encourage you, if
you're trying to choose and
evaluate different hardware
platforms, take your
workloads and measure them end
to end
to the accuracy you want in the
application.  That's a fair
amount of work.
If you can't run your own
workloads,
look to quality end to end
benchmarks that measure
accuracy.  And I think a good
example is Stanford's DAWNBench.
There's nuance in the parameters
of how they're set.
For example the dataset size, a
small dataset size or a large
dataset size.  And there's
nuance in how to set the
accuracy threshold.
Despite these, it's a lot harder
to perform well on an end to end
benchmark and not work on real
work.  You're less likely to be
mislead looking at the end to
end benchmarks.
That said, we're pushing for the
end- end-to-end benchmarks,
there's a lot of
utility in microbenchmarks to
understand how fast are the
components.
When I was optimizeing ResNet50
for
the cloud TPU case, how did I
know it was slow?
As Derek mentioned, input
pipelines can have over  13,000
images a second.  That's using
VDG pre-processing.  This
pre-processing is
computationally
cheaper than the ResNet on
Inception pre-processing, but
shows we can go really, really
fast.
ResNet50 on a
DGS-1, this is using a mixed
precision 16.  This is have
TensorFlow nightly.  This is the
performance you can expect in
the  future.  Now, if you want
to test the performance of the
GPUs themselves in isolation,
that's about 6.1 synthetic
images a second.  You are
excluding the cost of your input
pipeline.
For a cloud TPU we have a few
other microbenchmarks.  For
TensorFlow 1  1.7 that's
available today, you can expect
to achieve 2 .
6-5,000 images a second, mixed
flow B16.
You're streaming the data in
with a
batch size of  32, and get over
76% accuracy in about 13 hours.
If you lop off the input
pipeline and just test the
device performance, you're
actually over 3200 images a
second, which is very cool with
TensorFlow 1.7.
And with TensorFlow nightly,
coming in TensorFlow  1.
8, we have optimized the input
pipeline performance, and you go
from 2600
images a second to over 300
image 0 images a second in
TensorFlow 1.8.  Very exciting.
A lot of work happening
underneath the hood.  As we
stare into the future even
further, what is coming in
TensorFlow with performance?
This is actually our optimized
input pipeline, or something
very close to it, and you'll
notice there's a lot of magic
numbers we have hand-tuned and
picked out.  How did we choose
them?  We spent a lot of time
playing around with it and
picking them out.  Do you need
to do that?  There's no reason
you need to do that.  We can
autotune a lot of these values
and we're working on adding in
smarts to
TensorFlow to tune your
pipelines.  This is true not
just for the magic
numbers, but for these fused
dataset operations functions,
we'll be working
on switching a naive
straightforward implementation
to use the functions underneath
the hood.  If you give us
permission, we'll be
able to adjust things where
we're not preserving necessarily
the order,
but we can do the right things
for you.
Automatically  tuning the
prefetch buffer size, that last
line, that's available and
coming in TensorFlow 1.8.  We're
not just working on optimizing
the input  pipelines, we're
working on
optimizing in-device
performance.
There's XLA and grab grappler.
And they're rewriting the model
to work well on different
platforms.  There's exciting
work here that we will be
excited to share with you over
time.
There's a lot more reading and
there's a huge amount of
literature on this.  Check out
some of these things.
If you want to learn about
reduced precision  training,
here are references.  And I'll
Tweet out this link shortly.
They'll be available and you can
load them up into TensorBoard
and play around with them
yourself.  With that, thank you
very much for listening to me
today.
[ Applause ]
Next up is Mustafa who is going
to talk
about TensorFlow's high-level
APIs.
>> Thank you, Brennan. Hello,
everybody.
[ Applause ]
My name is Mustafa.
Today I'll talk about
high-level
APIs, but keep practitioners
like you in mind.
To keep you in mind, we'll
provide an example to increase
user happiness by the power of
machine learning.
After defining the example
project,
we'll use pre-made estimators to
start our first experiment.
Then we'll experiment more with
every
feature we have by feature
columns.  And we'll introduce a
couple of pre-made estimators
that you can experiment more.
And we learn, how can you
experiment with other modeling
ideas too?
So, those are the topics we will
cover in this talk, and talk
about how to scale it up and how
you can use it in your
production.  Let's talk about
estimators.  So, it's a library
that lets you focus on your
experiment.  There are thousands
of engineers.
This is not a small number.
And hundreds of projects in
Google who use estimators.  So,
we learned a lot from their
experiments.
And we created our APIs so that
the time from an idea to an
experiment will be as short as
possible.
So -- and I'm really happy to
share
all this experience with all of
you.  Whatever we are using
internal at
Google is the same as the open
source.
So, you all have the same
things.  Estimator keeps the
model function.  We'll talk
about what the model
function is later, but it
defines your network and how can
you train or what is
the behavior during the
evaluation or during the export
time?
And it provides you some loops
such as training, evaluation,
and it provides
you some interface to integrate
with tf.  Also, estimator keeps
sessions so you
don't need to learn what is  tf.
session.  It handles it for you.
But you need to provide data.
And as Derek mentioned, you can
return a tf.data set from your
input function.  So, let's
define our project and start
with our experiment.  I love
hiking.  This is one of the
pictures I took in one of my
hikes.
And let's imagine there's a
website,
hiking website, similar to IMDB,
but it's for hiking.
And that website has information
for each hike, and users are
labeling those hikes by saying,
I like this hike, I don't like
this hike, this is my rating,
and all this stuff.  And we want
to use this data.  Let's imagine
you have this data from that
website.
To recommend hikes for users.
How can we do that?
There are many ways of doing it.
Let's define one way machine
learning can help us.
In this case, we want to predict
probability of like.
Whether a given user will like a
given hike or not.
What you have, you have hike
features and user feature
features.  And where can you
learn from?  The label data, you
can have whether users like that
hike or not.
So, whack we use to predict if
they like a hike?
You can use one of the pre-made
estimators.
In this case, the  pre-made
estimator.
It's a binary estimation
problem.
We designed estimators to go to
this kind of problem.
This means you can use it as a
black box solution.
Pre-made estimators are
surprisingly
popular within Google and in
many projects.  Why?  The
engineers are using pre-made
solutions instead of building
their own models.
I think, first of  all, it
works.  It handles many
implementations so you can focus
on your experiment.
It has reasonable defaults for
initialization, partitioning, or
optimization so you have a
reasonable baseline as quick as
possible.  And it is easy to
experiment with new features.
So, we learn about that.
You can experiment with all of
your
data by using the same estimator
without changing it.  So, let's
jump into our first
experiment so that we can have a
baseline that we will improve.
I will talk about  it, but in
this
case, you are useing hike
_id, it might be hike name, as
an identification to your model.
And say you have hidden_units
one.  What this will learning
with it will learn the label for
each hike idea.
That may be a good baseline for
your overall progress.
You need to say what is your
evaluation data, what is your
training data?
Then you can call train and
evaluate.  Just by this couple
of lines of code, you should be
able to experiment.
And you can see the results on
the TensorBoard.  For example,
you can see training and
evaluation.  Or how the metric
is moving.  Since this is a
classification problem, you will
see accuracy metric.
And this is a binary estimation,
you will see that.  All of these
things are free and ready to be
used.  Let's experiment more.
Let's start with the data.
Experimenting with the data
itself.  The design feature
columns with the same mind-set.
We want to make it -- make it
easy to experiment with your
features, with your data.
And based on our experience --
internal experience -- it
reduces the lines of code and
may improve the model.
There are a bunch of
transformations you can handle
via feature columns.
These are bucketing, crossing,
hashing and embedding.
Each of these needs a careful
explanation.  Unfortunately I
don't have enough time
here, but you can check Magnus's
tutorial and the video, they are
very good.  Let's experiment
with all the hike features we
have.
Each hike may have text such as
kid friendly, dog  friendly,
birding.
You may choose indicator column
instead of embedding column in
this case because you don't have
a huge number of tags.  You
don't need the dimension.  And
for a numerical column, such as
each hike may have elevation
gain, you need to normalize so
that optimization will be
well-conditioned.
Your problem with condition.
And you can use a normalizer
function here.
Or, you may choose buckettizing.
In this case, the distance of
the
hike, we bucket-ize it so it
will learn the model for
different things for different
segments.  You can concentrate
as a different kind of
normalization too.  How can you
use all of these things
together?
Just putting them into a list,
that's it.  Then your system
should work.  So, let's
experiment with personalization.
What we mean by personal
ization is instead of
recommending the same hikes to
all users, let's recommend
different hierarchies for
different
users based on their interests.
And the way -- one way to do
that is  using user features.
In this case, we are using user
embedding by embedding_column.
So, this will let the model to
learn a
vector for each user and put the
users closer if their hike
preferences are similar.  And
how can you use that?
Again, it's just depending into
your list.
And you need to also play with
hidden units because rough
minimal  features now and you
need to let your model to learn
different transformations.  And
the rest of the pipeline should
work.
You will hear this a lot during
this talk because it's based on
that.  The rest of the pipeline
should work and you should be
able to analyze your
experiments.  Let's experiment
more.
We have a couple of pre-made
solutions.  I mentioned it's
very popular and I picked only
two of them here to show.
One is wide-n-deep,
it's a joint training of the
neural network and the model.
You may like it or not.  So
let's start the experiment.  You
need to define what are the
features you want to fit to the
neural network.
Again, via feature column, it's
the list.
And you need to define the
features to feed into the linear
part.
In this  case, user id and
picks.  For example, if a user
always picks
dog of had friendly-friendly
hikes, the model will learn this
feature.
And you can instantiate dnn and
the rest of the pipeline should
work.
Baseed on the
2017 Kaggle survey, they are
very popular.  And we are
introducing gradient
boosted trees as a pre-made
estimator.
And you can experiment without
changing your pipeline.  Let's
start our experimentation.
In the current version, we only
support buckettized column.  And
we are working to support
numerical column and cot
categorical column too.  Here is
hike distance and hike elevation
gain.
And we buckettize them.  And
then you can
have the classifier and the rest
of thepipe line should work.
We know that  trees are those at
computationally expensive -- or
training
trees is not as computationally
expensive as training neural
networks.  And they fit into
memory.  So, by leveraging that,
we provide you
a utility so that you can train
your
model in order of magnitude
faster than the usual one.  And
the rest of the pipeline should
work.
So, let's say this solutions are
not enough for you and you want
to experiment more ideas.  Let's
talk about them.
Before delve into this
high-level
solutions that you can use,
let's look at a network in a
supervised  setting.  In this
case, you have a network which
you fit the features.  And based
on the output of network and
the labels, you need to decide
what is the loss?  What is the
objective you want to minimize?
And what is -- what are the
metrics
that you will use as a success
metric for your  evaluation?
And your predictions on serving
time may be
didn't than in training time.
For example, if you have a large
setting, you may want to use
just the
ranking of the classes instead
of the priorities in the serving
time.
For that you don't need to
calculate the priority.  You can
use the losses to rank them.
For all of these, we can
sectored
them out under head API.  It
expects you to give the label
and out of your network and
provides these things for you.
You'll see it in action.  And
model function is an
implementation of this help and
network together.
We talk about the DNN class 5.
DNN class 5 has a model
function.
It has a specific implementation
for head network.
Let's implement this with the
head API.  In this case, DNN
estimator.  And we can
instantiate ahead.
In this case, it's binary
classification head because we
are trying to predict whether
it's like or not like.
And why are we introducing this
head
since these two lines are the
same as DNN classifier?  Why to
introduce this head?  So,
you can experiment with
different ideas by combining
different network architectures
and different heads.
For example, you can use
wide-ended, or DNN estimator
with a  multi-label head.
You can even combine different
heads together, we introduced
multi-head here.
So, it's the one way of
experimenting with the
multi-task learning.
With a couple lines of code you
can experiment with multi-task
learning.  Please check it out.
Say the architectures are not
enough for you and you want to
expand more, you can write your
own model function.
We strongly recommend to you to
use TFK layers to build your
network.  You can do whatever
you want there.  You can be as
creative as possible.  And after
you have the output of
network, you need to pick one of
the optimizers available in
TensorFlow.
And you can use one of the heads
we mentioned which will convert
your network had output and the
labels
into training behaviors or
evaluation
metrics or expart behavior
export
behaviors.  Then you can fit to
the estimator.  Again, the rest
of the pipeline should work.
Keras model is another way of
creating your model.
And it's very popular, it's very
intuitive to use.  For example,
this is one of the Keras models
you can build.
So, how can you get this
estimator so that the rest of
the pipeline should work?  You
can use model to estimator which
gives you the estimator so you
can run your experiments without
changing your pipeline.
Transfer learning is another
popular technique we  do.
Experiment with.
One way of extending is using
model A,
which is already the trend, to
improve the prediction of model
B.  How can you do that?
Surprisingly, just copying and
transferring from model A to
model B works.  That's simple,
but it works.
And we provide that for you.
You can use one start -- this
one line
is saying that transfer all of
the model A into model B.
Or, you can define a subset of
model A
to transfer from model A to
model B.  Let's talk
about image features.
We talk about embedding
categorical column and image
features.  But what if you have
image features,
how can you use them in your
pipeline with a couple of lines
of code?
You can implement one of the
image classifiers.
Which is not a couple of lines
of  code.
Or you can, thanks to TF-Hub,
you will learn later, you can
use one line from their hub to
instantiate the feature column,
called image  embedding column.
In this case, you may remember
Jeff
mentioned AutoML.  It is one of
the AutoML models.  It's really
good.  It's one of the top
models you can use.
Here you will use nasnet as a
feature.
It will use only the optimizeer
of nasnet into your feature.
How can you use it as the
classifier?
Just depending it into your
feature columns, and then done.
You can experiment with it.
Let's say you experimented and
you find some models, but you
need to scale it up.  Not all of
you, but some of you may need to
scale your training.
You can use multi-GPU, means
multiplication on different
GPUs.
You can learn about that after
my talk.  You don't need to
change the estimator or model
code.  Everything should work
with just a single line of
configuration change.  Or, you
may want to distribute your
training to multiple machines by
saying these are workers, these
are primary
servers and there's very little
going on.  Same.  You don't need
to change your estimator or
model code.  Everything should
work based on the configuration.
Or, you may want to use TPU
estimator for TPU.  There's a
minimal change in the model
function.  Hopefully later we
will fix that too.  But now
there's a minimal change in
your model function you need to
do.
To use this in your production,
you need to expart.  Or you can
-- you need to serve.
And we recommend you to use TF
serving.  In the serving time,
instead of reading data from the
files, you have a request.  And
you need to define the receiver
function, which is defining how
can you connect that into the
model?  In this case -- and
after that, what would be the
output of that model?  Which is
defined by a signature
definition.  So, here, again, a
couple of lines of code.  You
will export your chain model
with the TF serving.
For example, if your request is
tf.
example, you will use this
function to get your receiver
function.
And you can use export set model
so
that it will be used by TF
serving.
These are the modules I
mentioned,  tf.estimator, tf.
feature Curdy column.  Don't use
tf.learn, we are deprecating it.
And these are a couple that I
picked.  You can check it out.
Thank you.  I hope some of you
will improve your products with
the tools that we mentioned.
Thank you.
And I'll introduce Igor.
Igor will talk about how you can
do distribution with TensorFlow.
And he's coming.  Yes.  He's
coming.
>> Hey.
Hello, everyone.  My name is
Igor.  I'm going to -- I work in
the TensorFlow team and I'm
going to talk to
you today about distributed
TensorFlow.  Well, why would you
care about distributed
TensorFlow?  Many of you know
the  answer, probably.
But just in case, it's a way for
your models to train faster and
be more parallel.
It's a way for you to get more
things done, iterate quicker.
When you train in models, it can
take a long time.  And when I
say a long time, I mean week
weeks.
Without  With all the available
hardware to you out there,
scaling up to hundreds of
CPUs or GPUs are really make a
difference.  How could you scale
up?
Well, you could just add a GPU
to your machine.  In this case,
this is just plug and play.
You insert a GPU, TensorFlow
handles all the details for you
and you see a nice bump in the
training speed.
You could also insert multiple
GPUs.
In this case -- in this case,
you would have to write
additional code.  You need to
replicate
your model.  You need to combine
gradients from
every GPU and if you're using
batchnorm layer, you have the
tricky question of what to do
with the statistics on each GPU.
The point I'm trying to make is
that you need to do additional
work to make this work.  And you
need to learn stuff that you
didn't plan on learning.  You
can also use multiple machines.
And this situation is similar to
the one before.  But in this
case, your bottleneck is
probably going to be that
communication between the
machines.  You'll start thinking
about minimizing that
communication and probably doing
more work locally.
For example, combining the
gradients in the local GPUs
before exchanging them with the
remote GPUs.  Unless specialized
network and hardware is used.
The coordination costs in this
setup
are probably going to limit your
scaling.  But there is an
approach -- there is a solution
to this.  This approach is
called parameter server.
Some hosts we call them
parameter servers.
They're going to only hold
training weights.  Other hosts,
workers, they're going to have a
copy of the TensorFlow graph.
They're going to get their own
input, compute their own
gradient, and then
just go ahead and update the
training waits without any
coordination with other workers.
So, this is an approach with low
coordination between a large
number of hosts.  And there you
go.  This scales well.  And we
have been doing this at Google
for a long time.  But there is a
wrinkle with this approach.  You
give up synchronicity.  And that
has benefits.  And if you think
about it, parameter
server approach, it's an
approach from
the -- from the CPU era.  With
all the reliable communication
between GPUs, we can consider
designs which have tighter
coupleing and more coordination
between the workers.
One such approach is based on
overages.  That's not a new
idea.
The general goal of all-reduce
is to combine all the values and
distribute results to all the
processes.  All-
reduce is kind of tricky to
explain in this light.
But you can think of its results
as reduce stipulation followed
by a broadcast stipulation.  But
don't think of it that way in
terms of performance.  It's a
fused algorithm.  And it's way
more efficient than those two
operations together.
In addition to it, hardware
vendors --
hardware vendors specialized or
reduce implementations that
TensorFlow could secretly use
behind the scenes to help you.
Alternative approaches.  They
typically send all data to a
central place.
All-reduce is not going to have
such a bottleneck because it
distributed coordination between
GPUs way more  evenly.
With every tick of all-reduce,
each GPU sends and receives a
part of the final answer.
So, how could all-reduce help us
with our models.
Well, consider -- let's say you
have two GPUs.
You copied layers and the
variables in every GPU and you
performed the forward pass, nice
and parallel.
But then during the backward
pass, as the gradients
become available, we can reduce
-- we
can use  all-reduce to combine
those gradients with the
counterparts from other GPUs.
In addition to that, because of
the
way -- in addition to that,
gradients
from the other layers are
available before the gradients
from the other layers.
So, we could overlap backward
propagation computation and
reduce communication.  That
gives you even more per second.
The bottom line is, when all --
when communication between GPUs
is reliable, all-reduce can be
fast and allow you to scale
well.
How could you use  all-reduce in
TensorFlow?
Well, so far in this talk I told
you to take advantage of
multiple GPUs you need to write
additional code, change your
model and learn stuff.
Chances are you're using --
you're following -- of using the
highest level API that works for
your use case.
That probably isette is
Estimator.  It is the model
function, it has no knowledge
about GPUs or devices.
So, to have that model use
multiple
GPUs, you just need to add one
line.
You need to pass an instance of
a new
class called
MirrormirrorStrategy.
And it is one implementation of
our new distribution strategy
API.  TensorFlow, how to
replicate your model?  Oops.
Sorry.
Another thing I want to say is
that MirrorStrategy could take a
number of GPUs or a list of GPUs
to use.  Or you cannot give it
any arguments at all and then it
will just figure out what GPUs
to use.
MirrorStrategy works in a way
exactly as I described before.
It replicates your model, it
uses  all-reduce for
communication.
So, gradient updates from every
GPUs, from all GPUs, they're
going to be combined before
updating the waits.  And each
copy of your model, an average
GPU, is part of a single
TensorFlow graph.  That means
there is the replication
with synchronous training that
uses all- all-reduce on many
GPUs.  Now, the last ten minutes
are kind of a waste of time for
you if this doesn't perform
well.
And it does perform well.  As
you add GPUs, this
implementation scales well.  We
have a team at TensorFlow that
specifically works on fast
implementations of all-reduce
for various machine
configurations.  And this
implementation gets 90% scaling
on 8 GPUs.
And, again, it didn't require
any
change to the -- to the user's
model.
It didn't require any change are
because we changed everything in
TensorFlow that's not your
model.
Things like optimizer, bench
norm, summaries, everything that
rides state, now needs to become
distribution aware.
That means it needs to learn how
to combine its state with other
GPUs.
And this is important because
alternative APIs out there, they
typically ask you to rephrase
your model
to supply optimizeers, for
example,
separately so that they can do
all the state coordination
behind the scenes.
And if you have some experience
with training your models on
multiple GPUs,
you might be wondering, well,
can  I -- can I save my model
own a computer with
8 GPUs and then do an
evaluation on it on a computer
with, say, no GPUs?  Typically
this causes a problem.
But with distribution strategy
API, we
maintain backward compatibility
on the checkpoint level.
So, Mirror Mirrorstrategy, it
has multiple copies on the GPU.
It's going to save one coupe,
and then at the restore time,
it's only going to restore that
state to a required number of
GPUs.
So, this use case is supported.
Distribution strategy works with
Eager mode as well.  But we are
still fine-tuning the
performance.
And distribution strategies are
a very general API that I hope
in the future will support many
use cases.
It's not tied to Estimator and
we are
looking into ways of creating
even more
-- better APIs based on
distribution strategy.
We -- in the future, soon,
pretty soon -- we intend to
support all kinds of -- many
kinds of distributed training.
Synchronous, asynchronous,
multi-node,
parallelism, all of that is as
part of distribution strategy
API.  Until then, for
multi-node, use estimator.train
and evaluate.
Or Horovod, that offers a
multi-node solution.
MirrorStrategy is available for
you in our nightly build.  And
we are very, very actively
working on it.
And it's a product of work of
many people.  And I would really
encourage you to try it out and
let us know what you think about
it.
By GitHub or talk to us after my
talk.  All right.  Thank you.
Thanks for your attention.
[ Applause ]
Next up is Justine and Shanging
to tell
you how to debug TensorFlow
using TensorBoard.
>> Well, thank you, everybody,
for being here today.
We're going to be giving a talk
about
the new TensorFlow debugger,,
which comes included with
TensorBoard.  It's basically a
debugger like you
would see in an IDE that lets
you step in separate points and
models and watch tensors.  But
before we do that, I would like
to
give you some background on
TensorBoard and some of the
other developments which
happened in the last year.
Which we unfortunately don't
have too
much time to go into.
But TensorBoard is basically a
weapon application.
It's a suite of weapon
applications that was authored
by about 20 people.
And it's all packed into a 2
megabyte command web server that
works offline.  And TensorBoard
can be used for many purposes
with the different plugins baked
into it.
The one you're all most familiar
with for those who have used
TensorBoard is the scalers
dashboard.  You can plot
anything you want.  It could be
like loss curves, et cetera,
accuracy.  And these
things like sort of help us
understand, like, whether or not
our model is converging on
optimal solutions.
And here is the really
interesting, underutilized
feature called the embedding
projector.  And this was
originally written by Google so
we could do things like, you
know, project our data into a 3D
space, see how things cluster.
doing MNIST, the 7s here and the
9s here.  And we actually
recently -- what you
see on the screen is we got a
really
cool contribution from Francois
at IBM research.
He sent pull requests on the
GitHub repository, since we are
in the open.  He  added
interactive label editing.  So,
you can sort of like go in there
and change things as algorithms
like
TSNE, give your data -- sort of
reveal the structure of your
data.
To learn more, search Google for
interactive super vision with
TensorBoard.  This is another
really amazing contribution that
we received from a university
student named Chris Anderson.
It's called the  holder plugin.
And this basically gives you a
real
real-time visual glimpse into
TensorFlow data structures.
Like, for example, as you're
training script is running, it's
real-time.  It doesn't require a
hard drive.  It doesn't work
with something like GCS at this
point in time.  I think this
would be a very useful tool
going forward in terms of model
explainability.
Now, TensorBoard also has some
new plugins for optimization.
Cloud recently contributed a TPU
profiling plugin.  And TPU
hardware is a little different
from what many of you might be
used to.  And TensorBoard, with
this plugin, can really help you
get the most out of your
hardware and ensure that it's
being properly utilize utilized.
Now, the TensorBoard ecosystem,
part of the goal of this talk,
before we get
into the demo, is I want to
attract more folks in the
community to get involveed with
TensorBoard development.  We use
many of the tools you're
familiar with such as TypeScript
and Polymer.
We also use some tools you might
not
be familiar with, luck Bazel,
for good reasons.
You can go to the Readmes for
the plugins we wrote originally.
Now, with TensorBoard, the
reason this is just a little bit
more challenging compared to
some of the other web
application you may have used or
written in the past, is we deal
with very challenging
requirements.  Like, this thing
needs to work offline.
It needs to be able to build,
regardless of, like, corporate
or national firewalls that may
block certain URLs when it's
downloading things.  For
example, one of the first things
I did when I joined the
TensorBoard team wasn't actually
visualizing machine learning,
but adding a contribution to
Bazel which allows  downloads to
be carrier grade
internationally.  And there are
a whole variety of challenges
like when it comes to an
application like this.
But those  burdens are things
we've mostly solved for you, and
here is a concrete example.
Writing that toilsome thousand
line
file
was what it took to make
TensorBoard look good anywhere
in the world without having to
ping.  That is one of the many
burdens that the TensorBoard
team carries on behalf of plugin
authors.
Now, I want to give you a quick
introduction for Shanging who is
the
author of this TensorFlow
debugger.
And with the help of Che  Che
Zhang.
As I mentioned earlier,
TensorBoard has been the flash
light that's giving broad
overviews of what's
happening inside these black box
models.
What the TensorFlow debuggers
does, it turns that flash light
into an X had-ray.  Using this
plugin, you can literally watch
the tensors as they flow in
real-time while having complete
control over the entire process.
This X-ray is what's going to
make it
possible for you to pinpoint
problems we've previously found
difficult to identify.
Perhaps down to the tiniest nan
at the precise moments they
happen.  That's why we call it
an X-ray.
It reveals the graph and math
beneath
the abstractions we love, Keras
or
Estimator, or as was announced
today,  swift.  Whatever tools
you're using, this
could potentially be a very
helpful troubleshooting tool.  I
would like to introduce its
author, Shanging, who can show
you a demo.
>> Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Okay.
So, in a moment the screencast
will start.  Great.
Thank you, Justine for the
generous intro.  I'm Shanging.
And I'm glad and honored to
present the feature plugin for
TensorBoard.
Among the many createed for
TensorBoard so far.  For those
that know TensorFlow
debugger or TFDGB, it's only had
a can command line interface
until recently.  Like the
command line interface, the
debugger plugin allows you to
look into internals of the run
in TensorFlow
model, but in a much more
intuitive and richer environment
in the browser.  In this talk
I'm going to show two examples.
One example of how to use the
tool to understand and probe and
visualize a working model that
doesn't have any bugs in it.
I'm also going to show you how
to use the tool to debug a model
with a bug in it so you can see
how to use the tool to catch the
road cause of problems and fix
them.
So, first, let's look at the
first example.  And that's the
example on the right part of the
screen right now.  It's a
simple TensorFlow program that
does some
regression using some generateed
synthetic data.
And if we run program in the con
console, we can see a constant
decrease in the loss value
during training.  Even though
the model works, we have no
knowledge how the model works.
That's mainly because in graph
mode, the sessions are run as a
black box.  That wraps all the
computation in one single line
of Python code.  What if we want
to look in the model?
Look at the matrix
multiplication in a dense layer
and have a gradient and so
forth?  The TensorFlow debugger
or TensorBoard debugger plugin
as a tool can allow you to do
that.
To start the tool, we start the
TensorBoard with the flat
debugger port.  We specify the
port to be 7,000.
Once it's running, we can
navigate to our TensorBoard URL
in the browser.  At the startup,
the plugin tells you it's
waiting for connections from
TensorFlow to run.  That's
because we haven't started
program yet.
And code snippets, estimators or
Keras models.
In this model, we're using tf.
session.  The first line is an
import line, and the second line
is a line that wraps are the
original objects with a special
wrapper that has the information
where to connect the port
number.
Now, without our -- with our
program implemented we can start
program again.  Now, as soon as
program  starts, we
can see the graphical user
interface in the browser switch
to a mode that shows you a graph
of the sessions that are run in
two ways.  In a tree view on the
left and in a graph on the
right.  On the bottom left
corner, you can also see what
session is currently executing.
The tree structure on the right
corresponds to name scopes in
your model.
For example, the dense layer --
the dense name scope corresponds
to the dense layer.  You can
open the source code to look at
the correspondence between the
graph nodes and the lines of the
path and program created those
programs.
If you click  nasnal, you can
see which line of the
path and source code is
responsible for creating that
node.  In this case, it's dense
layer.  As expected.
If you click another -- if you
click the last tenser, you will
see the corresponding node in
the graph.  You can see where
it's created in the path and
source code.  It's where we call
the me squared error.
And the gradients, name scope
corresponds to the back
propagation part of the model.
You can click around, poke
around and
explore how a TensorFlow model
does optimization and
propagation if you are
interested.  And these nodes are
created when we created the
decent optimizer.  You can
continue to any node of the
graph and pause there.
So, we have just continued to
the m node in the dense layer.
And you can continue to the
gradient at the matmul.  And we
did.  And you can see the
summaries of the tensor values.
You can look although the data
type, their shape and also the
range of their values.
So, in the so-called health
pills, you can look at how many
of those
values are zero and negative or
positive and so forth.  You
hover over those, you can get
more information such as the
mean and the standard deviation
of the values in the tensor.
So, next, we can click these
links to
open a detailed view of the
tensors.
You can apply  slicing to reduce
the dimensionality so it's easy
to look at the values.  We have
reduced the dimension from 2 to
1, looking at it as a curve.
Now continue to the loss tensor.
Which is a scaler.  And yep.
It's a scaler.  And the shape is
an empty list as we can see
here.  We can switch to the
history -- full history modes.
We can look at how the value
changes as it is being trained.
So, with the full history mode
enabled, we can continue other
the sessions.  Like 50 of them.
We can see in real-time how the
loss value decreases and how the
value on the Matmul changes.
That's how you can use it as an
X-ray animater for the models to
have a better  understanding how
your model works.  Next, let's
look at a broken model.
That's the debug model we ship
with TensorFlow.  That's the
only broken model we ship with
TensorFlow as far as I know, and
I'm proud to be the author of
it.  We can see that the model
doesn't quite work.  After two
iterations of training, the
accuracy is stuck at about 10%.
We suspect there might be bad
numerical values like not a
number or infinities.  But we're
not sure which nodes of the
graph are responsible for
generating those infinities.
To answer that question, we can
use the debugger tool.  We do a
refresh in our browser.
And then we can start our debug
MNIST example to connect to the
debugger plugin.
So, again, we're looking at the
graph.  Now, in order to find
the nodes
responsible for that infinities,
we can look at the watch points.
And use the conditional break
points
feature to continue running the
model until any tenser includes
it.
You are  seeing a list of tensor
values.  Those a complete list
of tensors involved in training
the
model.  In a moment, the model
is stopping
because it hit an infinity in
the
tensor, cross entropy/log.  We
can see in the health pill and
see
in the detailed tenser view
those orange lines.  Showing you
the infinity values.  Now, the
question is, why do those
infinity values happen?  So, we
can go back to the source code
and find the line of Python code
where
it's created and that's where
it's tf.lot.  And we can open up
the graph view and we see the
inputs.  So, we can trace the
inputs.
In this case, the input is the
softmax tensor.  We can expand
and highlight and look at the
value of the inputs, which is
softmax.
There are, indeed, five values
of the is tensor.  And the
reason for infinity is because
we have log of zero.  With that
knowledge, we can go back to the
source code and fix it.  We're
not going to do this in this
demo here.  All right.
So, that's the TensorBoard
debugging.  And I encourage you
to use it, explore it.  And
hopefully it will help you
understand your
model better and help you fix
bugs much more quickly.  You can
just use this simple command
line, TensorBoard, with a
special flag.  With that, I
would like to hand this back to
Justine.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you, Shanging. I
thought that was a really
interesting demo.
And it is -- and it was a great
leap forward for TensorBoard.
And it really shows that one of
the things we have been doing
recently is, rather than being a
read-only reporting tool, we're
trying to explore more
interactive directions as we
have shown you today.
These are things folks who are
productionizing TensorBoard,
such as cube flow, should take
into consideration.
We want to attract more
contributors.  We have two
approaches for this where you
can develop an artificial repo
and send us pull requests.  We
do our work in the open.  This
does need approval on security
footprint, et cetera.  And there
is an escape hatch if that
doesn't work out.
You can independently develop
plugins, you can create custom
static builds without anyone's
approval.  You can do whatever
you want.  Because part of the
goal on this team
is to liberate the tools.
With that said, I want to thank
all of you for attending.  And
thank you watching on YouTube.
If you like this talk, hashtag
Tweeter or, you know, reach out.
Thank you, again.
[ Applause ]
Test.  Test.
>> Hi, everyone.
Hope everybody had a good lunch.
I'm Sarah Sirajuddin, an
engineer on activity.  And my
colleague, Andrew Aselle, also
on the same team.  And we are
excited to talk about the work
we have been doing to bring
machine learning to mobile
devices.
So, in today's talk, we'll cover
three areas.
First, how machine learning on
devices is different and
important.  Then we'll talk
about all the work
that we have been doing
on TensorFlow Lite.
And then how you can use it in
your apps.  Let's talk about
your devices.
Usually a device is a mobile
device, basically a phone.  Our
phones are with us all the
times.
These days they have lots of
censors giving rich data about
the world around us.
And lastly, we use the phones
all the time.
Another category of devices is
edge devices.
And this industry has seen a
huge growth in the last few
years.  By some estimates that
are 23 billion
connected devices, smart
speakers, smart
watches, smart sensors, with
what
have you.  And technology that
only was available on the most
expensive  devices is now
available on the cheaper ones.
So, this rapid increase in the
availability of these more and
more
capable devices has now opened
up many opportunities for doing
machine learning on device.  In
addition to that, though, there
are several other reasons why
you may consider doing on device
machine learning.  And probably
the most important one is
latency.
So, if you're processing
streaming
data such as audio or video,
then you don't want to be making
calls back and forth to the
server.  Other reasons are that
your processing
can happen even when your device
is offline.  Sensitive data can
stay on device.  It's more
power-efficient because the
device is not sending data back
and forth.  And lastly, we are
in a position to
take advantage of all the sensor
data that is already present on
the device.  So, all that is
great.  But there's also a
catch.
And the catch is that on-device
machine
learning is hard.  And the
reason it is hard is that many
of these devices have some
pretty tight constraints.
Small batteries, low compute
power, tight memory.
And TensorFlow wasn't a great
fit for this.  And that is the
reason we built TensorFlow Lite.
Which is a light-weight library
and tools for doing machine
learning on embedded and small
platforms.  So, we launched
TensorFlow Lite late last year
in developer preview.  And since
then we have been working on
adding more features and support
to it.  So, I'll just walk you
through the high-level design of
the system.  We have the
TensorFlow Lite format.  This is
different from what TensorFlow
uses and we had to do so for
reasons of efficiency.  Then
there's the interpreter, which
runs on device.
Then there are a set of
optimized kernels.  And they are
there are interface which is you
can use to take advantage of
hardware acceleration when it is
available.
It's  cross-platform, so, it
supports Android and iOS.  And
I'm really happy to say today
that we also have support for
Raspberry Pi and pretty much
most other devices which are
running Linux.
So, the developer workflow
roughly is that you take a
trained TensorFlow model and
then you convert it to the
TensorFlow Lite format using a
converter.  And then you update
your apps to
invoke the interpreter using the
Java or C++ APIs.  One other
thing that I want to call out
here is that iOS developers have
another option.
They can convert the trained
TensorFlow graph into the CoreML
graph
and use the CoreML run time
directly.
And this TensorFlow to CoreML
converter is something we worked
on
together with the folks that
built CoreML.  There are top of
the mind every time you talk
about TensorFlow Lite.
The two most common, is it small
in size?  And is it fast?  Let's
talk about the first one.
Keeping TensorFlow Lite small
was a key goal for us when we
started building this.  So, the
size of our interpreter is only
75 kilobytes.  When you include
all the supported ops, this is
400 kilobytes.  Another thing
worth noting here is a feature
called selective registration.
So, developers have the option
to only include the ops that
their models need and link
those.  And thereby keep the
footprint small.  So, how do we
do this?  So, first of all, we
have been pretty
careful in terms of which
dispense dependencies we
include.  And TensorFlow Lite
uses flat buffers
which are more memory efficient
than critical buffers.  And
moving on to the next question,
which is performance.
Performance, a super-important
goal for us.  And we made design
choices throughout the system to
make it so.
So, let's look at the first
thing, which is the TensorFlow
Lite format.
So, we use flat buffers to
represent models.
And FlatBuffer is it a
cross-platform serialization
library developed for game
performance, and since used in
other sensitive applications.
And the advantage of using
FlatBuffers is we are able to
access data without going
through heavy weight, parsing or
steps of the large files which
contain weights.  Another thing
we do at the conversion
is we look at the biases and
that allows us to execute faster
later on.
The TensorFlow Lite interpreter
uses static memory and execution
plans which allows us to load up
faster.
There are a set of optimized
kernels which have been
optimized to run fast on
the NEON and ARM platforms.  We
wanted to build TensorFlow Lite
so
that we can take advantage of
all the innovations that are
happening in silicon for these
devices.  So, the first thing
here is that
TensorFlow Lite supports the
Android neural network API.
The Qualcomm HVX is coming out
soon.
And MediaTek and others have
announceed their integration
with Android neural network API.
So we should be seeing those in
the coming months as well.
Second thing here is we have
also been working on adding
direct GPU acceleration.
And useing Metal on iOS.
So, quantization is the last bit
that I want to talk about in the
context of performance.
So, roughly speaking,
quantization is
this technique to store numbers
and perform calculations on them
in representations that are more
exact than 32-bit floating point
numbers.  This is important for
two reasons.  One, the smaller
the model, the better it is for
these small devices.
Second, many processers have
specialized instruction sets
which process fixed point
operations much  faster than
they process floating point
numbers.
So, a very naive way to do point
optimization would be to shrink
the
weights and activations after
you're done training.
But that leads to suboptimal
accuracies.  So we have been
working on doing quantityization
at training time.
And we have recently released a
script which does this.  What we
have seen is for architectures
and inception, we are able to
get accuracies that are similar
to their floating point
counterparts while seeing pretty
impressive gains in the
latencies.  So, I've
talked about a bunch of
different performance
optimizations.  Now let's see
what all of these translate to
together in terms of numbers.
So, these are two models that we
benchmarked and we ran them on
the Android Pixel 2 phone.  We
were running these with four
threads and using all the four
large cores of the Pixel 2.
And what you see is that we are
seeing
that these quantized models run
three times faster on TensorFlow
Lite than their floating point
counterparts on TensorFlow.
So, I will move on now and talk
about whats supported on
TensorFlow Lite.
So, currently, it is limited to
inference only, although we are
going to be working on
supporting training in the
future.  We support 50
commonly-used operations which
developers can use in their own
models.  In addition, they can
use any of these popular open
source models that we support.
One thing to note here is that
we have an extensible design,
so, if a developer
is trying to use a model which
has an app not currently
supported, they
have the option to use what we
call a custom op and use that.
And later in this talk, we will
show you some code snippets on
how you can do that yourself.
So, this is all theory about
TensorFlow Lite.  Let me show
you a quick video of TensorFlow
Lite in practice.
So, we took this simple
mobile-like
model and we retrain on some
common objects that we could
find around our office.  And
this is our demo classification
app, which is already open
sourced.  As you can see, it is
able to classify these object
objects.
[ Laughter ]
So, that was demo.  Now let's
talk about production stuff.
So, I'm very excited to say we
have been working with other
teams in Google to bring
TensorFlow Lite to Google apps.
So, the portrait mode on Android
camera, 'Hey Google' on Google
Assistant, Smart reply on Google
OS, these are going to be
powered by TensorFlow Lite in
the future.
And I'm going to hand it off to
Andrew who can tell you how to
use TensorFlow Lite.
>> Thanks for the introduction.
So, now that we see what
TensorFlow is, or TensorFlow
Lite is, in particular, let's
find out how to use it.  Let's
jump into the code.  So, the
first step of the  four-step
process is to get a model.  You
can download it off the Internet
or you can train it yourself.
Once you have a model, you need
to convert it into TensorFlow
Lite format using our converter.
There might be ops you want to
spot
optimize using special
intrinsics or hardware specific
to your application.  Or we
don't support.
write custom ops for that.  You
can go to the app and write it
using the client API of your
choice.  Look at the conversion
process.
We support save model or frozen
graph def.
And we are showing the Python
interface.
We give it a direct directory of
a
save model, and it gives us a
FlatBuffer out.  Before that's
done, there might be
some things you need to use to
make this work better.
The first thing is you need to
use a frozen graphdef.  A lot of
times a training graph has
conditional logic or checks that
are not
necessary for inference.
Sometimes it's useful to create
a special inference script.
Lastly, if you need to look at
what the model is doing, the
TensorFlow is good, but we have
the TensorFlow Lite visualizer
and looking at these compared to
each other can help you.  If you
find issues, file them with
GitHub and we will respond to
them as we get needs.
So, lastly, write custom
operator.  Let's see how to do
that.
To write it in TensorFlow Lite
is relatively
simple.  The main function is
invoke.  I've defined an
operator that returns PII.  A
one scaler Pi.  Once you have
done that, you need to register
the new operations.  There's a
number of ways to register
operations.
If you don't have custom ops and
don't need overriding, you can
use in the built-in resolver.
But you might want to ship
binary that's much smaller.  You
might want selective
registration.  You should ship a
needed ops resolver
or include your custom ops in
that same thing.  Once you have
the ops set, you just plug it
into the interpreter.  Okay.  We
have talked about custom
operations.  Let's see how we
put this into
practice in the Java API.
In Java, you put it in the
interpreter, fill in the inputs
and outputs, and run run, which
will
populate with the results of the
inference.  Really simple.
Next, how to include this?
Compile a bunch of code?  We're
working hard to make it so you
can use TensorFlow from the PIP
and do the training and you
don't need
to compile TensorFlow.
We parade an Android Gradle file
and you don't need to compile
for an Android app.
We have a similar thing for
Cocoapods.  Once we know how to
use TensorFlow, look at the
roadmap.  As we move forward, we
are going to support more and
more TensorFlow models out of
the box with more ops.  Second,
add on-device training and look
at so you can do hybrid
training.
Some of it on your server, some
on your device.  Wherefore it
makes sense.  Should be an
option.  And include tooling to
analyze graphs better to do more
optimizations.
We have more that we can talk
about that we're working on, but
hope this will make you
interested and excited to try
it.  So, there's one remaining
question
left, which is, should I use
TensorFlow mobile or TensorFlow
Lite?  TensorFlow mobile is a
stripped down
set of TensorFlow that  uses a
subset of the ops.  We are going
to improve TensorFlow Lite and
its ability to map to custom
hardware.
We recommend you target
TensorFlow Lite as soon as
possible if it's possible.  If
there's functionality you need
in TensorFlow mobile, let us
know and we'll work to improve
TensorFlow Lite ins a
commensurate way.  Okay.  Demo
time.  So, nothing like a live
demo, right?  So, let's switch
over to the demo feed and we'll
talk about it.
And, so, we saw some mobile
phones.  Mobile phones are
really exciting, you know,
because everybody has them.  But
another thing that's happening
is these edge  computing
devices.
One of the most popular ones for
hobbyists is the Raspberry Pi.
I have built hardware around the
Raspberry Pi.  As we zoom in, we
have the Raspberry Pi mobile
board.  This is a system on
chip, similar to a cell phone
chip.  And one of the great
things about the Raspberry Pi is
that they're really cheap.
Another great thing, they can
interface to hardware.  Here
we're interfaced to a
microcontroller that allow us to
basically control these motors.
These are server motors, common
in RC cars.
And they allow us to move the
camera left and right and up and
down.
Essentially it's a camera
gimbal.  And it's  connected to
a Raspberry Pi compatible
camera.  What to do with this?
We showed the classification
demo before.
Let's look at an SSD example.
Single shot detection.
It can identify bounding boxes
in an image.  Given an image, I
get multiple bounding  boxes.
So, for example, we have an
apple here.  And it identifies
an apple.
Now, the really cool thing we
can do with this, now that we
have the motor, we can tell it
to center the apple.  We turned
on the motors, and they're
active.  And as I move it
around, it's going to keep the
apple as centered as possible.
If I go up, it will go up, if I
go down, it will go down.  So,
this is really fun.  What could
you use this for?  Well, if
you're a person, it can identify
you.  Currently I have that
filtered out.  So, if I stand
back, it's going to center on
me.  So, I could use this as
sort of a virtual
videographer.  Imagine a
professor wants to tape their
lecture, but they don't have a
camera person.  This would be a
great way to do that.  I'm sure
that all the hobbyists around
can now use TensorFlow in a
really
simple way, can come up with
many better applications than
what I'm showing here.
But I find it fun and I theme
you do.
And I'm not an electrical or
mechanical engineer, so you can
do this too.  All right.  Thanks
for showing the demo.
Let's go back to the slides,
please.
So, I had a backup video just in
case it didn't work.  It's
always a good plan.
[ Laughter ]
But we didn't need it.  So,
that's great.  So, let's
summarize.
So, what should you do?  I'm
sure you want to use TensorFlow
Lite.  Where can you get it?
You can get it on GitHub right
around the TensorFlow
repository.  How you can find
out about it is looking at the
TensorFlow Lite
documentation on the TensorFlow.
org website.
And we have a  mailing list,
tflite@tensorFlow.org.  And you
can tell us about issues and
what you use TensorFlow Lite
for.  I hope to hear from all
you.  One at a time, please.
Thanks, everybody, thanks Sarah
for her presentation.  Thank
you, everybody around the world
listening to this.  And in
addition, this was work that we
worked very hard with other
members of the Google team, lots
of different teams.  So, there's
a lot of work that went into
this.  So, thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]
So, with that -- we have our
next talk.  And where is our
next speaker?
Our next speaker will be Vijay.
And he's going to be talking
about AutoML.
>> Thank you very much. Hi,
everybody.  My name is Vijay.
And today I'll be talking to
you, or hopefully convincing
you, that when we try to apply
machine learning to solving
problems, that we should really
be thinking about designing
search spaces over solutions to
those problems.  And then we can
use automated machine learning
techniques in order to evaluate
our ideas much more efficiently.
I think a big reason why a lot
of us are here today is due to
the incredible
impact that machine learning can
have on practical problems.  Two
often-cited reasons is that we
have increasing amounts of
compute capability and access to
data to train on.  But I think
one other aspect is all of you,
right?  There's so many more
people involved in many machine
learning today that are
contributing and publishing
ideas.
So, this graph tries to put this
into perspective by measuring
how many machine learning papers
are published on archive every
year since 2009.  And plotting
that
against a Moore's Law
exponential growth curve.  As
you can see here, we have been
keeping up with Moore's law, 2X,
every year.  And this is
demonstrating how many new ideas
are being developed in the
field.  This is a great thing,
right?
So, one concrete way of looking
at this is in the field of
computer vision,
we have seen top one image and
accuracy start from the 50%
range from the
AlexNet architecture, which, by
the way, revolutionized the
field of image classification.
And every year we have been
getting
better and better up until 2017.
Now, these improvements haven't
come just because we have been
training bigger models, right?
These improvements have also
come from the fact that we have
lots of great ideas, right?
Things like, batch
normalization,
residual or skip connections and
various regularization
techniques.  Now, each of these
points, like Jeff mentioned
earlier, is the result of years
of research effort.  And we
build on each other's ideas.
But one of the challenging
things is how do we keep up with
so much -- so many ideas that
are being produced?  And Is want
to zoom in a little bit in terms
of the complexity of some of
these models.
So, we're going to zoom in a
little
bit on InceptionV4 and look at
the idea  embedded in there.
These are models within the
architecture.
Every one of the arrows and
operations was designed by a
human.  Somebody wrote some code
in order to
specify all of these little
details.  Now, there are
high-level reasons why this kind
of architecture might make
sense.
But our theory doesn't really
explain with so much certainty
how every detail seems to
matter.  And as a field, I
think, we're definitely working
on trying to improve the theory
behind this.
But for many of us, we're happy
to use this kind of complexity
out of the box if we can.
Because it really helps to solve
problems.  Now, this isn't too
surprising.  We know that
because machine
learning has had such an impact
on real products, that we're
going to be willing to use
anything we possibly can.  And
even if we don't understand all
the little minor details.  As
long as it solves our problems
well
and hopefully are
understandable.
So, given all these ideas, how
can we harness this explosion of
ideas much more efficiently?
So, let's step back and kind of
ask a
few questions that we might have
heard when we were trying to
train machine learning models.
Simple, but hard questions.
What learning rate should I
apply for my optimization?  If
I'm training a deep neural
network model, what dropout rate
should I apply?  How do we
answer this question today?  I
think we combine a few different
types of benefits.
One of them is leveraging
research or intuition and
engineering intuition.  What
this means is that we start with
code, or we ask our colleagues,
hey,
what are good settings for these
fields?  If it were the case
that there was one setting that
worked for
everybody, we wouldn't be
looking at these  parameters.
But it does matter.  So, then,
we move on to some trial and
error process.  We try a certain
setting and see how well it
works on our problem and we
continue to iterate.  And I
think the other aspect, which is
becoming more common,
hopefully, is increasing access
to compute and data by which we
can evaluate these ideas.  So,
this combination is really ripe
for automation, right?  And not
surprisingly, this exists today.
It's  called hyperparameter
optimization.
And this kind of setup, we have
a tuner giving out these
hyperparameter settings.  We
have a train their trains our
model on our dataset and then
tries to give some kind of
signal about how good those
settings were.  And it might
give a validation accuracy of
some value.  And the tuner can
then learn from this feedback to
find better points from the
search space.  And, you know,
this is an  existing
big field and there are existing
systems
like those shown at the very
bottom that can help you to do
this.  But now let's ask a few
more complicated or detailed
questions that I think people do
often ask as well.
Why do you use batchnorm before
relu?  I switched the order and
it seems to work better.  If
you're trying to train a
completely new model, use one
type of sub architecture or
another type of sub
architecture?  Now, if you think
about it, these questions aren't
really that different from
hyperparameter settings.
So, if we think of
hyperparameter optimization as
searching over a specific domain
of ideas, then it seems possible
that maybe we can actually treat
the decisions made in this type
of model as another form of
searching over a domain of
ideas.  And we can therefore
think about deemphasizing any
specific decision that we make
on our architectures.
And instead think about the
surplus of ideas that we might
have.
So, let's take a concrete
example of a search space design
that my colleague Barrett did
where
he tried to design a search
space for a convolutional cell.
I'll walk you through how you
might design such a work space.
So, the first question is, you
have to get your inputs.  Might
say you have access to the
previous input.  And if you want
support for skip connections,
you might have the previous,
previous input.  So, the first
job in the search space is to
define which inputs I'm going
select.  And then, once you have
those inputs selected, you want
to then figure out what
operation should I apply to each
of those inputs before  summing
them together?  So, I might
select something like
three by three convolution or
three by three maxpooling and
combine those together.  We can
then recursively turn that crank
and apply it several more times
where we use different
operations for different inputs.
And we can even use the
intermediate outputs of previous
decisions in our search.  And
then finally, you take all of
your
outputs that are unused and you
concatenate them together.
And that is your convolutional
cell.
And if you want to build your
model,
like ResNet, stack them
together.  This is one point
from the search space of ideas.
There are a billion possible
ways to
construct a cell like this in
the search space.
Changing the list and the way
the connections can be made.
Now that we've designed our
search
space, we go back to the
hyperparameter tuning system.
We have a program generator on
the left that generates samples
from this search space.
We then train and evaluate on
the task at hand.  Oftentimes a
proxy task.  And iterate to
quickly find what are the best
programs from our search space?
And the system on the left, in
program generator, can
optionally learn from feedback.
So, it might use something like
reinforcement learning,
revolutionary
algorithms, or even search can
work well in certain situations.
So, we did this type of
approach.  We took this
convolutional cell.
Trained it on proxy task to make
quick
progress on the evaluation of an
idea.  And then we took the best
candidate cells that with found
from that search.  We enlarged
in terms of the number of
filters and the number of times
we
stacked it and applied it to the
ImageNet dataset.  These are two
found from the search.  Looking
at the results, you can see that
we were able to do better than
the existing state of the art
models in
terms of top line accuracy top 1
accuracy.  This effort was an
example where we took a model
where decisions were pretty
complex and we honestly found
another complex model that was
better.
But next I'll show you an
example where we can use this
general technique
to find even more interpretable
outputs.
So, let's look at optimization
update rules.
Most of you are probably
familiar with stochastic
gradient decent.
And shown on the left, gradient
by the learning weight and
delta.
And then we have Adam, these can
be
expressed fairly concisely just
by being given the moving
average of the
gradient and so forth.
But we really only have a
handful of these type of
optimization update rules that
we typically apply for deep
learning, for example.  What if
we,  instead, treat these update
equation rules as part of a
larger search space?
And so, you can take these
expressions and turn them into a
data flow graph that uses the
optimization update rule.  We
can express them using this
simple tree, but also a lot of
other ideas.  And so, you can
then turn this crank
on this new search space and try
to find
a better optimization update
rule.
So, my colleagues ran that
experiment.  They took a fixed
convolutional model
and tried to search over the
fixed rules.  They found
optimizations that did better
than what I have shown you on
this particular task.  One nice
feature of this search space,
the results are more
interpretable.  The fourth
update rule here.
Taking the gradient and
multiplying it by an expression.
The gradient and the moving
average
the gradient agree in your
direction, you should take a
bigger step in that direction.
And that they disagree that we
should make a smaller step.
This is actually a form of
momentum.  And so, one thing we
can get from this
is maybe we should be designing
search
spaces that have more notions
encoded in the search space
ideas.  We may be able to find
even better results.  So, so far
I have focused on techniques and
search space ideas where we care
about accuracy.
But what's great about searching
over many ideas, we night have
the potential to search over
more than just accuracy.  For
example, a lot of us care about
inference speed.  We want to
take a model and deploy it
on real hardware, real mobile
platform.  And we take a lot of
time and try to figure out how
to take one idea and make it
fast enough.  But what if could,
as part of the search space of
ideas, finds ones that balance
both speed and accuracy?  So, we
tried to do this experiment
where we included the run time
on a
real mobile device as part of
this inner loop of the
evaluation.
So, we tried to focus to
optimize on both accuracy as
well as inference speed.  And as
this process goes on over time,
program generator is able to
find faster models while also
figuring out how to
make those models even more
accurate.
One interesting side effect of
this is
that when you run searches over
ideas, the output is actually
not just one model, it's a
culture of models that
implicitly codes this tradeoff.
This shows you we have points
along
the space that provide a
tradeoff between inference speed
on a mobile platform and
accuracy on the dataset that
we're trying to solve.  Rather
than manually engineering the
one point I want to get working,
I can get a result that can
maybe be  deployed on various
types of platforms.  So, I'll
emphasize this in maybe a
slightly different way.  Which
is that we could define a search
space of ideas in TensorFlow,
and through this automatic
machine learning
process, we could get models
that have a guarantied run time
performance target on a target
platform device.  And one of the
nice things about
having an integrated ecosystem
like  TensorFlow, you can just
use the
libraries that convert from
program program to program to
you can get this end to end
pipeline working well together.
There's nothing required to
specifically tune a model.  Let
me conclude by returning to this
process of  evaluating ideas in
this world where we're trying to
explore different ideas.  The
first is that we designed search
spaces to try to test out a
large set of possible ideas.
Note that when we designed the
search space, that required
human intuition.  There's a need
for human ingenuity as part of
this process.
So, designing the search space
properly takes a lot of efforts,
but you can evaluate many more
ideas much more quickly.  When
it comes to trial and error, we
had to think about how software
should be changed so that we can
permit this type of search
process.  So, for example, I
think many of us have probably
written scripts where you take
things like learning rate and
dropout rate as command line
flags.
What if you wanted to test out
deeper ideas in your programs?
How do you design a program
that's much more tuneable at all
levels of your program?  I think
this is a big question for us to
tackle.  And lastly, we think
these ideas will become
increasingly relevant as many of
you get access to more and more
computation capabilities such as
TPU pods.  Imagine a world where
all you have to do is take your
idea, submit it to an
idea bank and you have a pod of
TPUs crunching overnight to
figure out which solution
organization ideas are the best
and then waking up in the
morning and it telling you,
these were the good ideas, these
were the bad ideas and so forth.
I think part of the reason this
excites me is that automatic
machine learning can keep these
machines much more busy than we
can.  We have to
sleep.
But machines can keep on
churning 24/7.  So, with that,
thanks for listening.
[ Applause ]
And next up is Ian who will be
talking
to you about fusion plasmas.
So, I want to talk to you about
something that's very important
to me.
And that's how will civilization
power itself for the next
hundred years?
So, in 2100, the projected
world's population is 11.2
billion.  If all 11.
2 billion people to want enjoy
the same
power usage that we do now in
the United
States, that's going to require
burning around .
2yata joules of energy over the
next hundred years.  That's a
whole lot.
So, to put that in perspective,
if we wanted to do that with oil
alone, we
would are have to ramp up oil
production by a factor of 10 for
the next hundred years.  There's
no way that's going to happen.
Besides being infeasible, that
would
contribute to catastrophic
climate change.
If we want to keep climate
change to a
not ideal, but reasonable, say,
degrees temperature increase,
only 1.
2% can come from coal or oil.
Where does the other come from?
One possible source would be
nuclear fusion.
So, fusion involves pushing
together two smaller nuclei.
What you get out is a whole lot
of energy.  And no greenhouse
gas.
So, right now the sun runs on
nuclear fusion.
And the reaction is so
energy-dense that .
2 yatajewels would require a
trivial amount of boron.
So, so far it sounds like a
miracle fuel.  What's the catch?
Well, the difficulty is that
people have been trying this for
70 years and so far no one has
gotten out more energy than they
put in.
So, to understand this, you have
to imagine that the -- well, the
reaction takes place inside of a
plasma.
And the plasma is a million plus
degree swarm of charged
particles.  And these particles
don't to want stay in place.
The sun uses a gravitational
force to keep everything in
place.  We can't do that.
So, instead, we use magnets.
Now, magnets, you try to squeeze
it with magnets and they can pop
out the end.  And you can get
little turbulent ripples.  And
what happens is the plasma
breaks up, it gets unstable.  It
gets
cooler.  And then the reaction
stops.  And that's what's been
happening for 70 years.  So,
this is the kind of problem that
I like.
It combines physics,
probability, computation,
mathematics.
And so, I was like, I want to
work on this.
How can we accelerate progress?
Well, so, Google is not
building a fusion reactor.  What
we have done is we have
partnered
with TAE technologies, the
world's largest private fusion
energy company.  And we have
been working with them since
2015.
So, pictured here is their fifth
generation plasma generation
device.  And this thing is huge.
It would fill up a large part of
this room.
And then in the center we have
-- is
where the  Applause ] many
plasma is kept.
This is elongated toriod.
And the goal is to keel this in
its place and prevent
turbulence.  If it gets out of
place, then the reaction stops.
So, there's magnets and neutral
beams and a host of other
technologies to keep it in
place.
Now, what's Google's job
specifically?
Well, our goal is to take the
measurements that come from this
experimental  reactor.  And
every time the physicists do an
experiment, within five minutes,
we want to tell them the plasma
density, temperature and
magnetic field on a
three-dimensional grid.  So, how
hard is that?
Well, first of all, the plasma
is very, very hot.
So, you can't just poke it with
a thermometer like a turkey.
The thermometer would melt and
you would disrupt the plasma and
ruin the experiment.  What you
do have are measurements along
the  boundary.  But there's only
so many measurements
you can take, because you can't
cut to -- can't cut, you know,
that many holes
in the side of this device.  So,
let's look closely at one.
Let's look at measuring of
electron
density, that's done with a
device known
as as an inner pherometer, it's
proportional to the average
density along that ray.
So, we have 14 lasers shining
through the center of the
plasma.  We know the average
density along
14 lines.
And from that, we want to know
the density everywhere.  So,
clearly there's no one unique
solution to this problem.
And instead we'll have a
distribution over possible
solutions.
So, we do this in a Basian
sense, and
the final output is a
probability
density function for the density
of the electrons given the
measurements.
And we can  visualize that with
a graph where you have a mean
and some air bars.
How does TensorFlow help with
this?  Well, so, the first place
is translating measurement
physics into code.  So, let's
consider the distribution for
the camera measurement.
So, the cameras measure photons.
And say we have some photons
being emitted from the plasma.
The mean number of photons
reaching
the camera is given by a sparse
tenser, dense matmul.  But we
don't realize the mean.
Instead what we realize is a
noisy mean.  There's noise due
to a finite number of photons.
And we have discreetization
noise, we have space.  The
TensorFlow normal distribution
library gives you access, so
this noisy flux represents a
normal distribution.  It has a
mean.  It has -- you can draw
samples.
You can compute the PDF and so
on.
That's not all, though, we also
have analog to digital
conversion process that we model
as passing this normal
distribution through a
non-linear response curve and
digitizing it to 8 bits.
So, at the end, this digitized
charge is another distribution
object that has the ability to
take samples.  You can compute
the probability mass function
because it's discreet.  And so
on.
And since we want to be
Bayesian, we
want to reassemble a number of
these distributions giving us a
likelihood and
a prior and so on with the goal
of producing a posterior.
And then we do Bayesian
inference.  To do inference, we
do this in two different ways.
The first way is variational
inference, which amounts to min
nic minimizing the loss
function.
And you can get the true
posterior.  This is done like
any other TensorFlow
minimization.
For example, we use Adam
Optimizer.
The second way is using
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo.
So the TensorFlow probability
library
gives you a number of Monte
Carlo sample
hers, and the Ham ill toneon
allows you to take samples
faster.  Notice in both cases,
it's autodifferentiation.
Whether we're taking afraid why
notes
for the loss or to do the
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
sampling.  Popping up a level,
you'll notice, we're not doing
deep learning.
As I said, we're doing an
inverse problem, measurements
given by physicists are into a
reconstruction of some physical
state.  So, there's a few
differences I want to highlight.
First of all, there are no
labels that are given to us.
The natch natural label here
would be a three-dimensional
image of the actual plasma.  But
we're the ones who are telling
people what the plasma looks
like, so, we're the ones
actually producing the labels.
So, begin that there's no
labels, you
might be tempted to say, this is
an
unsupervised learning technique
like word clustering.  Here
there really is a right answer.
There really was a plasma out
there.  And if -- or the plasma
doesn't fall within our air
bars, we have made a mistake.
And also you'll notice that our
graph
here models physics rather than
generic functions.
So, it's a bit more constrained
on these deep neural networks.
But that allows us to get the
right answer with no labels.
At the end of the day TensorFlow
does, despite it not being deep
learning, TensorFlow adds value
with the TensorFlow
distributions and the
probability library.  We have
autodifferentiation to do
inference.  And in order to
provide answers to
many measurements at once,  GPUs
and distributed computing is
very important.  So, thank you
very much.
[ Applause ]
And next up we have Cory talking
about
machine learning and
genomics.
>> Hello, everyone. My name is
Cory McLean and I'm an
engineering on the genomics team
in Google brain.  And today I'm
excited to tell you about
nucleus, which is a library
we've
released today to make it easy
to bring genomics data to
TensorFlow.
So, genomics is the study of the
structure and function of
genomes.  In every cell in your
body, you have two copies of the
genome, one from each parent.
And this is strings of DNA,
which is a four-letter alphabet.
And about 3 billion letters in
the genome.
So, here is a picture of a
snapshot on chromosome-1,
150,000 letters.  What we can
see is there's a number of known
things about this area.
One, there are functional
elements, like the genes
depicted in that second row.
Biological measurements allow us
to analyze what our different
things that are active in cells.
So, on that third row, we can
see the amount of gene
expression across different
tissue types is quantified
there.
And at the bottom, through
sequencing many
people, we can identify places
where there's variation across
individuals.
And there's many different
computational algorithmic
challenges in developing that
image.
This ranges from, on the
experimental data generation
side.
Can we better take the output of
these physical measurements to
get accurate DNA readings.
We'll reduce noise in the
experiments that quantify this
expression.
Can we take the DNA sequence and
interpret where our functional
elements like these genes?  Or
predict how active are they in
different tissue types?
And can we identify places where
individuals vary compared to our
reference?
And how is that different in
small variants versus say in
cancer?
And how do those changes
influence human traits?  So, one
thing that is really exciting
for us is, there are many
opportunities
for deep learning in genomics.
And a lot of that is driven by
the increase in the amount of
data available.  This graph
shows the dramatic reduction in
cost to
sequence a million bases of DNA
over the past  decade.
But also, there's a lot of
structure in these datasets that
is often complex
and difficult to represent with
relatively simple models.
But this made us display
convolutional
structure, so we can use
techniques from image
classification as well as
sequence models.  And there have
been a number of proven
successes of applying deep
learning to problems in genomics
such as deep variant, which is a
tool our group
developed to identify small
variants using convolutional
neural networks.  So, our goals
in genomics are multi-faceted.
One is to make it easy to apply
TensorFlow to problems in
genomics.  And do this by
creating libraries to make it
easy to work with genomics data.
We're also interested in
developing tools and pushing the
boundaries on some of these
scientific questions  using
those things that we've built.
And then want to make all of
that
publicly available as tools that
can be used by the
community.  So, today, I'll
focus on the first part of
making it easy to bring
genomics data to TensorFlow.
So, what is a major problem?
One major difficulty is that
there are
many different types of data
that are generated for genomics
research.
You can see here on the right a
subset of different types used.
And these different file formats
have
varying amounts of support and
in
general no uniform APIs.  We
have some concerns about
efficiency and language support
where we would like
to be able to express some
manipulations
in Python, but need some
effective ways to efficiently go
through this data such that
native Python wouldn't make that
possible.  So, to address these
challenges, we
developed Nucleus, which is a
C++ and Python library for
reading and writing
genomic data to make it easy to
bring to
TensorFlow models and then feed
through the tf.data API that
Derek talked about today
for training models for your
particular task of interest.
And we support the
reading of many of the most
common data
formats in genomics and provide
a unified API across the
different data  types.  So,
we're able to iterate through
the different records of these
different types and be able to
query on specific
regions of the genome to access
the data there.
The way that we developed this
uses
protocol buffers under the hood
so that we can implement all the
general parsing
in C++ and then make those
available to
other languages like Python.
And for those of you particular
with
genomics, we end up using HTS
lib which is a conical parser
for the high-through put
sequencing data formats with the
variants and then wrap that to
generate the protocol buffers
and then use CLIF on top of this
to make the data available to
Python.
And finally, we use some of the
TensorFlow core libraries so we
can
write out this data as T
FRecords so they can be ingested
by the API.  The data types we
currently support are the
following, raking from general
genome
annotation to reference genomes
and different sequencer reads.
Whether they're director off the
sequencer or mapped as well as
genetic variants.
So, to give an example of the
reading API, it's quite
straightforward.  So, this is
kind of a toy example, but it is
essentially similar to what is
used for deep variant where we
want to
train a model to identify actual
genome
variations based on maps,
sequence reads and a reference
genome.  So, you have three
different data types that we
need.  We import the different
reader types.
And then say, in this renal
region
that we're interested in, we can
issue queries to each of the
different reader
types and then have
iterables that we can manipulate
and turn into TensorFlow
examples.  On the writing side,
it's similarly straightforward.
So, if we have a list of
variants for
the -- the common vcf format,
we'll have an associated header
which provides metadata about
this, and then open a writer
with that header and then just
loop
through the variants and write
them.
And note that we support writing
to
block format which is for the
subsequent indexing by other
tools.
We can directly write to TF
records and write the methods to
write out charted data which we
found helps
avoiding certain hot spots in
the genome
using very a very similar API.
Finally, we have been working
with the Google Cloud team which
has some tools for analyzing
variant data.  And so, they have
developed a tool
called Variant Transforms, which
allows
you to load the variant files to
big
query using Apache Beam.
And you can do queries over that
data.
We're implementing here to have
Nucleus under the hood providing
that generation of the variants
and to learn more about that
tool you can go to the link
below.
So, to summarize, we have
developed Nucleus, which is a
C++ and Python
library to make it easy to bring
genomics data to TensorFlow to
train your models of interest
for genomic problems.
And we have the ability to
interoperate
with cloud genomics and being
integrated into the various
transforms at the moment.  And
this ended up being the
foundation
of our CNN-based variant caller
which is available at the link
below.  So, with that, I would
like to thank you all for your
attention today.
[ Applause ]
Next up we'll have Edd to talk
about open source
collaborations.
.
>> Thank you. Hi, everyone.
Now, I was going to talk to you
about
my plans to reanimate dinosaurs
with TensorFlow, but I don't
want to steal those  guy's
thunder.  Actually, I'm here to
talk about open source
collaboration in the TensorFlow
project.  That's my job at
Google.  To work on growing the
participation and the
collaboration in the project in
the whole community.  So, you
guys all here and everybody
watching on the livestream are a
huge part of this already.  If
you saw a slide like this at the
beginning of the day in the
keynote, you can see the numbers
ticked up.  In the five days I
have been monitoring this slide,
I am increasing the numbers.
The amount of participation is
staggering.  As an open source
project, it blows my mind when I
came to work on it.  And so much
of that is due to the
participation of everybody here
in the community.  There are
parts of TensorFlow that
wouldn't exist, many of them,
without that collaboration.  For
instance, whether it's Spark
connectors, whether it's support
for particular architectures and
accelerators, or maybe certain
language bindings.  We not only
benefit from a huge amount of
adoption by being open source,
but as the adoption grows, this
is the way we sustain and grow
the project.
You saw this map earlier as
well.
This is just some of the GitHub
stars that gave their locations
that we could map.
And it was as far north as
Norway and as far south as the
Antarctic.
And what's obvious right now,
although there's a large team at
Google
developing TensorFlow, there are
for
many more people and in far many
more places using it .  And the
open source projects, more
adoption were more demand.
There's so much we can do
together to grow TensorFlow.
Now, you remember that thing
where you turn up to a party and
everyone is having a good time
and they all seem to know what
they're doing and why it's such
fun.
But who am I going to talk to
with and what are they looking
at?  And sometimes a large open
source project can be a bit like
that.  You want to get involved
and contributing to TensorFlow,
but where do you start?
You think this module, -- this
feature and something you want
to work on.  How do you find the
right person to talk to?  How
you learn what we're thinking
about the direction for this?
We have heard some of those
things and we recognize that we
want to improve our openness,
our transparency and our
participation.  We're trying to
work to make it easier to get
involved in TensorFlow.  We have
already, for instance, refreshed
our roadmap which you can find
on the TensorFlow website about
the general direction of a lot
of the code.  And we'll do that
a lot more regularly.
But I want to talk about four
initiatives that we have going
that will enable us to work
together more effectively and
faster.  The first of these is
simple.
It's a central community for
everyone who is working on and
contributing to TensorFlow.
GitHub has so much energy going
on.  There's
so much great debate in all the
issues.  Look in there, in the
pull requests,
really  thoughtful conversation
conversations and contributions.
Thank you for being part of
that.
But what we don't have is a
central place you can
collaborate.
We have a mailing list,
developers @it feel.org.
That's a
developer@tensorFlow.org.  We
can work together as a community
to get feedback and coordinate
together.  Many of the projects
have mailing lists that you can
find at TensorFlow.
org/community.
Whether it's TF  Lite, or
TensorFlow.JS.
So, that's collaboration.  Now,
we talked about the fact there
are many use cases outside of
Google that the core team don't
see.  Many more.
Many  Much more happens outside
than inside the core team.
So, we want to make it possible
for people with shared interests
in projects to work together.
This is where the beauty of open
source comes in.
How do we do that?  We're
setting up a structure for
groups to work
together.  Special interest
groups.  We have been piloting
the first of these for a few
months now.
This is called SIG build.  It's
about building, packaging and
distributing TensorFlow.
Familiar with TensorFlow, you
know we built it in a certain
way.  Guess what?
Not every architecture or
application finds that the best
way for them.
For instance, the Linux wants to
build against the shared
libraries in the distribution.
That's not something we do.  So,
we brought together a bunch of
stakeholders over Linux,
companies like
redhat, IBM, and NVIDIA, Intel,
to collaborate in a group to
look at the build and make it
work for effectively for more
people in the future.  That's
just one group.  The pilot.
But, we want to pave the cow
paths.  Where there is energy
and people collaborating on a
particular thing, that's a great
candidate to bring a special
interest group together.
We're also bringing online a
group for TensorBoard where key
stakeholders of the TensorBoard
ecosystem
can work together on
collaboration.
And the bindings, completely
built by the group for
TensorFlow.  And each will have
a different way of working, a
different community.  But the
common thing is, we're going to
provide  forms, if you have a
shared interest in a particular
area, we can focus on it.
Now, I'd like to talk about the
design of TensorFlow.  You know,
one of the most amazing things
and the benefits of TensorFlow
is that the code that we release
is the
code that Google uses on a daily
basis.  It's kind of remarkable
for an open source project.  And
so, we're really causal about
changes.  We're really careful
about design.  We have a
commitment, obviously, to the
API through the 1.X series
release.  And we have design
reviews internally.   So, when
things change, we have
proposals, we get feedback.  But
by now you are thinking, well,
you just said that so many use
cases and so many users are
outside of Google.  Yet you're
having these design reviews
inside.
So, what we're going to do is
open up a public feedback phase
to our design process so we can
engage much more broadly with
every contributor and user about
how that might affect their
needs and what their opinions
are.
Keep an eye on the developers at
TensorFlow.org  mailing list.
That's where we'll notify it
coming online in the next couple
months.  My hope is this process
will be a way that everybody can
communicate and discuss about
the future direction of
TensorFlow.  Whether you're in
the core team at
Google or in the broader
community.
So,  contributing to TensorFlow
isn't just about issues or PR
requests.  In fact, I would say
I reckon that there's so much
more -- more energy going into
blogging, running meetups, doing
presentations, teaching, doing
courses.  So many universities
around the world.
And we want to amp up and
support the amount of content
that educates and highlights
TensorFlow.  We're really
excited already that so
many of you do such amazing
jobs.  We would like to be able
to point everybody in the
TensorFlow community to the work
that you're doing.  So, there's
a couple things that we launched
to support this.  The first you
probably already heard.  We now
have a blog for TensorFlow.  A
blog.tensorFlow.org.
One of the things I'm most
excited
about with this blog is that as
well as important announcements
and education, we're setting it
up from the beginning to involve
content from around the web and
into the community.  That's one
of the reason we're using
the Medium platform to make it
easy to integrate content around
the web and give you the credit
for the work you have done.
So, we would really like to hear
from you.  If you have a blog
post to get into the TensorFlow
publication, get in touch.
Secondly, and if you're on the
livestream watching this, you've
kind of found out about this, we
have a YouTube channel that's
launched today.
Now, one of the things I'm most
excited
about this in this is a show
called TensorFlow Meets.  We are
able to get out into the world
of contributors and users and
highlight some of the use cases.
Highlight the work of everybody.
This is a chance for you too.
We would love to meet you and
chat with you about what you're
up to and have you featured on
the YouTube channel.  Again,
reach out to us.  We would love
you to be a part of it.  There
is one URL to get  involved in
all these things that I
mentioned, TensorFlow.
org/community.
So, if anyone's mentioned a
mailing
list or group to you today,
please go to that URL and you
will find resources there.  It's
my hope that TensorFlow is going
to continue to be a party, but
maybe one you can find yourself
part of a lot sooner and have
more fun.  Please, feel free to
reach out to me.
There's my people address, ew
ewj@google.com.  And talk about
your experiences collaborating
around open source and
TensorFlow.  I would love to
hear about it.  Thank you so
much.
[ Applause ]
Now, our next speaker is Chris
Lattner.  He's going to talk
about a first principles
approach to machine learning.
>> All right. Thank you, Edd.
Hi there, everyone.  I'm excited
to introduce a new project
that we have been working on
that takes a new project to
improve usability of TensorFlow.
And we care so much about
usability here that we're going
all the way back to first
principles of the computation
that we're performing.  But
first, why usability?
I hope that everyone here agrees
that productivity and machine
learning is critical.  Because
it leads to a faster pace of
innovation and progress in our
field.  And, of course, question
are just want to build beautiful
things for TensorFlow users
since that's a big piece of it
as well.  But if you look at
machine learning frameworks,
there's two major approaches.
The most familiar are the graph
building approaches where you
explicitly
define a graph and execute it to
run a computation.  It's great
for performance, but not always
for usability.  In define by run
approach, eager execution, not
always the best
performance, but you can use it
easier.  And both approaches are
really about allowing Python to
understand the difference
between the tensor computation
of your code and all the
other non-tenser stuff like
command line  processing and
visualization and what you do.
I think it's interesting to look
at how these actually work.  In
the case of Eager Execution, you
write the model and Python
parses it.
And then it feeds every
statement at a time to the
interpreter.  If it's a tenser
operation, it hands
it to TensorFlow and  takes care
of the tensor applications
otherwise Python runs it.
The key thing about Eager
Execution is they're designed
within the constraints of a
Python library.  With the
compiler, what we can do.
compiler and language involved,
there's a whole other set of
approaches that can be applied
to  solving this problem.
That's what we're doing.  The
cool thing about a compiler,
after you parse your code, the
compiler can see the entire
program and all the tensor ops
in it.
We're all thing a new stage to
the
compiler, takes the tensor
applications out, and because
it's a standard TensorFlow
graph, you can get access to all
the things that TensorFlow can
do, including the devices.  You
get the power and flexibility of
TensorFlow, but you get the
usability of your execution as
well.  But there's a catch.
There's always a catch,ing
right?  The catch here is that
we can't do this with Python.
At least not with the
reliability we expect, because
it doesn't support the kind of
compiler analysis we need.  And
what do we mean by that?
Well, the compiler has to be
able to reason about values.
Has to reason about control flow
and function calls.
Variable listing and thing
Variable alassing.  And we have
come to know the things about
Python, including using all the
standard Python APIs.  I know
what you're thinking.  Does this
mean we're talking about doing a
new language?  Well, that's
definitely an approach to solve
the technical requirements we
want.  With a new language, we
can build all the nice things we
want into it.  But this comes at
a cost.
It turns out we would be
foregoing the benefits of a
community.  That includes tools
and libraries, but also things
like books, which some people
still use.  And even more
significantly, this would take
years of time to get right.  And
machine learning just moves too
fast.  No, we think it's better
to use an existing language.
But here we have to be careful.
Because to do this right, we
have to
make significant improvements to
the compiler and the language
and do it in a reasonable amount
of time.  And so, of course,
this brings us to the Swift
programming language.  Now, I
assume that most of
you are not very familiar with
Swift, so, I'll give you a quick
introduction.  Swift is designed
with a lightweight syntax.  It's
geared towards being easy to use
and learn.  Swift draws together
best practices from lots of
different places, including
things like functional
programming and generics.
Swift builds on LLVM, it has an
interpreter and scripting
capabilities as well.  Swift is
great in notebook environments.
These are really awesome when
you're interactively developing
in real-time.  Swift is also
open source.  It's part of lots
of platforms.  It has a big
community of people.  But the
number one thing that's most
important to us is it has a
fully open design environment
called Swift  Evolution.
Allows us to propose machine
learning
and compiler features
directorially for integration
into Swift.  When you bring all
of this together, I'm happy to
introduce Swift for TensorFlow.
Swift for TensorFlow gives you
the full performance of Graphs.
You can use native language
control flow.
Has built-ins for automatic
differentiation.  You can detect
errors without running.
And full interaction with APIs.
I would like to welcome Richard
Wei to tell you about it now.
>> Thank you, Chris.
[ Applause ]
I'm thrilled to show you Swift
for TensorFlow.  Swift is a
high-performance, modern
programming language.  And
today, for the very first time,
Swift has a full powered
TensorFlow built right in.
I'm going to walk through three
major styles of programming.
Scripting, interpreting, and
notebooks.  So, first let me
show you the Swift interpreter.
This is a Swift interpreter.
When I type some code, swift
evaluates it and prints a
result.  Just like Python.
Now, let's import TensorFlow.
I can create a tensor from some
scale scalers.
Now, I can do any TensorFlow
operation directly and see the
result.
Just like I would with Eager
Execution.
For example, A plus A, or ace
matrix product with itself.
Of course, loops just work.  I
can print the result.
Now, interpreter is a lot of fun
to work with.
But I like using TensorFlow in a
more interactive environment
just like Jupiter notebook.  So,
let's see how they work.
This is a Swift notebook.  It
shows
all the results on the right.
So, here's some more interesting
code.  Fun with functions.
So, here I have a sigmoid
function inside a loop.
Now, as I click on this button,
it shows a trace of all values
produced by this function over
time.  Now, as a machine
learning developer, I often like
to differentiate functions.
Now, when I type in -- well,
since we were able to improve
that programming
language, we built first class
automatic differentiation right
into Swift.
Now, when I type in gradient
effects, it shows the gradients.
Swift computes the gradient
automatically and gives me the
result.
So, here is the gradient in the
sigmoid.
Now, let's look at some Python
code.  Let's think about Python.
Well, as a machine learning
developer, I have been using
Python a lot.
And I know there are many great
Python libraries.  Just today my
colleague, Dan, sent me
a dataset in pickle format.
Well, I can directly use Python
APIs to load it.
All I have to do is just type in
"Import
Python.
"  And Swift uses a Python API,
Pickle, to be specific, to load
the data.  In here, you can see
the data right in the Swift
notebook.
Now, -- so, here's a Swift
Now, some people like to run
training scripts  directly in
command line.  So, let me show
you how to train a
simple model from command line.
So, here is a simple model.
I'm using TensorFlow dataset to
load the API.
I have the forward pass and the
backward pass defined in the
training loop.  Now, I usually
like to work on the go,
so, this code has been working
on the CPU on my laptop.  But
when I want to get more
performance, what do I do?
Well, why don't I just enable
cloud TPU?
So, all I have to do is add one
line
to enable TPU execution.
When I save this file, open the
terminal to run this training
script.  It's initializing TPU.
And the Swift compiler
automatically
partitions this program into a
program and a TensorFlow graph.
And TensorFlow is sending this
graph to
the TensorFlow  SLA compiler for
TPU execution.  Now, it's
running.  And we're waiting for
the TPU to give the result.
Look!  Loss is going down.  All
right.
So, why don't we simply
open TensorBoard and see the
training curve?
So, now I can see the entire
training history in TensorBoard.
So, this is  looking great!
Now, this is Swift for
TensorFlow.
It's an interactive programming
experience with super-computing
performance at your fingertips.
Back to you, Chris.
>> Thanks, Richard. Thanks,
Richard.
[ Applause ]
All right.
To recap quickly, Richard showed
you that Swift has an
interpreter.  And it works just
like you would expect.  Now, I
know that it's super-frustrating
to be working on a
program and two hours into a
training run, get a shape error
are or type mismatch.
Swift is catching it early.  We
built catching mistakes right
into TensorFlow.
And you can use APIs and other
languages from Swift.
And give use full access to any
of the python APIs that you love
to use.  Swift is generateing
standard TensorFlow graphs,
including control flow.  Which
give you the full performance of
the session API.  Of course,
graphs are also awesome because
they give you access to
everything that TensorFlow can
do, including devices spanning
the range from the tiniest
Raspberry Pi all the way up to a
TPU super computer.
You may wonder, what does this
mean?  This is an early stage
project.  But we're looking
forward to our open source
release next month.  And not
only are we releasing the code,
but
technical white papers and
documents to explain how it
works and moving our design
discussions out into the public
on the Google group so everyone
can participate.  We're not done
yet.  We have basic support for
automatic
differentiation built right into
the compiler and the language.
But we want to have exotic cases
like recursion and data
structures.
Compatibility issues are
super-frustrating.  Especially
if you use an op or  D-type not
supported by your device.  Swift
has great support for detecting
issues like this, and we are
looking forward to wiring this
into supporting TensorFlow.  We
are interested in high-level
APIs.
We have some prototypes now, but
we
would like to design multiple
approaches and experiment and
settle on the best one based on
real-world experience.
This has been a super-quick tour
of Swift for TensorFlow.
Swift for TensorFlow combines
the power and flexibility of
TensorFlow with a whole knew
standard of usability.  We think
it's
going to take your ability to
the roof.  It's an early stage
project.  We would like you to
get interested and help us to
build this future.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello, everyone. Welcome
back.  Welcome back.  I'm
Jeremiah, and this is Andrew.
We are here from the TensorFlow
Hub team.
We are based in Zurich,
Switzerland, and we're excited
to share TensorFlow Hub today.
So, this first slide is actually
one that I stole.
I took it from a colleague, Noah
Fiedel who leads TensorFlow
serving.
And Noah uses this slide to tell
a personal story.  It kind of
shows the growth of things
-- the type of tools that we use
to do software engineering.
And it shows how they mature
over time.  He connects this to
a similar thing happening, the
tools we use to do machine
learning.  And he draws these
connections.
We're rediscovering things as we
grow our machine learning tools.
Things like the machine learning
equivalent of source control.
Machine learning equivalent of
continuous integration.
And Noah make this is
observation that this is lagging
behind the software engineering
side by 15-20 years.  So, this
creates a really interesting
opportunity, right?  We can look
at software engineering.  We can
look at some of the things that
have happened there.  And think
about what kind of impact
they may have on machine
learning.  Right?
So, looking at software
engineering, there's something
so fundamental, it's almost easy
to skip over.  That's this idea
of  sharing code.  Shared
repositories.
On the surface, this makes us
immediately more productive.  We
can search for code, download
it, use it.  But has really
powerful second order effects,
right?  This changes the way we
write code.  We refactor our
code.  We put it in libraries.
We share those libraries.
And this really makes people
even more productive.  And it's
the same dynamic that we want to
create for machine learning with
TensorFlow Hub.
TensorFlow Hub lets you build,
share
and use pieces of machine
learning.  So, why is this
important?  Well, anyone who has
done machine learning from
scratch knows you need a lot to
do it
well.  Now media an algorithm.
You need data.  You need compute
power and expertise.  And if
you're missing any of these,
you're out of luck.
So, TensorFlow Hub lets you
distill
all these things down into a
reusable
package called a module.  They
can be  easily reused.
So, you'll notice I'm saying
"module" instead of "Model."  It
turns out that a model is a
little bit too big to encourage
sharing.  If you have a model,
you can use that model if you
have the exact inputs it wants
and you expect the exact outputs
it provides.  If there's any
little difference ises, you're
kind of out of luck.
So, modules are a small piece,
right?  If you think of a model,
like a
binary, think of a module like a
library.
So, on the inside, a module is
actually a saved model.
So this lets us package up the
algorithm in the form of a
graph.  Package up the weights,
you can do things like
initialize, use assets.  And our
libraries make it very easy to
instantiate these in
your TensorFlow code.  So, you
can compose these in interesting
ways.  This makes things very
reusable.  You can produce one
of these and share it.  These
are also retrainable.  Once you
patch it into your bigger
program, you can back propagate
through it just like normal.
And this is really powerful
because, if you do happen to
have enough data,
you can customize the tf.hub
module for your own application.
And to tell us a little bit more
about
some of those applications, I'll
hand it over to Andrew.
>> Thanks Jer reMaya.
Let's look at a specific example
of using a tf .
hub module for image
retraining.
Say we're going to make an app
to classify rabbit breeds from
photos.
We have a couple hundred
examples, not enough to train an
entire image classification
model from scratch.
But we could start from an
existing general purpose
classification model.  Most of
the high-performing ones are
trained on millions of examples
and they can easily classify
thousands of categories.
So, we want to reuse the
architecture and the trained
weights of that model without
the classification  layers, and
in that way, we can add our own
rabbit classifier on top and we
can train it on our own rabbit
examples.
And keep the re-used weights fix
fixed.
So, since we're
using TensorFlow Hub, our first
stop is TensorFlow.org/hub.  We
can find the list of the newly
released, state of the art, and
also the well-known image
modules.  Some of them include
the classification layers.  And
some of them remove them, just
providing a feature vector as
output.  And so, we'll choose
one of the feature vector ones
for this case.
Let's use NASNet, a state of the
art image module created by a
neural network architecture
search.  You paste the URL of
the module.  And TensorFlow Hub
downloads the graph and all of
its weights and importing it
into your model.  In that one
line, you're ready to use the
module like any function.  So,
here we just provide a batch of
inputs and we get back our
feature vectors.
We add a classification layer on
top and output our predictions.
But in that one line, you get a
huge amount of value.  In this
particular  case, more than
62,000 hours of GPU time went
into
finding the best architecture
for NASNet and  training the
result.
All the expertise, the  testing,
the research that the author put
into that, that's all built into
the module.  Plus that module
can be fine-tuned with your
model.  So, if you have enough
examples, you
can potentially get better
performance if you use a
low-learning rate, if you set
the trainable parameter to true,
and
if you use the training version
of the graph.
So, NASNet is available in a
large size as well as a mobile
size module.  And then there's
also the new progressive NASNet.
And then a number of new
MobileNet modules for doing
on-device image classification,
as well as some industry
standard ones like Inception and
ResNet.  That list is at
TensorFlow.org/hub.  All those
modules are pre-trained using
the TFslim check points and
ready to be used for
classification or as feature
vector inputs to your own model.
Okay.  Let's look at another
example.  In this case, doing a
little bit of text
classification.
So, we'd like to know whether a
restaurant review is a positive
or negative sentiment.
So, as Jeremiah mentioned, one
of the
great things about TensorFlow
Hub is it packages the graph
with the data.  For our modules,
that means that all
Doing things like normalizing
and  tokennizing operations.
So, we can use a  pre-trained
sentence embedding module to map
a full sentence to an embedding
vector.  So, if we want to
classify some restaurant
reviews, then we just take one
of those sentence embedding
modules, we add our own
classification layer on top.
And then we train with our
reviews.  We keep the sentence
modules weight's fix weights
fixed.
And just like for the image
modules, TensorFlow.org/hub
lists a number of different text
modules.
We have neural network language
models
that are trained for English,
Japanese,
Spanish, we haveword2vec trained
on Wikipedia.
And EL MO that looks how words
are used across context.  And
something really new, today, you
may have seen a new paper this
morning from the team, this is
the universal sentence encoder.
It's a sentence-level training
module and enables a variety of
tasks, in other words,
universal.
Some of the things it's good
for,
semantic similarity, custom text
classification, clustering and
semantic seven.
search.  But the best thing is
how little training is required
to adapt to your problem.  That
sounds great in our particular
case.  Let's try it on the
restaurant review task.
So, we just paste that URL from
the
paper, and like before,
TensorFlow Hub downloads the
module and inserts it into your
graph.
But this time we're using the
text
embedding column to feed into a
classifier.  And this module can
be  fine-tuned with your model
by setting trainable to true.
Of course, you have to lower the
learning rate so that you don't
ruin the existing weights that
are in there, but it's something
worth  exploring if you have
enough data.  Now, let's take a
closer look at that URL.  As
Jeremiah mentioned, a module is
a program.  So, make sure what
you're executing is from a
location that you trust.
In this case, the module is from
tf.hub.dev.
That's our new news for
Google-provided modules like
NASNet and the encoder.  We
would like to make a place where
you can publish the modules that
you create.  In this case,
Google is the publisher.  And
universal sentencing encoder is
the name of the module.
And finally, the version number
is 1.
So, TensorFlow Hub considers
modules to be immutable.  That
way you don't have to worry
about the weights changing
between training sessions.
So, that module URL, and all of
the module URLs on tf.hub.dev
include a version number.
And you can take that URL and
paste it into your browser and
see the complete documentation
for any module that's hosted on
tf.hub .Dev.  Here's the
particular one for the universal
sentence encoder.  And then we
also have modules for other
domains besides text
classification and imagery
training, like a generative
image module that
contains a progressive GAN that
was trained on celeb A.
And another model based on deep
local
features network that can
identify landmark images.
Both have great co-lab notebooks
on  TensorFlow.org/hub.  The
images here were created from
them.  And we're adding more
modules over time for tasks like
audio and video over the next
few months.  But most
importantly, we're really
excited to see what you build
with TensorFlow Hub.
Use the hashtag t tfhub, and
visit TensorFlow.
org/hub for examples of
tutorials, interactive notebooks
and code labs and
our new discussion mailing list.
For everyone from our team in
Zurich, I want to thank you so
much.
[ Applause ]
Okay.
Next up, Clemens and Raz will
tell you about TensorFlow
Extended.
>> Thank you. Hello, everyone.
First, thanks, everyone, for
coming to the TensorFlow Dev
Summit.  And second, thanks for
staying around this long.  I
know it's been a long day and
there's a lot of information
that we have been throwing at
you.
But we have much, much more and
many more announce  wants.
Stick with me.  My name is
Clemenss, and this is Ras.
And we are going to talk about
TensorFlow Extended today.  I'm
going to do a quick survey.  How
many of you do machine learning
in a research or academic
setting?  Okay.  Quite a big
number.  And how many much you
do machine learning in a
production setting?  Okay.  That
looks about half/half.
Obviously, also, a lot of
overlap.  For those who do
machine learning in a production
setting, how many of you agree
with this statement?  Yeah?
Some?  Okay.  I see a lot of
hands coming up.  So, everyone
that I speak with who is doing
machine learning in production
agrees with this statement.
Doing machine learning
in production is hard.  And it's
too hard.
Because after all, we want to
democratize machine learning and
allow people to deploy machine
learning in their products.  One
of the reasons it's still hard
is
that in addition to the actual
machine learning, the small,
orange box where you use
TensorFlow, you may use Keras to
put the layers in the model, you
need to worry about so much
more.  There's all of these
other things you
need to learn about to actually
deploy machine learning in a
production setting and serve it
in your product.
This is exact my what TensorFlow
Extended is about.  It's a
Google machine learning platform
that allows the users to go from
data to a production serving
machine learning models as fast
as possible.
Now, before we introduced TFX,
we saw that going through this
process of writing some of these
components, some
of them didn't exist before,
glueing them together and
actually getting to a launch
took anywhere between six and
nine months,
sometimes even a year.
Once we deployed TFX and allowed
developers to use it, most can
use it and get up and running in
a day and get to a deployable
model in production in a matter
of weeks or just a month.
Now, TFX is a very large system
and
platform that consists consists
of of a lot of components and
services, so I can't talk about
it all in the next 25 minutes.
We can only cover a small part.
But talking about the things we
have open sourced and made
available to you.  First, we're
going to talk about TensorFlow
transform.  And how to apply
transformations on your data
consistently between training
and serving.  Next, Ras is going
to introduce you to
a new product that we are open
sourcing called TensorFlow model
analysis.  We're going to give a
demo of how all of this works
together end-to-end.  And then
we can make a broad announcement
for our plans for TensorFlow
Extended and sharing it with the
community.  So, let's jump into
TensorFlow transform first.  A
typical ML  pipeline that you
may see in the wild is during
training you do a -- you have a
distributed data pipeline that
applies transformations to your
data.  Because usually you train
on a large amount of data.  This
needs to be distributed.
And you run that  pipeline and
sometimes materialize the output
before you actually put it into
your trainer.
Now, at serving time, you need
to somehow replay those exact
transformations online.
As a new request comes in, it
needs to be sent to your model.
Now, there's a couple of
challenges with this.  The first
one is, usually those two things
are very different code paths,
right?  The data distribution
systems that you would use for
batch processing are very
different from the libraries and
tools that you would use to, in
real-time, transform data to
make a request to your are
model, right?
So, now, you have two different
code paths.
Second, in many cases, it's very
hard to keep those two in sync.
And I'm sure a
lot of you have seen this.  You
change your batch processing
pipeline and add a new feature
or change how it behaves.  And
you need to make sure that the
code in the production system is
changed at the same time and
kept in sync.  And the third
problem is, sometimes
you actually want to deploy your
TensorFlow machine learning
model in many different
environments.  So, you want to
deploy it on a mobile device, on
a server, maybe you want to put
it on a car.  Now suddenly you
have three different
environments where you want to
apply these transformations, and
maybe different languages for
those and it's very hard to keep
those in sync.  And this
introduces something that we
call training serveing skew, the
transformations at training time
might
be different than serving time,
which
leads to bad quality of your
serving model.
TensorFlow transform addresses
this by helping you write your
data processing log at training
time.  Help you create those
data pipelines
And at the same time, it emits a
TensorFlow graph that can be in
line with your  training and
serving model.
Now, what this does is, it
actually hermetically seals the
model.
And your model takes a raw data
request as input.  And all of
the transformations are actually
happening within the TensorFlow
graph.  Now, this is a lot of
advantages.  And one of them is
that you no longer
have any code in your serving
environment that does these
transformations, because they're
all being done in the TensorFlow
graph.  Another one is wherever
you deploy this TensorFlow
model, all of those
transformations are applied in a
consistent way, no matter where
this graph is being evaluated.
Let's see how that looks.  This
is a code snippet of a
pre-processing function that you
would write with tf.transform.
I'm going to walk you through
what happens here and what we
need to do for this.  So, the
first thing we do is normalize
this feature.  And as all
of you know, in order to
normalize a feature, we need to
compute the mean and the
standard deviation.
And to apply this
transformation, we need to
divide by the standard
deviation.  For the input
feature X, we have to compute
the statistics.
Which is a trivial task if the
data fits into a single machine.
You can do it easily.
It's a non-trivial task if you
have a gigantic training dataset
and you have to compute these
metrics effectively.  Once we
have these metrics, we can apply
this transformation to the
feature.  This is to show you
that the output of
this transformation can then be,
again,
multiplied with another tensor,
which is a regular TensorFlow
transformation.  And in order to
bucketize a  feature, you also,
again, need to compute the
bucket boundaries to actually
apply this transformation.  And,
again, this is a distributed
data job to compute those
metrics for the result of an
already-transformed feature.
This is another benefit.  To
then actually
apply this transformation
transformation.   The next
examples show you in the same
function you can apply any other
tensor and tensor route
function.  And there's also some
of what we call
"Mappers" itpers" in tf .
transform that we don't have to
run a data pipeline to compute
anything.
Now, what happens is the orange
boxes are what we call
analyzers.  We realize those as
actual data pipelines to compute
over your data.
They're implemented using Apache
Beam.  We can talk about this
more later.  But this allows us
to actually run this distributed
data pipeline in different
environments.  There's different
runners for Apache Beam.  And
all of the transforms are just
single instance-to-instance
transformations using pure
TensorFlow code.  And what
happens when you run
TensorFlow transform is that we
actually
run these analyze phases,
compute the results of the
analyze phases, and inject the
result as a constant in the
TensorFlow graph.  So, this is
on the right.  And in this graph
is a hermetic TensorFlow graph
that  applies all of the
transformations.  And it can be
inlined in your serving graph.
Now your serving graph has the
transform graph as part of it
and can play through these
transforms wherever you want to
deploy this TensorFlow model.
So, what can be done with
TensorFlow Transform?  At
training time, for the batch
processing, really anything that
you can do with a distributed
data pipeline.  So, there's a
lot of flexibility here, what
types of statistics you can
compute.  We provide a lot of
utility functions for you.
But you can also write custom
data pipelines.  And at serving
time, because we generate a
TensorFlow graph that applies
these transformations, we have
limited to what you can do with
the TensorFlow graph.  But for
all of you in TensorFlow,
there's a lot of flexibility in
there as well.
And so anything that you can do
in a
TensorFlow graph you can do with
tf.transformations.   So, some
of the common use cases, the
ones
on the left I just spoke about.
You can scale and continue value
to the core.  A value between
zero and one.
You can bucketize a continuous
value.  If you have text, you
can apply a bag of words or
N-grams.  Or for future crosses,
you can cross
those strings and then generate
the result of those crosses.
And as mentioned before, the
transformer is extremely
powerful in being able to chain
look at these transforms.  You
can apply transform on the
result of a transform as well.
And another particularly
interesting transform is
applying another TensorFlow
model.  You have heard about the
safe model before.  If you have
a safe model that you can apply
as a transformation, you can use
this it f.transform.
You want to apply an Inception
model and combine it with
another feature or
use it as an input feature to
the model.  You can use any
TensorFlow model
that's in line in had your graph
and in your serving graph.  So,
all of this is available today.
And you can go check it out on
GitHub at  TensorFlow/transform.
I'm going to hand it over to Ras
who is going to talk about
TensorFlow model analysis.
>> All right, thanks, Clemens.
Hi, everyone.
I'm really excited to talk about
TensorFlow model analysis today.
We're going to talk little bit
about metrics.  Let's see.  Next
slide.  All right.  So, we can
already get metrics today,
right?  We use TensorBoard.
TensorBoard's awesome.
You saw an earlier presentation
today boutons.  It's a great
tool.  While you're training you
can watch your metrics, right?
And if you're training isn't
going well, you can save
yourself a couple of hours of
your life, right?  Terminate the
training, fix some things.  But
let's say you have a trained
model already.  Are we done with
metrics?  Is that it?  Is there
anymore to be said about metrics
when we're done training well?
Of course there is.  We want to
know how well our trained model
actually does for our target
population.  Right?  And I would
argue that we want to do this in
a distributed fashion over the
entire dataset.  Now, why
wouldn't we just sample?  Why
wouldn't we just save more
hours of hour lives, right?
Just sample, make things fast
and easy, right?  Start with a
large dataset.  You're going to
slice that dataset.  I'm going
to look at people at noon.
Noontime, right?  That's a
feature.  From Chicago.  My
hometown.  Okay?   Running on
this particular device.
Well, each of these slices
reduced the
size of your evaluation dataset
by a factor, right?  This is an
exponential decline.  By the
time you're looking at the
experience for a particular, you
know, set of users, you're not
left with very much data, right?
And the error bars on your
performance measures, they're
huge.  I mean, how do you know
that the noise doesn't exceed
your signal by that point,
right?   So, really, you want to
start with your larger  dataset
before you start sliceing.  All
right.  So, let's talk about a
particular metric.  I'm not sure
if, you know, who has heard of
the ROC Curve?
It's kind of an unknown thing in
machine learning these days.
Okay.  So, we have our ROC
Curve.  And I'm going to talk
about a concept that you may or
may not be familiar with, which
is ML fairness.  Okay.
What is father fairness?
Fairness is a complicated topic.
Fairness is basically how well
does our machine learning model
do for
different segments of our
population?
You don't have one ROC Curve,
you have
an ROC Curve for everybody
segment and group of  users.
Who here would run their
business based on their top line
metrics?  No one, right?  That's
crazy.
You have to slice your metric
metric.
You have to dive in and find out
how things are going.
That lucky user, black curve on
the top, great  experience.
The unlucky user, the blue
curve, not such a great
experience.
So, when can our models be
unfair to various users, okay?
Well, one instance is if you
simply don't have a lot of data
from where which to draw your
inferences, right?
So, we use  tochiastic
optimizers, and if we retrain
the model, it does something
slightly
different every time.  And you
get high variance for some users
because you don't have a lot of
data there.  We have been
incorporating data from a lot of
data sources.  Some data sources
are more biased than others.
Some  users get the sort end of
the deal.  Other users get the
ideal experience.  Our labels
could be wrong, right?  All of
these things can happen.  And
here's TensorFlow model
analysis.  You're looking here
at the UI hosted within a
Jupiter notebook.  On the X axis
we have our loss.  And you can
see there's some natural
variance in the metrics, you
know?  And we're not always
going to get spot on the same
precision and recall for every
segment of  population.  But
sometimes you'll see, you know,
what about those guys at the top
there?  Experiencing the highest
amount of loss.  Do they have
something in common?  We want to
know this.
Sometimes our -- our users that
are our most -- that get the
poorest experience, they're
sometimes our most vocal users,
right?  We all know this.
I'd like to invite you to come
visit ml-fairness.com.  There's
a deep literature about the
mathematical side of ML
Fairness.
Once you have figureed out
thousand measure fairness.
How does TensorFlow model
analysis give you the sliced
metrics?
How do you go about getting the
metrics?  Today, a saved model
for serving.  That's a familiar
thing.
TensorFlow model analysis is
simple -- is similar.
You export a saved model for
evaluation.  Why are these
models different?  Why export
two?
Well, the eval graph that we
serialized as a save model has
some additional annotations that
allow our evaluation batch job
to find the features, to find
the prediction, to find the
label.  And we don't want those
things, you know, mixed in with
our  serving graph.  So, we
export a second one.  So, this
is the GitHub.  We just opened
it I think last night at 4:30
p.m.  Check it out.  We have
been  using it internally for
quite some time now.  Now it's
available externally as well.
The GitHub has an example that
kind of puts it all together.
So, that you can try all these
components that we're talking
about from your local machine.
You don't have to get an account
anywhere.  You just get  cloned
and run the scripts and run the
code lab.  This is the Chicago
taxi example.
So, we're using public data from
-- publicly-had available data
to determine
which riders will tip their
driver and
which riders, shall we say,
don't have
enough money to tiptoed tip
today, right?  What does
fairness mean in this context?
So, our model is going to make
some predictions.  We may want
to slice these predictions by
time of day.  During rush hour,
we're going to have a lot of
data.  So, hopefully, our model
is going to be fair if that data
is not biased.  At the very
least, it's not going to have a
lot of  variance.  But how is it
going to do at 4 a.m. in the
morning?  Maybe not so well.
How is it going to do when the
bars
close?  An interesting question.
I don't know yet.  But I
challenge you to find out.  All
right.  So, this is what you can
run using your local scripts.
We start with our raw data.  We
run the tf.transform.  The tf.
transform emits a transform
function and our transform
examples.  We train our model.
Our model, again, emits two
saved
models, one for serving and one
for eval.  You can try this
locally.  Run scripts and play
with this stuff.
Clemens talked a little bit
about transform.
We want to take our dense
features and scale them to a
particular Z-score.  We don't
want to do that batch by batch.
The mean for each batch is going
to differ, may be fluctuations.
We want to normalize these
things
across the entire dataset.
We've built a vocabulary, we
bucket for the wide part of our
model, and we emit our transform
function, and into the trainer
we go, right?
You heard earlier today about tf
estimators.  And here is a wide
and deep estimator that takes
our transform
features and emits two save
models.  And now we're in
TensorFlow model analysis which
reads in the save model.  And
runs it against all of the raw
data.  We call render slicing
metrics from the Jupiter
notebook.  And you see the UI.
And the thing to notice here is
that
this UI  is immersive, right?
It's not just a static picture
that you can look at and go,
huh, and walk away from.  It
lets you see your errors broken
down by bucket or broken down by
feature.  And it lets you drill
in and ask
questions and be curious about
how your models are actually
treating various subsets of your
population.
Those subsets may be the
lucrative subsets.  Right?  You
really want to drill in.  And
then you want to serve your
model.
So, our demo, our example, has a
one-liner here that you can run
to serve your model.
And make a client request.
The thing to notice here is
we're mic making a GRPC request
to that server.
We're takeing our feature
tensors,
sending them to the server, and
back
comes probability, right?
That's not quite enough.  We
have heard a little bit of
feedback about this server.  And
the thing we have heard is that
GRPC is cool, but Rust is really
cool.
.  But  REST is really cool.  I
tried.  This is one of the top
feature
requests on GitHub for model
serveing.
You can now pack your tensors
into a JSON object.  Send that
JSON object to the server
and get a response back via
HTTP.  Much more convenient.
And I'm very excited to say that
it will be released very soon.
Very soon.
I see the excitement out there.
Back to the end-to-end.  So,
yeah.
So, you can try all of these
pieces, end-to-end, all on your
local machine.
Because they're using Apache
Beam director rinser.  And
direct runners allow you to take
your distributed job and run
them all locally.
If you swap in Apache Beam's
Dataflow runner, you can run
against the entire dataset in
the cloud.  The example also
shows you how to run the big job
against the cloud version as
well.
We're currently working with the
community to develop a runner
for Apache Flink, a runner for
Spark.  Stay tuned to the
TensorFlow blog and to our
GitHub.
And you can find the example at
TensorFlow/model-analysis.  And
back to Clemens.
>> Thank you, Ras.
[ Applause ]
All right.
We have heard about transform
and how to use model analysis
and how to serve them.  You say
you want more.  Is that enough?
You want more?  All right.  You
want more.
And I can think of why you want
more.
Maybe you read the paper we
published
and presented last year about
TensorFlow expended.  We laid
out a broad vision of how this
platform works within Google and
the
features and impact we have
using it.  And that figure one,
which allows these boxes and
described what
TensorFlow extrovert Extended.
It's overly simplified, but much
more than today.  We spoke about
these four components of
TensorFlow Extended.
This is not yet an end-to-end
machine learning platform.
This is just a very small piece.
These are the libraryies we have
open sourced for you to use, but
we haven't yet released the
entire platform.  We are working
hard on this.  We have seen the
profound impact it had
internally.  How people could
start using this platform and
deploying
machine learning in production
using TFX.  And we are working
hard to make more
of those come don'ts components
available to you.  And we are
looking at the data components
and you can analyze the data,
visualize the distributions and
detect anomalies.  That's an
important part of any machine
learning pipeline.  To detect
changes and shifts in your data
and anomalies.
After this, looking at the
horizontal
pieces that help tie all of
these components together.  If
they're all single  libraries,
you have to get them together.
You have to use them
individually.  They have
well-defined interfaces, but you
have to combine them by
yourself.  Internally, we have
the shared configuration
framework that allows you to
configure the entire pipeline.
And the nice thing on the front
end, allows you to monitor the
status of these pipelines and
see progress and inspect the
different artifacts that have
been produced by all of the
components.  So, this
is something we're also  looking
to release later this year.  And
I think you get the idea.
Eventual we want to make all of
this available to the community.
Because internally, hundreds of
teams use this to improve our
products.
We really believe that this will
be as transformative to the
community as it is at Google.
And we're working very hard to
release
these technologies in the
platform to see what you can do
with them in your products and
companies.
Keep watching the TensorFlow
blogs for our future plans.
And as mentioned, you can use
some
today, transform is released,
model-analysis yesterday,
serving is released.
And the end to end example is
available under this link.  You
can find it under the model
analysis repo.  Thank you from
myself and Ras.  I'm going to
ask you to join me in welcoming
a special external guest,
Patrick Brandt, joining us from
Coca-Cola who is going to talk
about applied AI at Coca-Cola.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hey, great job. Thanks,
Clemens.  All  right.  So, yes,
I'm Patrick.
I'm a solutions strategyist for
Coca-Cola.  I'm going to share
with you how we're using
TensorFlow to support some of
our
large largest and most popular
digital marketing programs in
North America.  We are going off
on a marketing tangent before we
come back.  As background, what
is proof of purchase and the
relationship to marketing?  As
an example, back in the day,
folks could clip the bar codes
off their cereal boxes and mail
the bar codes back into the
cereal company to receive a
reward.  Some kind of coupon or
prize back through the mail.
And this is basic loyalty
marketing.  Brands, in this
case, the cereal company,
rewarding consumers who
purchase.  And at the same time,
opening up a line of
communication between the brand
and the consumer.
Now, over the last 15-some odd
years
of marketing digitization, this
concept has evolved into digital
engagement marketing.
Consumers in the moment in
real-time
through web and mobile channels.
But proof of purchase is still
an important component of the
experience.
We have an active digital
marketing
program at Coca-Cola.
They can earn a magazine sub
corruption or the chance to
subscription
or a chance to win.
We printed these 14-character
product Pincodes.
And these are what our consumers
enter into our promotions.  You
can enter them in by hand.  But
on your mobile device, you can
scan them.  This had been the
holy grail of
marketing IT at Coke for a long
time.  We looked at commercial
and open source optical
character recognition
software, OCR, but it could
never read these codes very
well.  And the problem has to do
with the code.
These are 4x7,
dot-matrix-printed.
The printer head is an inch
under the cap, and they are
flying under the printer at a
rapid rate.
Creates visual artifacts, things
that normal OCR can't handle
well.  We knew if we wanted to
unlock this experience, we were
going to have to build something
from scratch.  When I look at
these codes, a couple of
characteristics jump out at me.
We're using a small alphabet.
Let's say ten characters.
And there's a decedent amount of
variability in the presentation
of these characters.
This reminds me of MNIST, the
online database of 60,000
handwritten digital images.
And convolutional neural
networks,
extremely good at extracting the
text.
I'm probably going to tell you
something you know, they work by
breaking it down into smaller
pieces and looking for edges and
textures and colors.
And these very granular feature
activations are pooled up,
often, into a more general
feature layer.  And then that's
filtered.  And those activations
are pulled up and so on until
the output of the neural net is
run through a function which
creates a probability
distribution of the likelihood
that a set of objects
exists within the image.
But they had a nice property,
handleing the nature of images
well.  From our perspective,
they can handle
the tilt and twist of a bottle
cap held in someone's hand.
It's perfect.  So, this is what
we're going to use.  We're going
to move forward.
Now we need to build our
platform.  That begins with
training.  The  beating heart of
any applied AI solution.  And we
knew we needed high quality
images with accurate labels of
the codes
and we likely needed a lot of
them.
We started with a synthetic
dataset of
random strings over blank images
and superimposed over blank
backgrounds.  This was a base
for transfer learning once we
created our real-world data set.
We did a production run of caps
and fridge packs and
distributing those to
multiple third-party  displayers
along
with custom tools to scan the
cap and label it with the pin
Code.  But an important
component was an existing
pincode validation service we
have had in production for a
long time to support our
programs.  So, any time a
trainer labeled an image, we
would send that label through
our validation service, if it
was a valid pincode, we knew we
had an accurate label.  This
gets the model trained and now
we need to release it to the
wild.  We had some aggressive
performance requirements.
We wanted 1 second average
processing time.  95% accuracy
at launch.  And host the model
remotely, for the web, and embed
it natively on mobile devices to
support mobile apps.  So, this
means that our model has to be
small.
Small enough to support over the
air updates as the model
improves over time.  And to help
us improve that model over time,
we created an active learning
UI, a user interface, that
allows our consumers to train
the model once it's in
production.  And that's what
this looks  like.
So, if I was a consumer, scan a
cap,
and the model cannot infer a
valid pincode, it sends a
per-character
confidence of every character at
every position.  It can render a
screen like what you see here.
I, as a user, am only directed
to address the particularly
low-confidence characters.  I
see the
characters, tap the red ones,
bring up the keyboard, I tap
them, entered into the
promotion.  It's a good user
experience for me.
I scan a code and I'm only a few
taps
away from being entered into a
promotion.  But we have
extremely valuable data for
training.  Because we have the
image that created
the invalid difference as well
as the user-corrected label they
needed to correct to get into
the promotion.  We can throw
this into the hopper for future
rounds of training to improve
the model.  All right.  When you
put it all together, this is
what it looks like.
User takes a picture of a cap,
the
image is  normalized, then sent
into our confident model.   The
output of which is a character
probability matrix.
This is the per-character
competence of every character at
every position.  That is further
analyzed to create a top ten
prediction.  Each one of those
are fed into our pincode
validation  service.  The first
one that's valid, often the
first one on the list, is
entered into the  promotion.
And if none are valid, our user
sees the active learning
experience.  So, our model
development effort went through
three big  iterations.  In an
effort to keep the model size
small up front, the data team
used
binary
binary  normalization and it
didn't
produce enough data to get the
model.  They switched and the
model size was
too large to support over the
air updates.  They start over.
They just completely rearchitect
the net using SqueezeNet,
designed to reduce the size by
reducing the number of learnable
parameters within the model.
After making this move, we had a
problem.
We started to experience
internal  co-variant shift, the
result of reducing the number of
learnable parameters.
That means that very small
changes to upstream parameter
values cascaded to
huge gyrations in downstream
parameter values.  This slowed
our training process.
We had to grind through this
co-variant shift to get the
model to
converge, if it would converge
at all.  We  introduced batch
normalization, which sped up
training.  It got the model to
converge.  And now we're exactly
where we want to be.
We have a model, a 25 fold
decrease where we started with
accuracy greater than 95%.  And
the results are impressive.
These are some screen grabs from
a test site that I built.  And
you can see across the top row
how the model handled different
types of occlusion.  It handles
translation, tilting the cap,
rotation, twisting the cap.  And
camera focus issues.  So, you
can try this out for yourself.
I'm going to pitch the
newly-launched Coca-Cola USA
app.
It hit Android and iPhone app
stores a couple days ago.  It
does many things, and you can
scan a code.  You can go on with
the mobile browser, take a
picture of a cap code to be
entered into a promotion.  Quick
shoutouts.
I can't not mention these folks.
Quantiphi built our model.
Ellen Duncan,  spearheaded this
from the
marketing side.
And my people in IT, my
colleague,
Andy Donaldson,  shepherded this
into production.  Thank you.
It's been a privilege to speak
with you.
I covered a lot of ground in ten
short minutes.
There's a lot of stuff I didn't
talk about.  Please feel free to
reach out on
Twitter,@patrickbrandt.  And
wpb.
is wpb.is/linkedin.  You can
read an article I  published
last year on this solution, on
the Google developers
>> AUDIENCE: .
And you can get there at wpb.
wpb.is/tensorFlow.  Thank you.
Next up is Alex.
And Alex is going to talk to us
about applied ML with robotics.
[ Applause ]
>> All right. Hi, everybody.
I'm Alex from the brain robotics
team.  And in this presentation
I'll be
talking about how we use
simulation and adaptation in
some of our real-world robot
learning problems.
So, first, let me start by
introducing robot learning.  The
goal of robot learning is to use
machine learning to learn
robotic skills that work in
general environments.  What we
have seen so far is that if you
control your environment a lot,
you can get robots to do pretty
impressive things.
And where the techniques break
down
is when you try to apply these
same techniques to more general
environments.  And the thinking
is if you use machine learning,
this can help learn from the
environment and address the
generalization issues.  So, as a
step in this direction, we have
been  looking at the problem of
robotic grasping.  This is a
project we have been working on
in collaboration with people at
X.
And to explain the product a
bit, we have the real robot arm
learning to pick
up objects out of a bin.  There
is going to be a camera looking
down over the shoulder of the
arm into the bin.
And from this RGB image, we're
going to train a neural network
to learn what commands it should
send to the robot to
successfully pick up objects.
Now, we to want try to solve
this task using as few
assumptions as possible.  So,
importantly, we're not going to
give any information about the
geometry
of what kinds of objects we're
going pick up.  And no
information about the depth of
the scene.  So, in order to
solve the task, the
model needs to learn hand-eye
coordination or see where it is
in the camera image and then
figure out where in the seam it
is and then combine these two to
figure out how it can move
around.
Now, in order to train this
model, we're going to need a lot
of data because it's a pretty
large-scale image model.  And
our solution at the time for
this was to simply use more
robots.
So this is what we called the
arm farm.  These are six robots
collecting data in parallel.
And if you have six robots, you
can collect data a lot faster
than if you only have one robot.
So,  using these robots, we were
able to collect over a million
attempted
grasps over a million total of
robot hours.  And we were able
to successfully train models to
pick up objects.
Now, this works, but it still
took a lot of time to collect
this dataset.  This motivated
looking into ways to reduce the
amount of real-world data needed
to learn these behaviors.  One
approach for doing this is
simulation.  So, in the left
video here, you can see the
images that are going into our
model in our  real-world setup.
And on the right here you can
see our simulated recreation of
that setup.  Now, the advantage
of moving things into
simulation, is that simulated
robots are easier to scale.  We
have been able to spin up
thousands
of simulateed robots  grasping
various objects.  And we were
able to collect millions of
grasps in just over eight hours
instead of the weeks that were
required for the original
dataset.  Now, this is good for
getting a lot of data, but
unfortunately, models trained in
simulation tend not to transfer
to the actual  real-world robot.
There are a lot of systemic
differences between the two.
One big one is the visual
appearancens of different
things.
And another big one is just
physical
differences between our
real-world physics and our
simulated physics.   What we did
was we were able to train a
model in simulation to get to
around 90% grasp success.  We
then deployed to the real robot
and it succeeds just over 20% of
the time, which is a very big
performance drop.  So, in order
to get good performance, you
need to do something a bit more
clever.
This motivated looking into
similar-to-real transfer, using
simulate the data to improve
your real-world sample
efficiency.  Now, there are a
few different ways you can do
this.
One way is adding randomization
into the simulator.  You can
change
around the textures you apply to
objects, changing their colors,
changing how lighting is
interacting with your scene.
And you can play around with
changing the geometry of what
kinds of objects you're trying
to pick up.  Another way of
doing this is the main
adaptation.
Which is a set of  techniques
for
learning when rough you have two
domains of data that have
structure but are different.
The two domains are the
simulated and real robot data.
And there are feature-level and
pixel-level ways of doing this.
In this work, we tried all of
these approaches.  And I'm going
to focus primary on the domain
adaptation side of things.
So, in  feature-level domain
adaptation, what we're going to
do is take our simulated data,
take our real data, train the
same model on both datasets.
But then
at an intermediate feature
layer, a similarity loss.
That's going to make the
distribution of features to be
the same across both
domains.
One approach for doing this is
domain adversarial networks.
This is implemented as a small
neural net that tries to predict
the domain based on the
interview questions put
features, and the rest of the
model is trying to confuse the
domain classifier as much as
possible.
Now pixel methods look at it
from a different point of view.
Instead of features, we're going
to
transform at the pixel level to
look for realistic.
We take a general adversarial
network.  We feed it an image
from our simulator.  It's going
to output an image that looks
more realistic.
And then we're going to use the
generator to train whatever task
model that we want to train.
Now, we're going to train both
the generator and the task model
at the same time.  We found that
in practice this was useful
because it helps ground the
generator output to be useful
for training your downstream
task.  All right.  So, taking a
step back.
Feature-level methods can learn
domain-invariant features when
you
have data from related domains
that aren't  identical.
Meanwhile, pixel-level methods
can transform your data to look
more like your  real-world data,
but in practice, they don't work
perfectly and there's small
artifacts and  inaccuracieses
from
generateor
output.
You can use both methods.  Not
getting all the way there, but
attach a feature-level to close
the reality gap.
And combine what we call the
grasp, a
combination of pixel-level and
feature-level.  In the left half
of the video, a simulated grasp.
In the right half, the output of
the generator.  You can see it's
learning cool things in terms of
drawing what the tray should
look like.  Drawing more
realistic textures on the arm.
Drawing shadows.  It's learned
how to draw shadows as the arm
is moving around in the scene.
It's not perfect.  There are
still odd splotches of color
around, but it's definitely
learning something about what it
means for an image to
look for realistic.  Now, this
is good for  getting a lot of
pretty images, but what matters
for our problem is whether these
images are actually useful for
reducing the amount of
real-world data required.  And
we find that it does.  So, to
explain this chart a bit, on
the X axis is the number of
real-world samples used.
And we compared the performance
of different methods as we vary
the amount of real-world data
given to the model.  The blue
bar is the performance with only
simulated data.
The red bar is the performance
when we use only real data, and
the orange bar is the
performance when we use both
simulated and real data and the
domain adaptation methods I have
been talking about.
When we use just 2% of the
original real world data set,
we're able to get the same level
of performance.  This reduces
the number of real-world samples
we needed by up to 50 times,
which is really exciting in
terms of not needing to run
robots for a long amount of time
to learn these grasping
behaviors.  Additionally, we
found that even when we give all
of the real-world data to the
model, when we give simulated
data as well, we're still able
to see improved performance.
So, that implies that we haven't
hit data capacity limits for
this grasping problem.  And
finally, there's a way to train
this setup without having
real-world  labels.
And when we train the model in
this  setsing, we found that we
were still able to get pretty
good performance on the
real-world robot.
Now, this was a work of a large
team across both brain as well
as X.  I would like to thank all
of my collaborators.  Here is a
link to the original  paper.
And I believe there is also a
blog post if people are
interested in hearing more
details.  Thanks.
[ Applause ]
All right.  And lastly, we have
Sherol who is going to talk to
you about art and music with
machine learning.
>> Amazing. Just amazing.
It's really just in awe of what
machine learning is capable of
and how we can extend human
capabilities.
And we want to think more than
just about, you know,
discovering new approaches and
new ways of using the
technology.  We to want see how
it's being used how
it impacts the human creative
process.
So, imagine you need to find or
compose a drum pattern.
You have some idea of -- of a
drum beat that you would like to
compose.
And all you need to do now is go
to a website where there's a
pre-trained
model of drum patterns sitting
on the online.  You just need a
web browser.  You give it some
human input and you can generate
a space of expressive
variations.  You can tune and
control the type of outputs that
you're getting from this
generative model.  And if you
don't like it, you can continue
going through it exploring this
generative space.  So, this is
the type of work that project
Magenta focuses on.
To give you a bird's eye view of
what Project
Magenta is about, it  basically
is a group of researchers and
developers and creative
technologists that engage in
generative models research.
So, you'll see this work pub u
pub
lushed published at machine
learning conferences, a lot of
research contributions from
Magenta.  And you'll see the
code, after it's been published,
put into open source
repository on GitHub in the
Magenta repo.  And from there,
we'll see ways of thinking and
designing creative tools
that can enhance and extend
human expressive creative
process.
And eventually ending up into
the hands of artists and
musicians.  Inventing new ways
we can create.  And inventing
new types of artists.
So, I'm going to give three
brief overviews of the
highlights of some of our recent
work.
So, this is performance RNN.
How many have seen this?  This
is one of the demos earlier
today.  A lot of people have
seen and heard of
this kind of work.  This is what
people think of as a generative
model.  How can we build a
computer that has the kind of
intuition
to know the qualities of
melody and harmony and
expressing dynamics.  It's more
interesting to explore this in
the browser enabled by
TensorFlow.js.  This is a demo
we have running online.  We have
the ability to tune and control
some of the output that we're
getting.  So, in a second, I'm
going to show you this video of
what that looks like.  You would
have seen it out on the demo
floor.  But we'll show you, and
all of you watching online.  We
were able to bring it even more
alive by connecting a baby grand
piano
that is also a midi controller
and we have the ability to
perform alongside the generative
model, reading in the inputs
from the human playing the
piano.
So, let's take a look.
So, this is trained on classical
music data from actual live
performers.
This is from a dataset that we
got
from a piano competition.
[piano playing] -- I don't know
if
you noticed, this is Nikhil from
earlier today.  He's a talented
young man.  He
helped build out the browser
version.
[piano playing] and so, we're
thinking of ways that we take
bodies of
work, we train a model off of
the data, then we create these
open source tools
that enable new forms of
interaction, of creativity and
of expression.  And this is all
these points of engagement are
enabled by TensorFlow.  The next
tool I want to talk about that
we have been working on is the
variational autoencoders.  How
many people are familiar with
latent space interpolation?
Quite a few of you.  If you're
not, it's quite simple.  You
take human inputs and you train
it through a neural network,
compressing it down to an
embedding space.  You compress
it down to some dimensionality
and then you reconstruct it.
So, you're comparing the
reconstruction with the
original.  And trying to train
-- build a space around that.
And what that does, is that
creates the ability to
interpolate from one point to
another, touching on the
intermediate points where human
may have not
given input.
So, the machine learning model
may have never seen an example
it's able to generate.  It's
building an intuition off of
these examples.  You can imagine
if you're an animator, there's
so many ways of going from cat
to pig.  How would you animate
that?  There's an intuition the
artist would have in creating
that sort of morphing from one
to the other.  We're able to
have the machine learning model
also do this now.  We can also
do this with sound, right?  This
technology actually carries over
to multiple domains.  So, this
is NSynth.
And we've released this I think
sometime last year.  And what it
does, it takes that same idea of
moving one input to another.
Let's take a look.  You'll get a
sense of it.
Piccolo to electric guitar
.  [sound moving back and forth]
-- so, rather than recompose, or
fading from one sound to the
other, what we're actually able
to do is we're able to
find these intermediary,
recomposed sound samples and
produce that.  So, it looks, you
know, there's a lot of
components to
that, there's a wave net
decoder.  But really it's the
same technology
underlying the encoder, decoder.
When we think about the types of
tools that musicians use, we
think less about  training
machine learning models.  We
think about drum pedals.  Not
drum pedals.  Guitar pedals.
They are used to refine sound to
cultivate the art and flavor the
musician is looking for.  We
don't think about parameter
flags
or trying to write lines of
Python code to create the sort
of art, you know, in general.
So, what we've done, not just
are we interested in finding and
discovering new things, we're
also interested in how those
things get used in general.
Used by practitioners.  Used by
specialists.  And so, we've
created a hardware.  We've taken
the piece of hardware.  We have
taken the machine learning model
and put it into a box where a
musician can plug in and explore
this latent space and
performance.  Let's look at what
musicians feel
and what thing in this process.
[synth music]
>> It feels like we're turning a
new corner of new possibilities.
It could generate a sound that
might inspire us.
>> The fun part is you think you
know what you're doing, there's
a weird interaction happening
that could give you something
totally unexpected.
>> I mean, it's great research,
and it's
really fun and it's amazing to
discover new things, but even
more amazing to see how it gets
used how people think to create
alongside it.  And so, what's
even better is it's just
released.  And in collaboration
with the creative lab London.
NSynth super.  It's open source.
All the specs are on GitHub.
We talk about potential to the
touch, and the code and what
hardware it's running on.  This
is all available to everyone
today.  You can go online and
check it out yourself.  Now,
music is more than just sound,
right?  It's actually a sequence
of things that goes on.
So, when we think about the --
this
idea of what it needs to have a
generative music space, we think
also about melodies.  And so,
just like we have cat to pig,
what is it like to go from one
melody to the next?
And moreover, once we have that
technology, how does it -- what
does it look like to create with
that?  You have this expressive
space of variations.  How
do we design an expressive tool
that takes advantage of it?  And
what will we get out of it?
This is another tool that's
developed by another team at
Google to make use of melodies
in a latent space.
How interpolation works and then
building a song or a composition
with it.  Take a listen.
Say you have two melodies.
[twinkle, twinkle little star
--]
And the middle.
[melody is morphing]
And extended.
[melody
is becomeing more complex]
And we really are just
scratching the surface of what's
possible.  How do we continue to
have the machine learn and have
a better intuition for what
melodies are about?  So, again,
to bring it back full
circle, we have, using different
compositions and musical works,
we're
able to train a variational
autoencoder to create an
embedding space that builds
tools that enable open source
communities to design creative
artist tools.  To look at new
ways of  pushing the expressive
boundaries that we currently
have.  This is, again, just
released.  It's on our blog.
All the code is open source.
And made available to you.  And
also enabled by TensorFlow.  In
addition to all these other
things,
including Nikhil, here enabled
by the type of work and
creativity and expressivity.
And so, in wrapping  up, I want
to take us back to this demo
that we saw.  Now, the most
interesting and maybe the
coolest thing about this demo
was that we didn't even know
that it was being built until
it was Tweeted by T Tero, a
developer from Finland.  And the
fact of the matter is, this just
-- we're barely scratching the
surface.  There's so much to do,
so much to engage in and so much
to discover.  And we want to see
so much more of this.  We want
to see more developers, more
people sharing things and more
people getting engaged.  Not
just developers, but artists and
creatives as well.  We to want
explore and invent and imagine
what we can do with machine
learning together as an
expressive tool.
And so, go to our website, g.
co/magenta, you'll find our
publications and these demos.
You can experience it yourself
and more.
And you can also join our
discussion group.  So, here's g.
co/magenta.  Join our discussion
group.  Become part of the
community and share the things
that you're building so we can
do this alongside together.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
So, that's it for the talks
today.  We've had an amazing,
amazing show.  Amazing spread of
speakers and topics.  Now let's
take a look at a highlight
review of the day.
[Music playing]
>> Earlier this year, we hit the
milestone of 11 million
downloads.
We are reallied really excited
to see how much users are using
this and the impact in fact
world.
>> We're very excited today to
announce
that we are joining the
TensorFlow
family, deeplearn .js.
>> TensorFlow is an early stage
project,
we would like you to help build
this future.
>> I told you at the beginning,
the mission for tf.data was to
make a library that was fast,
flexible and easy to use.
>> So, I'm very excited to say
that we have been working with
other teams in Google to bring
TensorFlow Lite to Google apps.
>> In general, the Google brain
team's
mission is to make machines
intelligent and use that ability
to improve people's lives.
I think that's good examples of
where there's real opportunity
for this.
[ Applause ]
>> So, hold on just a minute.